Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Warst du schon wieder in Europa?
Nein, aber zuletzt in Frankfurt.
Sehr gut, das stimmt, du warst in Frankfurt.
In Fedora, einer recht unbekannten, aber hervorragend inszenierten und grandios musizierten, gesungenen Oper in Frankfurt und es war wunderbar. Ich saß inmitten von 80-Jährigen, ganz vorn und das war großartig, weil die sich unterhielten darüber, dass sie so glücklich sind, keine Maske mehr zu tragen und sie sagten auch, wir haben ja für die ganzen ausgefallenen Vorstellungen Gutscheine bekommen. Und dann sagte aber ein Herr, ja ich bin 82, wenn ich so weitermache, dann kann ich die Gutscheine vererben. Ich bin froh, dass es jetzt wieder losgeht. Und es war einfach sehr beruhigend, die Gelassenheit der älteren Menschen dort zu sehen und die Freude auch daran, wieder etwas zu erleben. Und ich bin doch auch ein bisschen entsetzt, wie leer die Konzerthäuser, Opernhäuser und so weiter zum größten Teil noch sind. Also viele Leute scheuen es offenbar nach wie vor, sich jetzt wieder der Kultur hinzugeben. Sicherlich sind andere Prioritäten wichtiger vielleicht. Aber ich glaube, es gibt auch immer noch so eine gewisse Angst vor dem geschlossenen Raum. Und ich kann nur sagen, es ist wunderbar, wieder zum Beispiel Musik in Präsenz zu erleben. Ich freue mich schon. In Frankfurt werde ich mir auch noch Madame Butterfly dann bald ansehen. Und es ist sicherlich etwas, auf das man niemals verzichten sollte und sich jetzt wirklich... Man muss aus dieser permanenten Angst oder aus dieser mit der Angst einhergehenden Bequemlichkeit, die sich dann eingestellt hat, heraus und wieder Dinge erleben.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass die ganzen Zehner ja schon da waren. Also diese Ostukraine ist umkämpftes Gebiet und diese Switchblade drohen, also die trägt man im Rucksack. Dann packt man die einfach aus, schießt die ab und dann hat man 15 Minuten selbst angeflogene Ziele, kann sich nochmal abbrechen und sich nochmal ein neues Ziel suchen und so. Also wir haben es ja, finde ich, und der Economist spricht so von Baguette-Größe, mit echten schweren Waffen zu tun, die da einfach jetzt zum Alltag gehören werden über viele, viele Jahre.
Ja, wir hören jetzt einen Clip von Georg Stefan Troller. Er ist 100 Jahre alt geworden, hat also den Zweiten Weltkrieg miterlebt, hat deutsche Soldaten dann hier gefragt, er ist ein Jude aus Wien, ist dann emigriert, ist dann mit den Amerikanern zurückgekommen, hat deutsche Soldaten befragt nach dem, was sie getan haben. Die Heimat Wien ist immer in seinem Herzen geblieben, aber nie ist er wirklich dahin zurückgekehrt auf Dauer, auch wenn er jetzt mit 100 die österreichische Staatsbürgerschaft auch noch bekommen hat, aber er lebt in Paris. Troller ist Autor, ist Dokumentarfilmer und vor allem als großer Interviewer bekannt, aber hier wird er selbst interviewt und nur mal ein Clip zum Krieg.
Kommt das durch diesen Krieg in der Ukraine? Hat man da jetzt plötzlich wieder so Angst, in Europa kann so etwas zu einem großen Krieg werden?
Die großen Kriege beginnen mit kleinen Kriegen. Der Erste Weltkrieg begann mit einem Land namens Serbien, wo die meisten Leute gar nicht mehr wissen, wo das liegt. Wie die Ukraine. Und auf einmal war ein Weltkrieg da.
So, wir haben jetzt also einen Zeitzeugen, einen 100-Jährigen, der einfach noch mal die Assoziationen, die wir auch schon alle mehrmals aufgegriffen haben, wachruft, erster Weltkrieg und das beginnt im Kleinen und wird dann ganz schnell groß. Ich glaube, wenn man Zeitzeugen wirklich ernst nehmen will, die das jetzt überblicken und die das jetzt möglicherweise ein zweites Mal erleben könnten, dann sollten wir uns auch dieser Gefahr immer gewahr werden. Wer das tut, ist natürlich Alexander Kluge. Wir haben schon mal im Salon oder im Vorhof zum Salon über ein Interview mit ihm gesprochen. Er war jetzt im Schauspielhaus Stuttgart zu Gast. SWR 2 hat das Ganze dokumentiert und er sagt ganz wunderbare Sachen, zum Beispiel das hier.
Also Lu Zu, der chinesische Kriegstheoretiker und Klausowitz, sind die einzigen, von denen ich behaupten würde, dass sie die Gefährlichkeit dieses Dämonskrieg wirklich verstanden haben und dass sie tatsächlich die Schlüsselworte entwickelt haben, die Begriffe entwickelt haben, wie man ihn zum Stolpern bringen könnte. Zum Stolpern. Der Krieg muss man zum Stolpern bringen. Ja, von selbst endet er nicht.
Wie stolpert ein Krieg?
Wie stolpert ein Krieg? Zum Beispiel so, Kluge ist ja der Mann der Anekdoten und der historischen Fakten, folgendes.
Also Karl V steht mit seinen Söldnern und Frunzberg vor Rom und will die Stadt massakrieren. Die Soldaten kriegen alle Ruhe. Dann ist der Krieg gestolpert. Sie haben jetzt zum Beispiel in Bildern, wenn Sie aufmerksam geguckt haben, die Rasputica, die Schlammperiode in der Ukraine vielleicht bemerkt. Die russischen Panzer stecken im Schlamm, so wie sie die Straße verlassen. Die Langsamkeit ihres Vordringes ist auch damit verbunden, dass zweimal im Jahr die Ukraine wie überschwemmt ist, wie ein Nildelta. Schwarz Erde. Das ist ein Fakt der Fruchtbarkeit. Die Schwarz Erde ist wie in Ägypten eingehegt. Zweimal, dass das halbe Schwarze Meer da runterplatzt. Dann ist der Krieg gebremst.
Auch so kann der Krieg stolpern.
Vor allem kann man auch mal so über Krieg reden. Ich weiß nicht, ob das eine Schule war. Wir sollten irgendwann mal ein Projekt suchen. Ich glaube, es war eine Schule. Dann habe ich über Flakken und so überlegt. Ich komme aus Jena. Da war eine Napoleonschlacht, die dann im Nebel usw. Dann habe ich mir die Frage gestellt, müsste man sich das mal anschauen, inwieweit das Wetter auf Kriegeeinfluss hatte? So wie Napoleon da nicht so richtig vorwärts kam. Weil morgens so Nebel war und man nichts sah usw. Das hier wieder zu hören, während man das bei Ilna oder so... Es gab vorher, das weiß ich noch, im Januar immer dieses, Putin wartet, bis die Böden gefroren sind, um dann mit dem Panzer drüber zu fahren. Das fand ich schon immer hanebüchen und irgendwie... Weil das hat ja dann zeitlich auch nicht gepasst. Er ist ja losgefahren, als diese Schlammzeit irgendwie begann. Und dann dieser Konvoi da 80 Kilometer lang und nichts funktioniert. Aber das finde ich gut. Es gehört auch ein bisschen Mut dazu hier einfach. Zum einen dieses Stolpern. Ja, ich meine wirklich Stolpern. Und dann ebenso vom Schlamm zu sprechen.
Ja oder hiervon.
Da war ein deutscher Obergefreiter und er hatte am Fuß so eine dicke Blase, als es auf Stalingrad zu ging, östlich von Scharkow. Und er konnte nicht weiter marschieren. Da hat ihm der Fuß das Leben gerettet. Der Fuß war klüger als der Kopf.
Ja, das sind einfach sehr, sehr schöne Bilder. Und man muss hin und wieder den Poeten sprechen lassen, wenn man einen intelligenteren Diskurs haben will, als der, den wir gerade in Talkshows haben.
Also hier kommt sehr viel mehr Realität rein, als in jeder Diskussion über irgendwas. Schwere Waffen, Hashtag.
Ja, hier sitzt nicht jemand, ja wir kennen ja alle den Krieg nur noch aus dem Fernsehen und deswegen sollte man den mal wieder kennenlernen. Das ist was ganz, ganz anderes. Ja, was ist denn nun gemeint von Klausowitz mit diesem Nebel?
Wir haben die Station jetzt genannt.
Nebel des Kriegs.
Warum?
Das ist ein Ausdruck von Klausowitz. Sowie der Krieg ausgebrochen ist, hat er keinen Aufseher oder Vorgesetzten mehr. Sein Dämon, der träumt von seiner absoluten Gewalt. Wie man diesen Dämon bekämpft, das ist die Geheimwissenschaft von Klausowitz. Und ich fände, in der Öffentlichkeit muss ich damit beschäftigen, aber nicht, indem sie phrasiologisch einfach nur eine der Seiten beschimpft.
So, wenn wir jetzt daran denken, dass wir Aufrüstung überall haben. Also es gibt kein einziges Land auf der Erde, das gerade abrüstet, sondern alle haben den Militäretat erhöht und wollen ihn weiter erhöhen. Dann müssen wir uns jetzt mal vergegenwärtigen, was Kluge sagt.
Wenn beide Parteien sich stark fühlen oder eine sich stark fühlt, gibt es keinen Frieden. Wenn beide sich schwach fühlen, haben sie Frieden. Und wir sind Schwachstellenforscher als Poeten. Wir müssen herausfinden, wann beide gleichzeitig sich schwach fühlen. Und dann dürfen nicht Dritte den einen wieder aufpulveren propagandistisch, dass er sich eben nicht schwach fühlt, obwohl er schwach ist.
Machen wir das momentan?
Im Moment machen wir das.
Ja, ich meine, wenn man das mal aufgreift, warum leben wir hier in Deutschland im Frieden? Weil bei uns zwei Tage Regen 60 Milliarden Euro Schaden verursachen können. Dieser Regen ist total zufällig und es ist nur Wasser. Wenn jetzt jemand vorhat, hier Bomben hageln zu lassen, wir können den Schaden nicht am Messen. Es wäre alles vernichtet. Es gibt von den Germanen, die das so ausklamüsern, wo trifft eigentlich der Klimawandel am härtesten? Und wir sagen immer, das sind so die küsstennahen armen Gegenden und so weiter. Nein, da kann nicht viel kaputt gehen, nur Menschenleben und das wird anders kalkuliert. Es ist Deutschland, Japan, Indonesien. Weil hier einfach, gerade in Japan auch, wenn da einmal zu viel Regen fällt und der Regen bahnt sich da zehn Kilometer durch diese Hanglagen, wo die Leute wohnen, ist das alles vernichtet. Es kann also unglaublich viel kaputt gehen.
Sehen ein Familienhäuser 5 Millionen Euro weg.
Genau, wir sind superreich, aber das macht uns super-schwach militärisch gesehen. Weil wir können das, was wir hier haben, nicht verteidigen. Eine Bombe auf Frankfurt am Main und man hat die halbe europäische Wirtschaft lahmgelegt. Und diese Bombe kann man aber nicht abfangen. Und in deren Sicht kann man das wirklich fühlen, wie er das hier so meint. Und es gäbe so viele Beispiele, um das einfach mal zu beschreiben.
Fühlen ist ein gutes Stichwort. Wir haben ja schon mal in unserer Habermas-Kontroverse darüber gesprochen, welche Rolle eigentlich die Gefühle spielen müssen. Und kann man jetzt nur sachlich darauf blicken. Was ist eigentlich die richtige Strategie? Kluge möchte Einfühlung und Sachlichkeit zusammenbringen.
Es gibt ja immer Empathieeinfühlung. Und ich habe die, glauben Sie mir, dass ich sehr genau beobachte, wenn Menschen fliehen müssen, wenn sie massakriert werden, wenn sie sterben. Das ist nicht so, dass mich da irgendetwas unbewegt lässt. Aber die gleiche Emotion, die ich da habe, steckt auch in der Sachlichkeit, die ich von meiner Großmutter gelernt habe. Sie war eine Engländerin, die war zufällig sachlich. Und wenn Sachlichkeit und Empathie zusammenwirken, dann ist es ein menschliches Urteil, dann kann man urteilen. Und deswegen meine ich, dass hinter Sachlichkeit auch viel Emotion stecken muss.
Und beides wird jetzt zusammengeführt von ihm?
Und wenn diese Sachlichkeit dann einfach nur aufzählt, was sie sieht, dann würde sie im Moment sagen, Putin hat diesen Krieg bereits verloren. Dass eine Atommacht und eine Veto-Macht keine Kriege machen darf, egal wie sie gereizt wird, das halte ich für Grundlage der UNO-Karta. Also Recht hat Russland überhaupt keinen anzugreifen. Umgekehrt aber kann man auch sagen, sich mit einer Supermacht, die Atomwaffen hat und Veto-Recht hat, anzulegen. Auch kein guter Gedanke.
So, wenn wir das jetzt nehmen, dann stellt sich ja schon die Frage, wie wird sich das in den nächsten Jahren, Jahrzehnten ausgestalten? Nun gibt es ja viele, die sagen, die Ukraine sollte möglichst schnell der NATO beitreten. Dann passiert ja genau das, wovor Putin Angst hat. Aber das können wir sowieso beobachten. Putins Albträume hat er sich selbst realisiert. Das ist ganz klar so, denn das gibt es ja auch noch ein paar Tage vor dem Krieg als Scholz da war. Da sagte er, wir wollen ja gar nicht, was sie hier erzählen. Und das werden wir auch beide nicht erleben und sowas. Putin hat tatsächlich seine Albträume realisiert. Oder man könnte eher sagen, seine Träume. Es gibt so einen schönen Satz von Slavoj Šicek. Er sagt ja, wir haben ein gutes Wort. Wenn wir unsere Träume realisieren, dann sind es Albträume. Und in gewisser Weise haben wir das jetzt. Nun, was wäre aber zu sagen, wenn jetzt wirklich tatsächlich die Ukraine in die NATO eintreten würde? Kluge ist da sehr skeptisch.
Wir wollen der NATO jetzt beitreten. Und das ist eine Idee von Bush Junior aus dem Jahr 2008. Dann würde das bedeuten, dass die Grenzlinie und damit die Raketenstellungen bis dahin östlich von Scharkow vorrücken, wo einmal die deutsche Wehrmacht 1942 stand. Und es würde zweitens bedeuten, dass die Krim und die Donbass-Republiken wiedererobert werden müssen mit Mitteln der NATO. Denn dazu ist sie verpflichtend, wenn die Ukraine beitritt. Und beides geht ja nicht.
Das heißt, diese Konstellation ist eine, die zunächst einmal logisch erscheint, aber einen dauerhaften Krieg eigentlich mit sich führt. Beziehungsweise den Krieg nicht beendet, sondern ihn fortsetzt. Und die Frage ist, wie sieht die Alternative aus, wenn man versucht, das Beste für die Ukraine rauszuholen?
Ja, aber ich meine, das war ja auch seit 2014. Also die Krim wird erobert und die Ostukraine da so unklar gelassen. Kein Land, das in einen Krieg verwickelt ist, kann der NATO beitreten. Also in deren Sicht hat Putin es für die NATO-Mitglieder eigentlich einfach gemacht, weil die gar nicht positiv entscheiden konnten, selbst wenn sie wollten. Auf der anderen Seite hat es ihn wieder schwer gemacht, weil er eben jetzt diese konkrete Verteidigungssituation für die ganze Ukraine hergestellt hat. Und da greift dann auch Cizek's Spruch mit, es ist halt wirklich wahnsinnig schwierig, hier einen Albtraum von einem Traum zu unterscheiden und ihn auch noch zuzurechnen. Weil wollte Putin jetzt einfach nur mal wieder einen Gegner haben, so wie wir das aus der ganzen Literatur kennen. Wir kämpfen jetzt gegen Ozeanien und so weiter. Hauptsache einen Gegner, egal wie virtuell. Und dann hat er es irgendwie übertrieben. Und der Gegner ist aber nicht mehr virtuell. Und jetzt wird er halt wirklich ausgezehrt. Also materiell einfach wirklich in so einen... Vernichtungskrieg ist falsch, aber so einen Abnutzungskrieg reingeschickt, wo auch alle Ideen irgendwann lächerlich werden, wenn so gesagt wird, ja als nächster holt er sich das Baltikum. Ja, womit denn? Ja, also es stellt sich ja echt die Frage, irgendwann womit denn eigentlich?
Abnutzungskrieg ist auch ein gutes Stichwort, denn wir vergessen immer Abnutzung meint, dass da sehr viele Menschen bei sterben und nicht nur Material abgenutzt wird. Und deswegen sollten wir auch nochmal diese Rolle der NATO bedenken, weil jetzt zu Recht ja Ukrainer sagen, wir kämpfen hier für eure Freiheit, insofern als wir den Kopf hinhalten. Und sie halten den Kopf, aber man kann das konkret machen, dafür hin, dass Putin sich abnutzt an ihnen. Das heißt, dass wir ein geschwächtes Russland haben, was den NATO-Block erstarken lässt. Das erklärt damit aber dann auch, warum wir jetzt nicht ein Angebot machen, seitens des Westens, seitens Deutschlands zu sagen, wir nehmen alle auf, wir nehmen auch die Männer auf, die fliehen wollen. Weil wir sagen eigentlich, die sollen sich jetzt mal da einbringen, damit Russland sich abnutzt und wir erstarken. Und das ist die große, große moralische Verfehlung, will ich nicht sagen, es ist ein moralisches Dilemma, in dem wir uns da befinden. Also es geht nicht nur darum zu sagen, wir helfen den Ukrainern oder wir helfen den Ukrainern nicht genug, sondern wir müssen auch sehen, wir schicken die Ukrainer, weil wir einen Machtinteresse natürlich daran haben, an einem eher schwächeren Russland und einem erstarkten NATO-Block. Und das ist eine ganz, ganz heikle Sache. Und deswegen, glaube ich, ist die Empathie wichtig, aber die Empathie muss auch über das so konkrete, ich fühle jetzt gerade was angesichts zerschrecklichen Bilder hinausgehen, sondern auch bedeuten, ja, aber warum können wir dann nicht sagen, dass wir einfach diejenigen, die fliehen wollen, alle, auch die Männer aufnehmen, warum können wir dann da nicht weitergehen? Naja, weil die jetzt auch eine geopolitische Funktion für uns füllen. Und das ist das große, große Drama, wo wir dann auch mit schuld sind.
Also du hast es jetzt angesprochen und auch in Worte gerungen, und so geht es mir auch, aber jetzt ist das Thema einmal da und ich will es so ein bisschen all-iniger einmal fragend formulieren. Missbrauchen wir gerade die Ukraine für ein urwestliches Anliegen? Nämlich Russland einfach demütigen, würde ich nicht sagen, aber zumindest materiell in eine Lage zu bringen, dass sie uns nicht mehr gefährlich werden können, da sie ja schon, das sehen wir ja bei Putin, dann doch über Jahre und so weiter so Ideologien da politisch ausbreiten. Und wenn man sich so anhört, wie seine Chefideologen im Fernsehen reden, oder auch die ganze Zeit.
Ich bringe im Salon einen Text mit, der einen die Schuhe auszieht. Von einem Chefideologen. Dieser Text ist dokumentiert in den aktuellen Blättern. Das riecht wirklich nach Völkermann.
Genau. Es ist nicht nur Putin, sondern es gibt so eine ideologische Blase drum herum in Moskau. Das scheint da irgendwie durchseucht zu sein von seiner Ideologie, dass man ja eigentlich die verkannte Weltmacht ist und jetzt noch mal den Leuten zeigen will, wo der Hammer hängt. So und jetzt haben wir aber eine Lage, in der wir Hashtag-Atomkrieg irgendwie westliches Material in Anklang bringen wollen, aber die NATO kann es nicht tun, denn dann wäre sie Kriegspartei. Weshalb in Rammstein eben die Amerikaner einladen und dann wird einfach so ein riesiges Bündnisgebiet und die kommen dann einfach da zusammen und treffen sich und an Lennina Baerbock sagt er im Bundestag auch, es sind irgendwie 180 Länder, das hat gar nichts mit der NATO zu tun, sondern es gibt so eine große Verlangs gegen Russland. Gleichzeitig haben wir Zelensky, der so als ideologischer Führer dann doch eine große Welle macht über die Ukraine hinaus, sodass wir auch so Identifikationsmerkmale finden und haben eben die Situation, dass junge ukrainische Männer nicht ausreißen dürfen und wir uns aber gleichzeitig sagen, wir können alles liefern, also Markus Keimer hat ja auch noch mal daran erinnert, von der Stiftung für Wissenschaft und Politik, wir haben ja allein durch die UN-Mitgliedschaft eine Verpflichtung der Ukraine beizustehen, aber eben nur mit Material, nicht mit Soldaten. Also kämpfen gerade die Ukrainer für uns, das ist eigentlich unser Anliegen. Man sieht ja richtig, wie sie im Pentagon da sitzen und sich die Hände reiben, wie man heute wieder die Ukrainer darin unterstützen kann, Russland mal so richtig in den Arsch zu treten. In Deutschland wird das halt alles so überdeckt. Man hängt sich dann so an Jan Böhmermann-Tweets und ist ganz sauer auf den Kanzler und so weiter. Aber das eigentliche ideologische Geschehen ist ja doch ein anderes. Al-Robin Alexander hatte einen so einen Tweet, da hat er irgend so ein Dings aufgegriffen, so ein Beaumont im Sinne von, und dann die Deutschen werden der Ukraine nie verzeihen, dass sie von Russland angegriffen wurde. Und das kann man aber auch anders deuten. Wir werden der Ukraine nie zeigen können, wie froh und dankbar wir sind, dass wir jetzt endlich mal gegen Russland was tun können. So ungefähr. Also ich bin jetzt sehr weit gegangen in dieser Beschreibung des Problems.
Ja, aber das ist sehr ehrlich, wenn es einem wirklich darum geht, um die Ukrainer. Also wenn man jetzt nicht einfach sagt, ich sehe da so einen geopolitisch wichtigen Flecken für mich, und darüber können wir in anderer Weise diskutieren. Aber wenn ich jetzt diesen Diskurs vordenke, zu sagen, wie können wir den Ukrainern, also den Menschen in der Ukraine helfen, dann wäre ja darüber nachzudenken, was ist das außer dieser Waffenlieferung vielleicht noch? Und da kommt man natürlich daraus, ja für die, die nicht kämpfen wollen, doch einen anderen Weg zu finden, nämlich den der Ausreise. Und das ist auch etwas, was eigentlich, wenn, das hören wir jetzt häufiger, wir von feministischer Außenpolitik reden wollen, dazu gehören müsste, weil die wäre ja dann konzentriert auf den Menschen. Und dass das so wenig stattfindet, zeigt dann auch wieder, dass es dann sehr leicht sein kann, dass man da sich so Spielbälle schafft, menschliche. Und das ist eine ganz, ganz dramatische Situation, wie ich finde. Und das, also ich würde das auch nur mal so in den Raum stellen lassen, dass wir nicht so tun dürfen, als würden wir mit der Waffenlieferung uns moralisch freikaufen. Als hätten wir dann, hätten wir jetzt aber wirklich das getan. Nein, nein, die müssen diese Waffen ausführen und die werden auch zum Teil mit diesen Waffen in ihren Händen sterben, weil dann trotzdem es zum Gefecht kommt und so weiter. Also so einfach ist die Lage nicht. Kluge sagt aber immerhin, Putin hat verloren.
So etwas sind sachliche Überlegungen, die genauso viel Empathie brauchen, genauso viel Emotionen brauchen wie die andere Seite. Und jetzt kann man aber Folgendes sagen, mir geht ein bisschen das Herz da über, weil Putin ist ja besiegt in dem Moment, in dem er angriff. Denn durch Eroberung kann er die Sicherheitsarchitektur, die er haben will, nicht bekommen. Die kann er nur bekommen durch Anerkennung der anderen. Und die hat er völlig verloren. Ihnen werden die 139 Nationen, die ihn in der UNO verurteilt haben, mehr erschüttern als alle Sanktionen.
So, Putin hat sich isoliert. Klar, er hat auch Länder, die sich nicht von ihm distanzieren und keine kleinen Länder. China, Indien hält sich auch zurück, Pakistan hält sich auch zurück, obwohl Indien und Pakistan eigentlich verfeindet sind. Das muss man auch wieder da unseren westlichen Blick noch mal hinterfragen. Wie wichtig sind wir dann jetzt auch für das künftige Weltgeschehen, sagen wir mal in zehn Jahren oder so, wenn wir, ich glaube, 2035 zwei Drittel der Weltbevölkerung in asiatischen Ländern wahrscheinlich leben wird? Also da tut sich auch noch mal einiges. Nun, wie ist jetzt weiter vorzugehen? Kluge schlägt Folgendes vor.
Wenn Sie mal die Szene sich vor Augen führen, die in den Zeitungen zu lesen war, und ich habe nachgeforscht, die ist auch wahr, dass Zivilisten am Anfang dieses Kriegs sich vor Panzer hingestellt haben, und dann ist der Panzer zurückgerollt. Und jetzt ist für mich die wichtige Beobachtung, nicht bloß dieser Vorgang, der hätte ja auch gestellt sein können, sondern dass da zwei zu erforderlich sind. Die tapferen Zivilisten, die sich vor den Panzer stellen, und der junge Panzerfahrer, der das Fahrzeug zurückmanövriert. Und so etwas sehe ich dann als zweite Erfahrung, ist beim Putsch in Moskau gegen Gorbatschow 1991 ebenfalls gut gegangen. Der Putsch wurde durch solche Zivilisten, die diese Panzerdivisionen angehalten haben und durch die, die in den Panzern saßen, beigelegt worden. Und dasselbe ist am Platz der Zivilischen Friedens als Massaker geendet. Und auch in Ungarn 1956 und 1968 in Prag nicht gut gegangen, weil da eben nicht zwei dabei waren. Die haben sie ja nicht verstanden und dieses, dass das zwei sind, ist mir das Wichtige daran.
Jetzt schauen wir nochmal in die Zukunft. Wir haben jetzt ganz am Anfang Florian Schaub gehört, die sagt, die Russen sind anders und da würde man draus Schlussfolger müssen. Gut, dann kommen wir niemals mehr zusammen, auch nicht in 50 Jahren. Und jetzt schildert Kluge folgende Anekdote, die sich abgespielt hat in Bayreuth auf dem grünen Hügel.
Und ich erzähle jetzt eine weitere Geschichte. Ich habe gefilmt den Gorbatschow in Bayreuth und wir trafen dann auf L'Oreal und die beiden hatten die Götterdämmerung gesehen von Wagner und saßen jetzt beim Wein. Und da kommt raus, dass der Gorbatschow in Stavropol seiner Heimatstadt 1942 deutsche Panzer gesehen hat. Und da sagt der L'Oreal und ich war einer der Kommandeure davon in Stavropol 42. Sehen Sie, und das ist jetzt für mich etwas Beglückendes.
Das ist ein Friedensbild, das sich nachträglich einstellt. Noch ein letztes Mal, Kluge, wir haben jetzt diesen Diskurs. Ist Putin überhaupt noch rational in seinem Handeln? Wir würden das auch bezweifeln. Nun, Kluge, bringt hier auch nochmal das historische Wissen mit ein.
Dieser Nixon war bekannt dafür, dass er sich rühmte. Er verbreite immer gerne bei Verhandlungen den Eindruck, er sei verrückt. Weil das einen Verhandlungsvorteil bringt. Die Leute werden vorsichtig, wenn ein Verrückter da ist. Sie merken, gut und böse, moralisch integer oder nicht integer. Wir können uns das alles nicht aussuchen. Immanuel Kant hat mal gesagt, auch eine Republik von Teufeln ist zum Friedensschluss fähig, sagte Philosoph. So ist die Schwäche in uns unter Umständen der stärkere Friedensbringer. Einer war zu doof für den Krieg. Das wäre immerhin der Soldat Schwaig. Ich will jetzt nicht übertreiben und ich habe auch keine Rezepte. Ich sage nur, was die Beobachtungsgabe der Poetik hier in diesem Fall an Unterscheidungsvermögen zusammentragen muss.
Ja, dieses Moment der Schwäche da reinzubringen scheint mir doch den größten Gewinn zu bringen in der ganzen Beobachtung. Die Frage ist, wie kann man dieses heuristische Potenzial, das ja nun echt ein Friedensstiftendes ist, da einbringen, da wir natürlich alle, wenn der Krieg einmal läuft, über die Stärke regeln und sei es nur vorgespielt oder wie auch immer. Ich will auch mal noch zwei kleine Clips anfügen, denn eine Sache geht mir immer völlig abhanden. Also ich sehe das einfach nirgendwo und ich finde es aber grotesk. Und Alexander Kluge hat es hier sehr gut, immer so mitgeführt. Putin hat schon verloren. Putin wird diese Anerkennung nie bekommen. Und Russland ist im Krieg. Wir haben es ja hier auch besprochen. Es sind ja nicht nur Sanktionen, sondern es findet eine Deglobalisierung statt. Es wurde die Zentralbank aus dem Spiel genommen, der Zahlungsverkehr wurde eingestellt, zumindest der internationale und so weiter und so fort. Und in meinem neuen Hashtag-Lieblings-Podcast, nämlich im Economic Challenges-Podcast vom Handelsblatt mit dem Chefökonom des Handelsblatt, Bert Rürup und Michael Hüther vom Deutschen Institut Wirtschaft Pippa Po. Was ist er genau?
Ja, es gibt einen...
Institut der Deutschen Wirtschaft ist ja... Da ist jedenfalls das Arbeitgeber nahe. Ja. Institut der Deutschen Wirtschaft, das glaube ich. Weil das Fratschersladen ist ja das Institut für Wirtschaftsforschung. Man kommt ja immer durcheinander. Da gibt es ja noch das Weltwirtschafts-Ding in Kiel und... Naja, wir wissen alle, wer Michael Hüther ist. Und er hat... Er kann hier referieren, was die russische Zentralbank-Chefin sagt. Und damit kriegen wir ja doch mal einen kleinen Einblick. Damit ist dieser Clip auch ein bisschen länger. Er geht über anderthalb Minuten.
So hart der Krieg ist, irgendwann wird auch dieser Krieg zu Ende gehen. Aber das alte Geschäftsmodell Russlands wird nicht mehr funktionieren. Wie könnte denn das neue Geschäftsmodell Russlands aussehen?
Ja, die Elvira Nabulyana hat auch dazu einen Hinweis gegeben in diesen Interviews. Das ist übrigens vielleicht als Nebenbemerkung wirklich spannend, dass es offensichtlich unter der Ägide der Gruppe der Zentralbanker so etwas gibt wie einen gemeinsamen Diskursraum und auch Qualitätsstandard. Also ich war mal vor der 2018 Adenauer Stiftung mit Kollegen eingeladen nach Moskau zu einer Tagung bei der Beuteing Hochschule für Ökonomie, die nun sehr systemtreu ist. Das konnten wir auch merken, denn mit denen konnte man wirklich keine interessanten Gespräche über Ökonomie führen. War alles andere schon, aber nicht über Ökonomie. Aber der dort teilnehmende Zentralbanker, also aus der russischen Zentralbank, war ebenso exzellent ausgebildet, wie wir das von den internationalen, westlichen Zentralbanken kennen. Und insofern spiegelt sich das, was du zu ihr gesagt hast, auch in ihrer Wahrnehmung, die sie weit über Russland hinaus genießt, durchaus auch in dieser persönlichen Anekdote. Aber den Hinweis, den sie gegeben hat, ist das mal vor, aus dem Interview zu sagen, ja, she said Russian firms need to adapt by searching for new business models, partners, logistics, or, jetzt kommt das hier an, switch to the production of products of previous generations. Previous generation, das heißt, sie empfiehlt im Grunde, den russischen Unternehmen gar nicht darauf zu hoffen, dass sie in dem Technologiewettbewerb mitmachen können oder mithalten können und dabei wettbewerbsfähig sein können, sondern dass sie sozusagen das, was sie immer irgendwie nachlaufend gemacht haben, auch weiter noch machen, also mit Produkten früherer Technikgeneration, die sie noch haben.
Ja, Russland wurde also einfach eingefroren. Da wird einfach von der Zentralbank, und er hat nochmal betont, ja, da rennen noch viele Spinner um, aber die Zentralbänger kennen sich aus und die verstehen ihr Geschäft. Die sagen dann den Unternehmen, versucht hier nicht irgendwie Research & Development zu machen oder so. Nehmt die Möglichkeiten, die ihr habt und versucht, die Produktionsstrecken, die ihr aufrechterhalten könnt, aufrechterhalten, was dann einfach wirklich bedeutet. Nachdem jetzt die Sanktionen griffen und bei IKEA die letzte Pfanne verkauft wurde, gibt es halt wirklich nur noch die Küchengeräte, Modelle 1900 und so weiter.
Klingt nicht nach einem Zukunftsmarkt und irgendwann wird man dann immer mehr aus China importieren.
Das muss man aber bezahlen.
Genau, das ist die Sache. Man wird nämlich dadurch armen, wenn man dann immer weniger exportieren kann. Und Öl und Gas will man im Westen nicht. Und ob das dann China alles abnimmt, ob Indien das, wie das jetzt gerade geschieht, da dankbar zugreift und sich über billige Preise freut, das ist erstmal was, was in der Zukunft steht. Ich glaube, dass wir aber sicherlich so ein Bündnis zwischen China und Russland erstarken sehen gerade. Das merken wir auch mit dem Auftritt da nochmal bei den Olympischen Spielen. Wir merken es daran, dass China sich nicht so distanzieren will. Wir merken es natürlich auch daran, dass Amerika ganz klar Kampfansage nach der anderen raushaut gegen China und China aber auch nicht in irgendeiner Weise zurücktritt. Wir merken es im Übrigen auch an der bundesdeutschen Außenpolitik, denn die sah ja so aus bei Merkel, dass sie unglaublich häufig nach China gereist ist. Und normalerweise wäre jetzt für den Bundeskanzler auch der erste Asienbesuch natürlich China. Wo ist er hingereist? Nach Japan. Das heißt, man versucht hier offenbar auch ein bisschen diese japanische Tech-Industrie mit ins Boot zu holen, wenn man sich von China unabhängig machen will. Denn man braucht, wir haben es ja mit Apple jetzt auch gesehen, man braucht gute Entwickler und sowas. Es geht ja nicht einfach nur darum, dass man irgendwelche Fabriken hat, wo was zusammengebaut wird oder ein paar helle Köpfe, die verrückte Ideen haben, sondern man braucht auch ganz viele Leute, die umsetzen können. Da ist Japan ein wichtiges Land. Japan hat ohnehin die Westausrichtung. Und dass man jetzt ganz klar sagt, wir reisen mal erst nach Japan und China sowieso sich immer weiter isoliert durch den Doktor. Das wäre auch ein Thema nochmal gewesen. Man kann aber so ein paar Dokus sich ja mal bei YouTube ansehen, wie das in Shanghai aussieht. Es ist so furchterregend, dass man sagen muss, ja, wahrscheinlich sind das die neuen Allianzen, die sich bilden.
Shanghai wäre ein eigenes Thema gewesen für diesen Monat. Das ist, man kann es nicht glauben.
Geht es dir auch so? Man sieht bei Twitter ein Video und denkt, okay, das ist jetzt Fake. Und dann ruft man es aber auf und sieht es auf den Nachrichtenseiten und sagt, ne, das ist kein Fake. Das sieht da wirklich so aus.
Ja, es ist eine ganz schlimme Lage gerade in Shanghai. Was eben auch bedeutet, selbst die fortschrittlichsten, bestentwickelten, jüngsten Städte der Welt irgendwie können politisch einfach, klar, das ist jetzt nur temporär und so, hoffentlich, aber wirklich ins Mittelalter zurückversetzt werden. Irgendwie Leute in ihrer Wohnung eingesperrt. Du hast gesagt, man braucht jetzt auch Manpower und Womanpower. Man muss jetzt mit irgendwem dann auch gestalten und Land machen. Und da hat Michael Hüther hier nochmal einen zweiten Abschnitt.
Man konnte heute in einem sehr spannenden Interview lesen, wie viele qualifizierte Arbeitskräfte Russland verlassen haben. 2012, nach der Wiederwahl von Putin, waren es 12.000 Wissenschaftler, von denen man es weiß. 2021 waren es 70.000. Und seit dem Kriegsausbruch sind es mehr als 200.000 hochqualifizierte Arbeitskräfte. Das sind die e-fach genannten IT-Spezialisten, aber auch zunehmend Forscher von regimetreuen Institutionen, weil sie im Grunde keine Perspektive mehr sehen. Wo gehen die hin? Die gehen, weil sie da leichter ausreisen können in die ehemaligen sowjetischen Republiken, Armenien, Georgia und so weiter, aber auch in die Türkei, die ja, obwohl NATO-Mitglied noch die Flugverbindungen in Richtung Russland offen hält. Und für diese Länder brauchen die Russen dann kein Visum. Wir sind gut beraten, auch das zur Kenntnis zu nehmen. Einerseits bestätigt es ja im Grunde die Aussage von Frau Nabulianer zu sagen, wir haben eigentlich keine Perspektive in einem technisch getragenen Wachstum, durch Fortschritt getragenen Wachstum, weil die kommen noch hinzu, wir haben nicht nur die Produkte, wir haben auch die Leute eigentlich immer weniger, denn das sind ja keine minoren Zahlen. Und gleichzeitig müssen wir uns aber fragen, was heißt das für uns? Können wir die integrieren? Welche Perspektiven können wir bieten? Genauso wie wir auch die Stärkung der wissenschaftlichen Expertisen der Ukraine natürlich mit zum Thema machen müssen. Was übrigens, das darf man auch noch mal, wenn so viel gesagt wird, was alles versäumt worden sei, das ist auch versäumt worden. Es gab beispielsweise seitens der DFG kaum Förderprogramme für ukrainische Wissenschaftler.
Ja, das ist natürlich immer so ein Jungbrunnen-Argument, dass Rentenrepubliken so ein bisschen verlogen nutzen. Also wie sähe die bayerische Wirtschaft aus, ohne den Mauerfall? Dass einfach eine Million Menschen nach Bayern ziehen. Junge Menschen, die dann plötzlich so da sind und jeden Job annehmen und so weiter. Und jetzt ist das 30 Jahre her und es ist versiegt. Und jetzt ergibt sich gerade wieder eine Möglichkeit. Und dann sagt Hüter nur so, ja, schade, dass wir keine Anwerbeabkommen haben. Ohne noch mal, was bedeutet das eigentlich für die Herkunftsländer und so, die sind ja dann auch entsprechend geschädigt.
Ja, da haben wir einen richtigen Brain Drain. Wir können das auch, glaube ich, noch mal differenzieren. Dann von Ländern, wo der Entwicklungsstadium so gering ist, dass also für diejenigen, die da irgendwie rauskommen und die die Chance haben, sich im eigenen Land nichts mehr ermöglichen würde. Aber hier in der Ukraine, und das ist auch, weil man nicht entsprechend gefördert hat, wären diese Köpfe sehr gut aufgehoben. Und hätte man diese Köpfe auch schon längst ganz anders noch mal unterstützen können.
Zum Ende will ich nur kurz referieren, aber es ist ganz interessant. Im Micky Beisenherz Apokalypse und Filter-Café-Podcast war Thorsten Körner zu Gast. Der hat einen Film über Merkel gemacht, so typisches ARD-Mediathek-Zeug, und hat dann noch mal geplaudert. Zum Beispiel hat der Merkel gefragt, was bereuen sie am meisten aus ihren vier Kanzlerzeiten? Und dann sagt sie, dass sie die Ukraine nur in fragiler Stabilität zurücklassen konnte. Und er fügt dann noch mal an und versucht es dann auch, also ich will ja gar nicht Küchenpsychologisieren, und macht es dann doch, Merkels Zittern damals, 2019, also sie steht beim Staatsempfang vor den Soldaten und fängt an zu zittern. Und alle deutschen Journalisten fragen sich, was ist denn da los? Und seitdem ist sie ja nur noch sitzend bei diesen Veranstaltungen aufgetreten, war neben Zelensky. Das war der erste Besuch von Zelensky. Und da kann man natürlich jetzt in alle Richtungen überlegen, was das bedeutet. Nun gut. Wir reden über Twitter und über Elon Musk.
Freust du dich, dass du jetzt endlich wieder deine freie Meinung auf Twitter äußern kannst, wenn das in den Händen eines Einzelnen ist?
Also wir haben ja schon häufiger über Elon Musk gesprochen. Über seine Raketen.
Du warst doch einst der große Elon Musk-Fan. Also für dich müssen das doch hier Feiertage sein.
Ich fand das unter die praktische Intelligenz eines Menschen mal richtig in Anklang gebracht und dann diese Dinge aufgebaut. Bewundernswert. Aber jetzt im April hat er den Bogen überspannt. Das muss man ganz deutlich sagen. Wir haben es hier mit einer... Klar, wir haben uns über Ukraine und echten Krieg und so weiter gesprochen. Aber ich finde das wirklich eine ganz brisante, hochgefährliche Lage, in der die Welt da gerade ist, dass nämlich ein Milliardär einfach nur durch Umschichtung seines Vermögens plötzlich so eine gesellschaftliche und politische Macht erringen kann. Wenn jetzt immer gesagt wird, er kauft Twitter, ne, der tauscht nur eine sehr werthaltige Aktie gegen eine andere sehr werthaltige Aktie und hofft, dass die Werte nicht verloren gehen, aber er verliert ja nicht wirklich Wert, dadurch, dass er was kauft. Also er investiert in Twitter, müsste man sagen, und wird wahrscheinlich dadurch sogar noch reicher, denn wir haben ja schon besprochen, sein erstes Upstar, ich hab niemandem Bescheid gesagt, obwohl ich es eigentlich müsste, und mir gehört jetzt 9%, hat eben zu 27% Kursgewinn bei Twitter geführt. Und er hatte in dem Moment diese 9% schon, also hat er auch ordentlich Geld verdient.
Allerdings nimmt er ja das Unternehmen dann von der Börse.
Das ist sein Plan, genau, was aber trotzdem bedeutet, dass die Aktien weiter vorhanden sind mit diesem Wert. Nur eben nicht, also alle bei ihm, sozusagen. Aber es ist ja trotzdem noch eine AG, oder wie auch immer das dann heißt.
Für 44 Milliarden. Manche sagen, es sei fast zu günstig. Andere sagen wieder, na ja, aber Twitter erwirtschaftet ja in dem Sinne noch nichts. Also man hat es ja nie geschafft, wie auf Instagram, wirklich profitabel groß zu sein. Die Werbung bringt nicht viel ein. Also auch da stellen sich ja Fragen, wie sich Twitter dadurch ändern wird, ob da Elon Musk einen Masterplan hat oder nicht.
Also er hat einen. Zumindest hat er wieder so einen Anlass, das zu machen. Das erklärt er. Hat er selber auf einer Bühne erklärt. Wir beginnen aber mal hier. James Corden, der übrigens heute Nacht seinen Abschied von der Late Late Show verkündet hat.
Tatsächlich?
Er möchte 2023 aufhören, mit 43 Jahren oder so. Weil es gibt ja noch andere Möglichkeiten, irgendwas zu machen. Ich finde auch, das ist so schade.
Ich finde gerade auch James Corden, der so ein Talent hat, der muss er bis zum 80. machen.
Ich habe es auch nicht verstanden. Ich finde auch, es müssten alle wie David Letterman bis einem das Alter dann zu Gesicht stehen, muss man das machen. Never quit a hit bei sowas. Aber gut, darunter werden wir dann auch leiden. Er hat es mal in folgendem Spruch hier gepackt.
Twitter und Elon Musk haben einen Verkauf erreicht, für den Billionär den sozialen Medienkommandanten zu kaufen und ihn privat zu nehmen.
Die Fraktion hat dieses Abend den Verkauf von Musks 44-Billionen-Dollar-Verkauf verabschiedet.
44 Billion Dollar.
Im Moment ist es ein guter Plan, die Hölle zu kaufen.
So, to buy hell, die Hölle, ist natürlich erst mal auf Twitter bezogen. Er kauft die Hölle. Twitter ist die Hölle. Nur wir wissen ja, wie Twitter funktioniert. Also da toben sich Präsidenten aus, Europäische Parlamentarier, keine Ahnung, es geht so. Also es ist Rambazamba. Es hat Effekte in der echten Welt. Also es könnte durchaus eine Hölle für uns alle sein. Er kauft uns alle in die Hölle ein.
Elon Musk steuert ja seine Unternehmenspolitik über Twitter. Er hat ja immer wieder von seinen Aktionären gesagt bekommen, bitte nicht so viel twittern. Also seine Tweets erzeugen Werte oder Verluste.
Genau.
Wenn man es jetzt mal ganz auf die Börse runterbringt.
Und zwar nicht nur bei Aktien und Geld, sondern auch bei Dogecoin und so weiter. Also es geht rundherum und ist auch ein echtes Problem. Und jetzt sind wir aber in so einer Situation, dass wir hier nicht genau wissen, mit was haben wir es eigentlich zu tun? Geld ist es nicht wirklich in kaufen. Warum will er es kaufen? Wir wissen das alles nicht. Und die Berichterstattung war ja enorm. Also nicht so sehr in Deutschland. Die benutzen es ja auch nicht so viele. Aber Wall Street Journal hat Podcasts dazu gemacht. Chaoswisher hat Notfall-Podcasts dazu gemacht. Es gab in The Daily damals nur zum Ich möchte Twitter kaufen, wo es noch nicht mal feststand und so weiter. Also alle haben es irgendwie aufgegriffen und konnten aber nicht so richtig einen Rahmen dafür finden. Hier zum Beispiel hört man es beim Wall Street Journal. Also die Wirtschaftsjournalisten sagen, sowas habe ich noch nie gesehen. Ich weiß nicht was. Mal gucken. Wir können jetzt drüber reden, aber wir kennen den Rahmen noch nicht so genau. Und Chaoswisher und Scott Galloway haben das dann auch mal eingerahmt und zeigen dann auch mal, es gibt eigentlich dafür kein Beispiel für das, was uns droht, außer eins. Und das ist halt ein sehr negatives.
Ich dachte, stopp es.
Es ist ein Zeichen.
Es ist kein Nationaltreasure.
Aber es hat viel Info.
Und das ist Mark Zuckerberg.
Das einzige Beispiel, das wir haben, ist Facebook. Da hat irgendwann mal Microsoft 0, 9% für 450 Millionen gekauft. Und dann hieß es, die werden irgendwie 15 Milliarden wert. Und alle so, ne, 15 Milliarden für ein paar Texte, die irgendwelche Leute im Internet schreiben. Und jetzt ist es halt 500. Also wir wissen nicht so genau, was ist das Potenzial für Twitter, wenn man da wirklich, wie auf Instagram, alle drei Posts, eine Werbung einfügt oder wie auch immer.
Oder wenn es noch gleichzeitig eine Podcastplattform wird.
So was irgendwie, genau, wenn man es dann mal richtig ausbaut.
Videos nochmal anders. Also jetzt gibt es ja einfach Tweets und unten werden da irgendwie Videos dran gehangen, reingefügt. Aber auch da gibt es ja nochmal andere Möglichkeiten, wahrscheinlich das aufzufächern. Und es ist die Profi-Plattform. Das heißt, wir haben eine Plattform hier, die einen hohen Impact hat durch die Leute, die da sind. Bei Mark Zuckerberg ist das Geschäft ja einfach zu sagen, ja hier sind eine Milliarde Leute und die klicken und machen und tun. Und wenn du willst, dass von dieser Milliarde oder anderthalb Milliarden, wenn da 100.000 auf dein Unternehmen aufmerksam werden sollen und deinen Post sehen sollen, dann zahlst du so und so viel Geld. Dann weißt du aber eigentlich, zwar kannst du es einschränken mit Regionen oder so, aber welche Bots sind da? Wer ist da wirklich? Und na, sind das wirklich relevante Leute, die man da erreicht? Und das kann jetzt für irgendwelche Konsumprodukte interessant sein, aber wenn man Sachen für Impact haben will, also wenn man wirklich Leute erreichen will, die wichtig sind, damit das wirklich einen Effekt hat, ja. Also wenn ich jetzt mal einfach übertrage auf unseren Podcast, ich glaube, wenn wir jetzt Werbung machen wollten für unseren Podcast, dann würden wir das eher auf Twitter machen, weil wir dort Leute erreichen, die potenziell diesen Podcast hören, die den vielleicht auch dann bei Steady abonnieren, die vielleicht auch in ihrem Podcast über unseren Podcast reden. Also das wäre für uns effektiv, als jetzt einfach nur zu sagen, ja, wir haben da jetzt 100.000 Leute über Facebook erreicht, die haben alle mal kurz draufgeklickt und sind wieder weg. Und das ist etwas, was sicherlich ein sehr, sehr gutes Geschäft für Twitter werden könnte, wenn man das schafft zu monetarisieren.
Genau. Was wäre, wenn man die ökonomische Power auf das Level bekäme, bei dem man beim politischen Impact schon wäre? Bei Twitter, ja. Und das, also da sind ja wirklich noch ein paar Grenzen einzureißen. Ähm, beim Worshid Journal machen sich dann so Gedanken und stellen dann relativ zügig fest, na, es geht hier irgendwie nicht um Geld, er will auch nicht reicher werden, um was geht es ihm eigentlich? So, er hat also inhaltliche Vorstellungen. Und er war auf dieser Tett-Bühne. Das ist also diese Konferenz, wo jeder so eine 15-Minuten-Slot bekommt und dann irgendwie gute Ideen und so. Und wie soll man sagen? Es ist genau dieser Moment, das Angebot ist schon da, aber das Funding ist noch nicht secure. Das ist genau diese Wackelphase, wo er sich aber einladen lässt, weil er dann doch irgendwie schon darüber reden will, aber irgendwie dann doch nicht. Und Scott Galloway glaubt ja auch jetzt noch, dass es nicht zu diesem Deal kommt.
Das glauben einige.
Es ist ja diese Klausel drin, für eine Milliarde kann man einfach zurücktreten. Und der Impact ist ja jetzt schon da, auf Twitter. Also ich werde es auch nachher nochmal kurz vorlesen, wie er das Board da schon durcheinander gebracht hat. Naja, wir gucken mal in diese Ted-Talk-Veranstaltung rein. Es ist natürlich so, dass dort viele Vorträge gehalten werden, es sei denn, es kommt jemand von Relevanz. Der muss natürlich nicht vorbereitet mit irgendeinem Gesp... sondern der wird eigentlich mitfragen. Also der kann da einfach vorbeischneien und halt so ein bisschen spontan. Und die Art und Weise, in der Elon Musk das übertrieben hat, finde ich, wie soll ich sagen, es ist echt unanständig. Dieses Verhalten ist einfach unwürdig. Das will man auch nicht sehen, ich finde es einfach frech. Allerdings weiß er ja, wo er da ist. Also wir hören uns auch mal die Begrüßung vorher an.
Die Zukunft der Menschheit und dann findet man Elon Musk an, das ist so schlimm.
Vor allem in diesem Modus. Ich mein, Harald Schmidt hat damals immer jeden Gast als du bist mein Lieblingsgast begrüßt. Was ja immer hieß, die anderen sind alle Scheiße. Außer du. Du bist heute Abend hier.
Aber ich hab natürlich deinen Film nicht gesehen, dein Buch will ich aber auch nicht lesen.
Und ich finde, das geht auf der TED Talk Bühne nicht, dass man einfach alle anderen Referenten dort abqualifiziert mit. Aber jetzt kommt eigentlich der eigentliche. Das ist jetzt der richtige Visionär, der jetzt kommt. So, und wenn das wirklich stimmen würde, könnten wir nicht so, wir müssen es vielleicht auch ein bisschen beschreiben, denn Elon Musk wird ja nicht direkt gleich ins Gespräch einsteigen, sondern spielt ja auch sehr viel mit Mimik und so weiter. Aber ich finde es unsäglich.
Also, hast du den Film Ted über den Bären gesehen?
Diese Performance ist hochinteressant. Er grimassiert laufend und bewegt sich unruhig. Was er mitteilen will, ist, ich bin wirklich ein Visionär. Aber ich bin so visionär, dass ich euch das nicht gerade darlegen kann. Sondern in mir gibt es noch was, was schon so weit sieht und so viel weiß, dass es jetzt fast banal ist, mit einem gewöhnlichen Mensch, nämlich einem Moderator, da zu sitzen und eine Frage zu beantworten. Deswegen mache ich eigentlich nur Spökes.
Er kommt da rein mit so einer Haltung, ich bin der mächtigste Mann der Welt und ich kann euch alle in Verlegenheit bringen. Ohne, dass ich mich selber in Verlegenheit bringe. Sondern ich kann euch das einfach hier, ich kann euch alle mal richtig vor den Kopf stoßen.
Wer so ein Interview abliefert, wenn ich jetzt dann denke, man wäre im Radio eingeladen oder du beim Presseclub und du würdest so sprechen, dann würden die wahrscheinlich sagen, müssen wir nochmal abbrechen oder wir laden ihn zumindest nicht mehr ein.
Genau und dann zeigt er nochmal seine Macht, indem man dann einfach umschaltet und sagt, okay, wenn ihr wollt, dann sage ich euch halt den Satz, bei dem ihr mir zujubelt. Und dann ist das aber auch so, dann jubeln sie ihm gleich zu. Und die Situation so auszunutzen, die kleine Transferleistung sei vielleicht gestattet. Ja, so wie er das Gespräch hier führt, so kauft er auch Twitter. Ich kann euch alle in Verlegenheit bringen. Ich muss nur einfach ansagen, ich möchte Twitter kaufen und schubs, schreiben 10.000 Kommentatoren irgendwas über, oh, scheiße, was ist, wenn Donald Trump auf Twitter zurück ist und so. Und wir haben es hier einfach mit einem Irren zu tun, der sich die Welt einfach ausliefert, also sich die Welt ausliefert.
Der ja noch abhängig, aber ist von Kreditgebern. Es ist ja keineswegs so, dass er jetzt diese 44 Milliarden auf dem Sparbuch hat und die dorthin überweisen wird, sondern es ist ja so, dass er etwa die Hälfte der Summe sich leit. Und da offenbar Leute gefunden haben, die ihm das leihen, also Institutionen gefunden haben, die ihm das leihen. Und das andere wird ja dann bezahlt, vermutlich mit Tesla-Aktien.
Genau, es bedeutet aber insgesamt, Tesla gehört jetzt auch schon den Banken, BlackRock und so weiter. Ab sofort wird das halt umgeschichtet in Kredite, die auf seinen Namen laufen und es sind trotzdem noch die Banken im Hintergrund. Also es verändert sich gar nicht so viel, aber er ist plötzlich in dieser mächtigen Position, da einfach bestimmen zu können.
Es gibt jetzt so diesen Effekt, dass die Tesla-Aktie dadurch fällt, weil sie wissen, es wird ja Geld, es wird ja verkauft. Also er verkauft ja einen Teil der Aktienkauf mit diesem Twitter. Und wenn dann die Erwartung mit Twitter nicht eingehalten wird, dass das also wirklich profitabel im Sinne eines tollen Impacts, die man ausnutzen kann oder so wird, dass man dann eine Situation geschaffen hat, wo eigentlich diese Aktien noch beide in den Keller gehen könnten.
Genau, die Gefahr besteht insbesondere, weil es ja doch ein Meme-Stock ist, Tesla. Man investiert eben in Elon Musk. Und wenn man dann hört, der hängt da gar nicht mehr so groß drin und hat das auch so ein bisschen blöd, dann wird es auch unattraktiver. Es geht eben nicht nur um die Autos.
Ich frage mich ja auch, wie ist das für die institutionellen Anleger? Und die sind ja am Ende entscheidend. Hier geht es ja nicht um irgendwelche Bros, die Bitcoin im Twitter-Profil stehen haben und dann wegen mir 5.000 Euro in Tesla investiert haben, sondern es geht ja um die großen institutionellen. Und die sehen ja auch solche Auftritte. Und das sind ja auch institutionelle, die immer wieder sagen, ja das ist schon gut, dass Tim Cook immer mit einem Privatjet fliegt, weil wir müssen da vorsichtig sein mit so einer Person. Und die sehen ja jetzt hier eine Person, wo man denkt, puh, würde ich dem überhaupt mein Auto leihen für heute Nachmittag?
Ich frage mich das auch immer, wie das funktioniert. Seit er da bei Jerogen mit seinem Joint und so weiter. Das sind halt immer wieder diese Momente. Wir werden gleich noch sehr viel über seine Persönlichkeit hören. Zu dieser Idee, Twitter. Und was ist Twitter eigentlich? Im David McWilliams Podcast haben sie Mark Little eingeladen. Das ist ein ehemaliger Twitter-Manager. Wir lassen ihn uns mal vorstellen, um so ungefähr zu verstehen, welche Position das war.
Danke, dass du mich hast.
Mark, einer deiner Gigs war vor ein paar Jahren Vice-Präsident der Medien, und.
So, Vice President Media, keine Ahnung, in Europa. Er plaudert hier mal so ein bisschen. Wenn Elon Musk irgendwas von Free Speech, Arena usw. spricht, wie denken die so bei Twitter darüber?
Es ist, und das ist die Art, wie die Internet gerade geplant ist, dass es keinen richtigen Übersicht gibt. Aber ein konstantes Thema in all den Dingen, die ich gemacht habe, ist das Fakt, dass ich die Idee wirklich willkommen, dass wir nicht mehr dieses Gatekeeper-Elite-System haben. Wir haben sie nicht mehr bei Banken, Religion, aber auch die Medien. Hier ist das Problem. Wer soll dir zugegeben werden? Für mich ist es eine Art, eine Art Weg zu kommen, um diese Kontradiktion zu lösen.
Für wen stimmt das eigentlich? Wenn er sagt, die Banken haben ja schon gar keine, wie soll man sagen, Guidance-Möglichkeiten mehr, die sind powerless, die liegen einfach nur noch da. Für einen normalen Menschen mit einem normalen Einkommen, der sich ein normales Können eröffnet, stimmt das doch alles gar nicht.
Jeder, der sich ein Kredit nehmen muss, stimmt das nicht. Das stimmt für fast gar nichts. Das stimmt nur für eine Liga, für die das aber nie eine Rolle spielt. Es ist keine Frage von, wir genießen technischen Fortschritt, sondern die hatten ja immer alle Möglichkeiten.
Genau, alle sind nur noch Publikum und suchen nach Orientierung. Und die ganzen alten Gatekeeper sind weg. So, als müsste man biografisch durch keinen Nadelöhr mehr. Man kauft sich einfach ein Handy und ist der mächtigste Typ der Welt. Das ist doch alles. Aber die denken da so. Also hier hört man ja auch an diese Art, wie er das so vorträgt, dass das für die so handlungsleidend ist, wenn die so Twitter und so weiter gestalten.
Und welcher Stand der Debatte ist das eigentlich? Wir beschäftigen uns doch bestimmt jetzt in der öffentlichen Debatte seit 15 Jahren in Deutschland damit, welche Macht-Algorithmen haben. Wir wissen sehr genau, wie dieses Geschäftsmodell von Google funktioniert. Wir wissen, dass uns auf der ersten Seite nicht unbedingt das beste Ergebnis angezeigt wird, sondern das Ergebnis, das entsprechend lukrativer ist, nach oben zu bringen, beziehungsweise jemand hat dafür bezahlt. Wir wissen all das von Facebook, von Twitter. Wir wissen auch im Podcastgeschäft, dass es da Leute gibt, die über Netzwerke es schaffen, ihren Podcast zu pushen und dadurch immer nach oben gelenkt werden, ohne dass sie wirklich de facto Hörer haben. Es gibt da tausend Tricks, die angewandt werden. All das wissen wir. Und wir wissen aber, dass alles, was ich jetzt gerade aufgezählt habe, immer nur mit Kapital funktioniert. Das heißt, ich mach dir den Welthit. Wenn du mir eine Million gibst, dann kann ich das investieren. Und dann wird der überall gedudelt werden. Und bei TikTok kann man das sehr genau nachlesen, wie es ja diese Kooperationen da auch gibt. Also sie bieten die ja ganz öffentlich an. Und deswegen erleben wir es ja auch dann, dass irgendwelche alten Hits plötzlich viral werden. Und das ist ja ganz erstaunlich. Und das hat alles nur mit Gatekeepers zu tun und mit Kapital, um diese Gatekeeper manchmal zu kaufen, manchmal zu bestechen, wie auch immer. Und das ist nicht ein System mit, ja, das ist schon mal vorgekommen, dass jemand aus dem Nichts berühmt wurde und wirklich nur mit dem Smartphone was gemacht hat. Das kann sein. Aber das ist höchst unwahrscheinlich.
Ja, vor allem gerade jetzt in diesem Moment, wo wir wieder Quartalszahlen vorgelegt bekommen und die Börse irgendwie Google abstraft, weil sie nur 20, 1 Milliarden Jahresgewinn gemacht haben und man sich eigentlich mehr erwartet hat und so weiter. Auf der anderen Seite hat man diese riesigen Verarmungswellen da in Amerika und diskutiert diese neue Familienpolitik, zu der es dann aber ewig nicht kommt. Und da einfach so reinzugehen und sagen, ja, die alten Gatekeeper sind weg, jeder kämpft hier auf Augenhöhe und man braucht nur ein Handy und dann ist man so richtig dabei. Aber die gehen nachher einfach all in. Also er baut das mal hier weiter aus.
Ich bin in Iowa, in einem Diner, wo die Leute in diesem Diner alle sämtliche Präsidenten für 50 Jahre gesehen haben. Sobald das Internet zentralisiert wird, möchte ich mehr Macht an Menschen geben, um einen Label zu haben, wie dein Food-Label, um zu verstehen, warum diese Information da ist. Ich denke, das wird uns beginnen zu sehen. Mehr Contentmoderation, bessere Contentmoderation, Regulation, die das Internet mehr transparent macht, die Technik-Plattformen mehr erstaunlich machen, die Arbeit, die ich in Kinzen mache, ist die Erwarnung von Missinformationen und Missinformationen. Nur mehr Macht und Kontext zurückgeben zu den Individuen.
Für was hat er denn jetzt eigentlich argumentiert? Geldkeeper abzubauen oder Neuer aufzubauen? Für beides. Das ist so shit zu freen, wenn man sich das anhört, wie die darüber reden. Ja, dann sammeln sich halt ganz viele Leute, aber die verteilen ja dann so Labels der Reputation untereinander und orientieren sich dann daran und finden so neue Leistungsrollen, wo man sich denkt, nee, wieso lässt man nicht einfach die Alten weiter ihre Stiftung Warentest lesen und die haben dann schon rausgefunden, nach welchen Kriterien sie welche Produkte bewerten sollen. Warum muss das jetzt im Internet irgendwie, ah, Egon hat wieder getwittert, dass das aber super geil ist, also kaufe ich jetzt Dogecoin und so. Das ist doch, also das ist so hanebüchen dieser Art von Ideologie irgendwie zu hören. In so einem, und sie wissen ja selber nicht, warum Twitter so viele Nutzer hat und diesen großen Impact hat, aber sie werkeln halt die ganze Zeit auf ihrer eigenen Theorieebene da irgendwie an diesem riesigen lebenden Objekt darum und kommen dann mit solchen Objekte und so weiter und so. Das ist einfach gruselig.
Und glaubst du, das hängt auch stark damit zusammen, dass da nach wie vor im Silicon Valley dieser Anarchist, na ich will es nicht Anarchengeist, es ist doch schon fast so ein so ein anarchistischer Traum einer herrschaftsfreien Ordnung existiert, dass man glaubt, man könnte herrschaftsfreie Räume schaffen mit ganz ganz vielen Leuten und man aber dann immer fragt ja, herrschaftsfreie Räume auf so einer Mikroebene, da gibt es ja Beispiele, dass das umsetzbar ist und David Graeber könnte uns jetzt viele nennen und wir können sie nochmal nachlesen in seinem Buch. Aber wenn wir auf so einer größeren Organisationsebene sind, dann ist ja die Frage, wie das organisiert ist, immer eine Nachherrschaft und diese Herrschaft kann jetzt personell sein und ich glaube deswegen arbeiten sich jetzt auch gerade so viele an Twitter ab. Es ist jetzt nicht so, als hätten wir gerade noch eine öffentlich-rechtliche Plattform gehabt und nun kommt der böse Elon Musk und dann auch Jack Dorsey ist ja mit vor sich zu genießen. Ja, aber wir haben jetzt so ein klares Feindbild wieder. Der sieht ja auch mittlerweile aus, Elon Musk, wie aus so einem Pixar-Film oder sowas. Und wir müssen aber anerkennen, selbst wenn es jetzt Elon Musk nicht gäbe und wenn das bei Twitter so weiter laufen würde, wie es es tut, dann haben wir ja trotzdem eine algorithmische Macht. Wir haben eine hierarchische Struktur, wir haben ein System der blauen Haken. Also wir haben Twitter-Profile, die mit dem blauen Haken nicht nur besonders verifiziert sind, sondern auch besonders häufig angezeigt werden und und und und es ist ja auch kein Zufall, wem was angezeigt wird. Das heißt, die Idee, dass das ein herrschaftsfeier Raum sein könnte, ist ja vollkommener Nonsens.
Genau und da kommt jetzt Elon Musk selbst ins Spiel. Er versucht jetzt mal das, was Mark Little hier gerade beschrieben hat, nämlich die alten Gatekeeper wieder weg, aber die neuen Gatekeeper auch irgendwie hin und keine Ahnung, dann machen wir das halt so mit Labels oder so. Er versucht es jetzt hier mal auf einer technisch umsetzbaren Art und Weise runterzubrechen.
Es ist wirklich wichtig, dass die Leute die Realität und die Perception haben, dass sie frei sprechen können, innerhalb der Bindung der法.
Und also eine der Dinge, die ich glaube, Twitter soll tun, ist, den Algorithmus zu öffnen.
Und sich die Tweet zu ändern, damit die Tweet nicht verletzt werden, damit niemand sieht, dass diese Tweet verwendet wurde. Es gibt also keine Hintergrundkarte, die man manuell oder algorithmisch verwendet wird.
Die Idee, durch Open-Sourcing von dem ganzen Zeug Transparenz zu schaffen, ist hane Büchen, die Leute verstehen meistens nicht mal Tweets, die man schreibt. Und es reicht nicht, was auf der Hinterbühne technisch mit diesem Tweet passiert.
Das kann man sich dann mal bei heise erklären lassen oder bei netzpolitik.org.
Genau.
Und unser eins liest das dann vielleicht mal, aber das wird ja keineswegs so sein, dass der normale Twitter-User sagt, ach so, haben die das jetzt gerade für mich kuratiert.
Genau. Also wir bräuchten sowas wie, was es alles gibt jetzt, Bundestagswatch, Abgeordneten, Befragungen und so weiter. Irgendwer muss sich dann darum kümmern, dass solche Ordet wirklich passieren. Aber wer hat Lust drauf, sich für alle Tweets, und es werden ungefähr 1 Milliarde pro Sekunde geschrieben, da irgendwie, also man kriegt vielleicht mal durch Initiative von irgendweben so einen Überblick, bis dann noch damals, als es diese Tweet-Welle gab, dieser Shitstorm und so weiter, dann kommt so Monate später irgendwie eine Aufarbeitung davon. Aber das irgendwie live und dann auch sozusagen mit Handlungsleitend, während man gerade twittert, zu organisieren und nicht zu glauben, das ist aber vor der Bühne und wir haben die Hinterbühne versteckt, sondern wirklich den Anspruch zu haben, hier ist aber gerade alles transparent, ist einfach, also das ist einfach der totale Blödsinn.
Und die Transparenzideologie, die hier drinsteckt, meint ja auch, dass man dadurch, dass man es weiß, zum reflektierteren User sofort wird. Das ist ja auch nicht der Fall. Ich will zwei Beispiele nennen, einmal eins außerhalb von Twitter. Man kann ja leicht sich so ein Programm unterladen oder man hat es vielleicht auch auf dem Laptop schon, dass man sich anzeigen kann, von wem wird man da gerade getrackt und wo hat man irgendwelche Cookies am Bein. Ja, das könnte man immer machen, aber macht man das? Ich glaube eher nicht. Also ich bin da faul und gestehe das auch. Und der zweite Fall ist, wir haben die Twitter-Trends. Wir wissen, in Deutschland sind die Trends relativ schnell herzustellen. Ich glaube, wenn wir uns jetzt alle hier im Podcastshow abreden würden, wir tweeten morgen zwischen 10 und 12 Uhr mittags zu einem gewissen Hashtag. Wir haben genug Hörer, damit wir da irgendwie mal in die Trends kommen könnten. Und wir wissen also, diese Trends funktionieren im Prinzip so, dass man da so ein paar reichweitenstarke Profile hat. Die können sich sogar vorher absprechen oder tun es nicht. Oder es ist so eine Blase, wo man weiß, da kommt jetzt gleich wieder was. Und dann gibt es diese Trends. Das bedeutet aber nicht, dass die Leute, die das alle wissen, sagen, ah ja, das ist da dieses komische Ding, dann Trends. Ich mache mal weiter hier meinen Kram auf Twitter. Sondern sie sagen, ach ja, das ist diese Idiotie mit den Trends. Und dann fängt man aber an, obwohl man um die Idiotie weiß, selbst mit diesen Trends zu entfachen und zu torpedieren und weiter zu perpetuieren. Und wir haben es hier mit der Idee zu tun, dass der reflexive User dann dadurch entsteht. Also das würde ja selbst Habermas sich nicht erkühlen zu träumen.
Ja, ich meine, Habermas hat sich gerade mal so ran getraut an diese alte Welt. Gut, er publiziert das nochmal neu und so. Mal abwarten, ob er den Text noch ausbaut. Der war ja schon 90 Seiten lang, den du da gelesen hast. Aber das Problem politisch, das wir ja gerade haben mit irgendwelchen Menschen, die Lügenpresse schreien, ist, dass schon der Ablauf einer einstündigen Redaktionskonferenz nicht zu vermitteln ist. Ich glaube, den Hund hören wir nicht, der da draußen ist. Den hören nur wir beide hoffentlich, aber wenn, ist auch egal. Also schon eine Redaktionskonferenz wird als zu, das kriegen wir den Leuten nie erklärt, wir laden sie alle ein, wir machen hier Live-Streaming, man kann hier hospitieren, wie auch immer. Schon das ist zu kompliziert, wenn man sich das alles technisch übertragen und wirklich mikromäßig in jede einzelne Äußerung zerlegt, dann anschaut, das ist einfach... So, Elon Musk geht trotzdem hier all in, also der übertreibt einfach völlig. Wir wissen ja bisher, wie er über seine Autos und seine Raketen sprach. Jetzt hat er sein Portfolio eben um Twitter oder möchte es erweitern.
Das ist nicht ein Weg, Geld zu machen.
Er spricht von einer Zukunft der Zivilisation, die davon abhängt, dass es eine Möglichkeit gibt, Transparenz zu kommunizieren. Das Internet ist ja da. Es gibt ja Gründe, warum er so viel Geld für Twitter ausgeben will. Twitter ist ja nicht die einzige Möglichkeit, sein Wort zu publizieren. Das wird überhaupt nicht reflektiert, darum kommt man auch in dem Gespräch nicht zurück. Das ist einfach brutal, wie sehr er eigentlich weiß, was Twitter bedeutet und es hier einfach im Unklar lässt und so ganz abstrahiert von der Zivilisation usw. spricht. Mark Little, der uns ja eben auch schon mal so ein bisschen, das ist so die eigentliche Ideologie, er kommt hier auch noch mal über die Free Speech Arena und wie weit muss man es treiben?
Ich denke, ich würde generell für eine öffentliche Fläche, wie ein öffentliches Media, wo wir alle die selbe Plattform teilen und dann Plätze kreieren, wo wir gehen können, wo wir sagen, was wir wollen, anonym. Die Erkennung einer öffentlichen Utilität, wo wir alle zusammen sind, und dann für finanzielle Hilfen oder für kleinere Kommunen und Plattformen, die ihren eigenen Weg haben, die ihren eigenen Regeln setzen. Aber Anonymität, das zu enden, ist kein Silberbullett und könnte unvergessliche Konsequenzen wie jede mögliche Reform der Internet kreieren. Und das ist das, warum das so schwierig ist.
Anonymität und Free Speech, das sind nur die beiden Leitplanken für die Typen. Also da wird es mir echt ein bisschen mulmig.
Und glaubst du denn, dass Trump zurückkommt? Lässt man ihn wieder?
Also Scott Galloway hat ja häufig recht. Gerade bei Elon Musk. Deswegen wurde er ja auch häufig von Musk beleidigt auf Twitter. Ich glaube, es wird tatsächlich nie zu diesem Deal so kommen. Und Trump hat ja von sich aus schon gesagt, er würde nicht wollen. Er geht jetzt da auf seine Plattform, die eben keiner nutzt.
Genau.
Das ist ja auch für ihn so.
Da muss doch irgendwas dann passieren.
Ich glaube sowieso nicht, dass Trump, also eher den Willen, aber er wird es nicht schaffen, sich politisch noch mal so ein Spiel zu bringen. Dafür sind die Republikaner jetzt auch dann doch zugeschlossen, gemeinsam mit einem Ziel aufgestellt und werden sich nicht noch mal so die Köpfe rasieren lassen. Aber mal sehen. Musk hier auf der Bühne erscheitert an seinem eigenen Anspruch.
Und wenn das der Fall ist, dann haben wir freie Sprache.
Die ja er selbst nicht aushält, die Situation.
Es ist jemand, der versucht, Journalisten klein zu machen, der versucht, dass keine Gewerkschaften gegründet werden und sonst was. Er ist ja nicht jemand, der sagt, ja dann mach doch mal freien Meinungsaustausch. Dann werden wir mal sehen, welches bessere Argument sich durchsetzt.
Die New York Times hat noch mal so eine kleine Chronik getickert. Von der Ankündigung bis zu Funding Secured und so weiter. Er hat hart gegen Viya Yagade gezwittert, die ist die Top-Lawyer bei Twitter und war eben auch als zuständig für Content Policies. Worunter unter anderem fällt, maßgeblich die Entscheidung herbeizuführen, Trump dann wirklich mal von der Plattform zu nehmen. Und dieses Giftszwittere gegen sie, inklusive dieser ganzen Musk-Meute, die dann so hinterher schwemmt, hat dann echt zu diesem ganzen kontroversen Gefühl, dass zum einen sehr viele aufgewühlte Mitarbeiter von Twitter sich auch erstmal öffentlich so, ey, das kann aber echt nicht sein. Und selbst Dick Costollo, der Twitter-Chef von 2010 bis 2015, hat dann auf Twitter nochmal geschrieben, ey, Bullying is not leadership. Also die müssen sich echt auch erstmal wehren jetzt. So gegen Elon Musk und das ist wirklich krass. Und jetzt ist ja die große Frage. Kriegt man es eingehegt? Er hat sehr viel Geld, heißt das denn automatisch gleich politische Macht? Oder müsste man nicht mal von außen und so weiter? Und Scott Galloway und Kara Swisher haben ja so darüber gesprochen, dass Obama viele Chancen nicht genutzt hat. Dafür aber immer große Reden hielt. Also irgendwie so. Aber liebe Unternehmen, wir motivieren euch jetzt mal irgendwie für die Zukunft Amerikas. Und dann kam es ja nie dazu, sondern alle haben ihre Ausbeuterökonomie, BWL, weitergefahren. Und daran anschließend sagt dann Kara Swisher hier mal so, mit den Reden sollte jetzt mal Schluss sein. Wir brauchen jetzt Regulierung. Aber komm schon, ich meine, einer der Dinge ist, dass Trump diese Unternehmen auch sehr kritisch war. Aber ich denke, diese Politiker sind sehr hinter.
Ich habe wirklich viel Respekt für President Obama.
Aber ich denke, die Sprechen, und wir sollten uns für uns selbst fassen, sind, versuch nicht, Zigaretten zu trinken, obwohl sie betrunken sind.
Versuch nicht, diese Schwierigkeiten zu essen.
Aber ich denke, es ist...
An die Trust Klobucar zu sprechen, genau. Und sagen, ja, also man muss es dann halt einfach mal machen. Die Anhörungen waren ja alle und man weiß jetzt auch, worum es da geht. Wie wichtig es ist, hat dann Elon Musk selber auf der Bühne nochmal verlautbaren lassen. Er hatte ja damals diesen Tweet gemacht, der ihm ja sehr viel Ärger eingebracht hat. Funding secured, ich werde Tesla von der Börse nehmen. Und dann hat er irgendwie mit irgendwelchen Saudi-Arabischen Finanziers oder so, keine Ahnung, so ein Deal abgesprochen, angeblich. Dann hat die SEC die Börsen auf sich zu ihm gesagt, hör mal zu, so geht das nicht. Du kannst nicht so börsenrelevante News, vor allem, wenn sie gelogen sind, nicht so öffentlich kundgeben, woraufhin es dann einen großen Rechtsstreit gab, weil er eben sagte, nee, das ist secured. Und just in dieser Woche wurde er, also wurde das Urteil nochmal bestätigt. Nein, Elon Musk, du hast damals gelogen. Und ja, es bleibt dabei, deine Tweets müssen vorher nochmal von einem Anwalt begutachtet werden. Du kannst nicht einfach so twittern. Also die Strafe bleibt. Und in dieser, ich bin gerade nochmal quasi neu frisch verurteilt worden. Und die Lüge von mir ist bekannt, äußert er sich so auf der Bühne.
Aber sie haben eine aktive öffentliche Beobachtung nicht weniger.
Er sitzt auf der Bühne, redet über die Aufsichtsbehörden, die für ihn zuständig sind, beschimpft sie mit Bastards und das Publikum findet es cool.
Und wenn wir mal eine Parallele ziehen, das ist doch ganz typisch. Wir können das häufig sehen bei solchen Akteuren, gerade auch aus dem neoliberal-rechten Spektrum bei Twitter. Man liebt Free Speech, wenn das bedeutet, dass die Kapitalmacht, die man hat, man komplett austoben kann. Und das macht man. Man kann die auch noch als Bastards beschimpfen. Und zugleich kann man aber jene, die sich auch einer solchen Sprache bedienen würde, sofort mit einem Tross von Anwälten verklagen. Richtig. Und dann kann man gegen die vorgehen und dann sagt man, naja, gut, das ist ja dann Jurist der Reihe, das hat ja jetzt nichts mit Meinungsfreiheit oder so zu tun. Ich gehe da mal gegen vor. Und das können wir bei einigen großen Kanzleien, die auch in Deutschland erleben, dass das so stattfindet. Und es ist ganz erstaunlich, dass gerade die, die immer so sehr für die Meinungsfreiheit da scheinen zu kämpfen, sofort klagen und sie wollen einfach nur ihre Kapitalinteressen ungestört durchsetzen können. Und da soll die Meinungsfreiheit dann nicht stören.
Genau, ist ein bisschen wie Mark Zuckerberg und Facebook. Und dieses Ganze, jeder hat da ein Profil und darf bewertet werden. Aber sein Privatwohnsitz wird natürlich umrahmt von Ländereien, die er alle aufgekauft hat, um da einfach in Privatsphäre zu leben. Aber eben nicht juristisch abgesichert, sondern einfach ökonomisch, einfach alles aufgekauft, was im Blickweite ist. Musk sitzt hier auf der Bühne. Statt dass dieser Ted Talk ihn mal so richtig jetzt auch befragt und so weiter, hat man so mittendrin gemerkt, nach 20 Minuten wusste er auch nicht mehr, was er mit ihm eigentlich reden will, weshalb sie so übers Biografische zu sprechen kamen. Und nach der Thematisierung seines Autismus, einer dieser Asperger-Varianten, sagt Elon Musk noch mal Folgendes und das ist, was ist hier los, Frankfurt. Das ist einfach jetzt der April, alle sind aus der Kirche ausgetreten, aber sie will uns sagen, dass sie noch da ist. Also Elon Musk.
Ich bin aber sehr fürs Glocken, das wollte, glaube ich, die FDP mal abschaffen und natürlich müssen die Glocken weiter läuten.
Okay, lass mal das mal so dahingestellt.
Du merkst, ich bleibe ein christlicher Konservativer.
Ja, aber du weißt auch genau das Gebäude, eins nebenan ist die Kirche. Also Elon Musk auf der Bühne, sein Autismus wurde betont. Wir haben seine Ideologie hier so ein bisschen angeleuchtet und er gibt noch mal folgenden Spruch.
Ja, ich glaube, ein Aspekt von der Kondition, die ich hatte, war, ich war einfach absolut besoffen mit der Wahrheit.
Ja, also mit so einem Wahrheitsideologie Anspruch kann man nicht an Twitter herantreten. Da geht es nicht um Technik, sondern es ist Sozialität. Sonst könnte man ja einfach das Internet kaufen.
Was will er denn auch eigentlich? Also zum einen sagt er jetzt, er ist für Wahrheit und das ist ja eine ganz positivistische Aussage. Bezieht sich da dann auf die Physik und da kann man zwischen Wahr und Falsch sehr einfach unterscheiden. Und dann gibt es aber diese Sphäre der Meinung, da ist Wahr und Falsch überhaupt gar keine Kategorie dann für ihn oder was. Oder will er das dann am Ende noch verbinden und dann ist seine Wahrheit zugleich auch die richtige Meinung und alles andere muss sanktioniert werden. Das ist dann nämlich genau dieses juristische Level, das wir erreichen. Und dieser Positivismus macht mir ja wirklich große Sorgen, weil wir das immer wieder in Debatten haben. Wir erinnern uns vielleicht noch an diese Rezo-Geschichte, wo er in einem Video nachvollziehen wollte, wie die Journalisten in Deutschland falsch über ihn berichtet hatten und er dann aber gar nicht das journalistische Schreiben verstand, also Metaphern wortwörtlich nahm oder auch so Äußerungen wie die meisten seiner User sind jung. Und dann sagt er ja, aber was heißt die meisten? Ja, und ich habe einen guten Freund, der jetzt einen Anwaltsbrief bekommen hat für eine Reportage, die Jahre alt ist und über eine Person aus dem Wirtschaftsleben und das ist aber eine Reportage, die einfach so ein Event betrachtet und dann fallen da so Sätze wie Funktionsjackenträger, soweit das Auge reicht und dann steht halt im Anwalt schreiben, ja, das Stimme-Nicht-Hier sei ein Foto, man könnte ganz klar erkennen, dass da auch Menschen ohne Funktionsjacke sitzen. Ja, also die genau dann nämlich in so eine positivistische Wahrheit kommen.
Aber die sind geschädigte, wie die der Anwalt spricht?
Ja, für den, der da porträtiert wird in dieser Reportage. Und es werden halt einfach so positivistische Kriterien an einen vöhetonistischen Text angelegt und damit soll jetzt diese Meinungsfreiheit als Fake-News dargestellt werden, also die vöhetonistische Freiheit. Und wenn er jetzt hier zum einen über so Free Speech spricht und jetzt aber auch zugleich noch diesen Aspekt reinbringt, ja ich bin besessen von der Wahrheit, dann können wir uns auch ausmalen, dass da so ein libertäres Wahrheitsministerium gerade bei Twitter aufgebaut wird.
Ja, man muss sich das eh... Wahrheit ist natürlich das eine, aber was ist mit Wirklichkeit und so? Und man könnte ihm auch genauso gut sagen, naja, wenn ein Richter ein Urteil spricht und andere Richter das bestätigen, dann haben die auch in gewisser Hinsicht soziale Wahrheit ausgedrückt. Und wenn du da gelogen hast und das ist so analysiert, begutachtet und dann richterlich bestätigt worden, dann hast du da gelogen. Dann kannst du nicht auf der Bühne sitzen und sagen, das sind aber Bastards, die haben gelogen. Sondern das ist dann schon geklärt in diesem Moment.
Aber das ist ja wie Trump, zu sagen, ich habe die Wahl gewonnen.
Genau, das ist dann einfach die eigene Realität. Aber das hat mit Wahrheit relativ wenig zu tun. Es gibt hier einen Clip, den können wir mal kurz anspielen. Das Wall Street Journal stellt Projekte vor mit den Silicon Valley-Führer. Und wir nehmen ihn mal dazu, gerade mit Starlink. Versuchen, er will jetzt Twitter kaufen, eine Stufe abstrahiert, das Internet selbst aus den Fängen der Politik und, wie soll man sagen, auch andere Wirtschafts- und Konkurrenz zu befreien, indem man es nämlich einfach über den Weltraum regelt.
Facebook wollte es mit solar-gebliebenen Drohnen machen. Das Flugzeug, namens Aquila, ist für 90 Tage über Wettersysteme geflogen, bringt die Verbindung zu hohen Regionen, wo die Sol-Tauern oder das fiber-optische Kabel vielleicht schwierig zu erledigen sind. Loon ist ein Netzwerk von freiflohrenden stratospherischen Ballonen. Und jedes Loonballon hat eine Antenne, die das Internet – wie man es sich vorstellen kann – als Kone des Umfangs auf dem Boden verwendet. Und in 2019 hat Amazon ein eigenes Internetprojekt eröffnet.
Ja, Kuiper und so weiter. Dann kommt auch noch Starlink und andere Sachen. Und wir kennen ja aus diesem BND, also Snowden und so weiter, da wurde ja die Weltraumtheorie irgendwann vorgebracht, in dem es nämlich hieß, ja, der BND und die Zuständigkeiten und überhaupt das Internet kam ja aus dem Weltraum. Und das ist ja extra territorial, da haben wir ja gar keinen Zugriff und deswegen durften wir da, also da gibt es keine Zuständigkeit, deswegen durften wir da eigentlich alles abgreifen. Da gelten dann die Regeln nicht und so weiter. Und was ist, wenn die das jetzt für sich beanspruchen, diese Theorie, dass sie einfach sagen, naja, also ich habe jetzt Strahlen aus dem Weltraum auf den Boden geleitet, warum gilt jetzt für mich irgendwie, dann ist ja die Frage, welches Gesetz eigentlich. Und da hat hier der Kölner Stadtanzeiger und da kann man auch mal wieder überprüfen, ja, stimmt eigentlich. Wir hören die Presseschau des Deutschlandfunk letzte Woche, als das alles mit Elon Musk und so weiter, also war auch großes Thema. Und dieses eine Thema, von dem man denkt, ey, das müsste doch mal, nur der Kölner Stadtanzeiger hat es nochmal so aufgegriffen, dass es dann zumindest am Ende der Sendung, kurz vor Mitternacht, so kurz vor den Hymnen, nochmal kurz angesprochen wurde.
Mit Twitter wird Musk kein leichtes Spiel haben. Weniger wegen der Geschäftsaussichten, die für ihn offenbar zweitrangig sind. Vielmehr brockt sich Musk einen Haufen Ärger ein. Denn Twitter ist eine Plattform, die vor Hass und Hetze strotzt. Sollte die Übernahme gelingen, wird Musk feststellen, dass unbegrenzte Meinungsfreiheit zu viel Unfug führt. Und für den hat er als Firmeneigner geradezustehen. Eben erst hat sich die EU auf den Digital Services Act geeinigt, ein halbherziger Kampf gegen Hetze könnte für Twitter teuer werden.
So, der Digital Services Act ist fertig. Wir werden uns dann im nächsten Monat mal angucken, in welcher Form. Und wir haben sowieso noch viel Zeit. Denn jetzt laufen erst mal wieder zwei Jahre, die das Gesetz einfach nur so da ist, damit sich alle dran gewöhnen. Bevor es dann überhaupt mal greift. Und dann dauert es ja wieder eine Weile, bis man weiß, was greift denn da jetzt eigentlich. Also in deren Sicht viel Zeit für Elon Musk, noch einiges kaputt zu machen.
Und das heißt jetzt, der Kölner Stadtanzeiger hat diese beiden Dinge mal zusammengebracht und gedacht. Sonst aber geht das einfach parallel. Oder man kann sagen, das eine findet so gut wie gar nicht statt. Der Digital Service Act findet fast nicht statt. Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir dann Elon Musk und die große Show und Twitter.
Ja, und der DSA und eben auch der Markets Act, das sind ja gigantische Projekte. Also das ist ja über Jahre und Monate Vorbereitungszeit ewig, noch im Schulterschluss mit Amerika. Man guckt sich so gegenseitig an, wie weit kann man es treiben. Und es versandet einfach komplett. Da muss nur Elon Musk. Vielleicht ist auch diese ganze Twitter-Action wirklich nur dafür da, um dieses Gesetzkleid zu bügeln. Ja, man weiß es ja aber nicht. Da zumindest nicht so viel Aufmerksamkeit und was auch immer. Aber es ist wirklich ein Trauerspiel. Das muss man einfach sagen.
Wir haben hier ein Thema, das aus dem März ist, das aber keineswegs an Aktualität verloren hat. Denn das ist ein wissenschaftlicher Fortschritt, den man da erzielt hat, der ganz erstaunlich ist. Und zwar Niels Bierbaumer. Den werden vielleicht manche schon mal gehört haben. Das ist ein Forscher, der sich damit auseinandersetzt, wie kann man eigentlich mit Patienten, die ein totales Locked-In-Syndrom haben, darunter leiden, also die auch nicht mehr die Möglichkeit haben, mit den Augen zum Beispiel zu kommunizieren, wie kann man mit denen sprechen? Und ist da überhaupt was, mit wem man sprechen kann? Also sind das Menschen, wo die Kommunikation eigentlich noch funktionieren kann, aber es nicht mehr tut, weil sie sich nicht mehr in irgendeiner Weise äußern können, keinen Finger heben können oder so. Also es ist nicht wie bei Stephen Hawking, der dann doch noch so minimal Bewegungen machen konnte, um was zu steuern, sondern was ist, wenn diese Patienten überhaupt keine Möglichkeit mehr haben, sich zu äußern? Vor ein paar Jahren war das bei Björn Maum mal so, dass er schon mal in renommierten Zeitschriften Forschungen präsentierte, Ergebnisse präsentierte, die sensationell schienen, ist aber dann doch nicht ganz so wahren, zumindest gab es dann Kritik daran. Wir hören mal ganz kurz in den Deutschlandfunkbeitrag, in einen aktuellen hinein, wo uns das ein bisschen aufgeschlüsselt wird.
Nils Bierbaumer, dessen Karriere erlitt jedoch im Jahr 2017 einen Knick. Er hatte damals eine Studie veröffentlicht an sogenannten Locked-In-Patienten, die vollkommen bewegungsunfähig sind. Professor Bierbaumer wollte bewiesen haben, dass man mit diesen Menschen kommunizieren kann über eine sogenannte Hirn-Computer-Schnittstelle, also über Sensoren an der Kopfhaut. Die sollten sozusagen die Gedanken lesen können. Aber ein Kollege wies Bierbaumer und seinem Team methodische Fehler in dieser Studie nach, sodass sie zurückgezogen werden musste. Also ein großer Skandal. Heute nun setzt der Forscher zum zweiten Versuch an, mit einer neuen Veröffentlichung im renommierten Fachmagazin Nature Communications.
Also er ist nicht zur Person an, nur ein Krater geworden, aber die Reputation hat gelitten. Viele Wissenschaftsjournalisten haben sich dann auch auf die eine oder andere Seite geschlagen. Das soll uns hier aber mal gar nicht interessieren. Uns geht es um das Ergebnis, wenn man jetzt gehört. Diese alte Studie, die da an einem Patienten durchgeführt wurde, sah so aus, dass man Sensoren außerhalb des Kopfes hatte, die dann mit dem Gehirn kommunizierten. Und das wurde dann übertragen. Jetzt hat man eine neue Methode, dass man also gleich in das Gehirn diese, ich sage jetzt einfach mal, Chips oder Drähte eingebaut hat. Wir hören jetzt Christine Westerhaus, die das kurz einschätzt.
Also ich habe mehrere Experten nach ihrer Einschätzung befragt und sie sagen, dass diese Methode auf jeden Fall plausibel erscheint. In der neuen Studie haben sie die Hirnaktivität direkt über eingepflanzte Elektroden abgeleitet, also direkt an den Nervenzellen.
Der 37-jährige Patient liegt auf dem Rücken im Bett. Er ist vollständig gelähmt und wird künstlich beatmet. Nicht einmal die Augen kann er bewegen. Und dennoch ist es den Forschern gelungen, mit diesem Mann zu kommunizieren, wie die in Nature's Communications veröffentlichte Studie zeigt. Und zwar mit Hilfe von 162 Mikroelektroden, die dem Patienten ins Gehirn gepflanzt wurden, sagt der Tübinger Forscher Nils Bierbaumer.
Wenn das eingepflanzt ist, machen sie die Schädeldecke wieder zu. Und da kommt dann nur ein Draht raus. Und dieser Draht vermittelt die Feuerrate der Zellen in diesem Teil des Gehirns.
Also ich muss mal sagen, dieses Thema, was wir gerade besprechen, ist für mich eines der düstersten überhaupt. Dieses Szenario-Lock-Innen.
Ich will dir vielleicht die Angst ganz nehmen. Für mich war das auch eins. Ich habe den Artikel gelesen, es gibt da jetzt diese Erkenntnis und dachte, oh Gott, ist das alles fürchterlich. Und dann kann man zwar jetzt kommunizieren, aber wir werden jetzt gleich was ganz Überraschendes hören. Und deswegen bringe ich das auch hier, weil ich auch erst mal, wenn wir das jetzt so hören, klingt das furchtbar. Klar, das ist eine unglaubliche technische Errungenschaft, aber wer möchte in einer solchen Situation sein? Natürlich niemand. Und man würde sagen, ist das überhaupt eine, ich benutze jetzt hier mal den Ausdruck in Anführungszeichen, lebenswerte Situation, wenn man sich überhaupt befinden kann. Dazu kommen wir gleich. Wir bleiben noch ein bisschen bei dieser technischen Umsetzung.
Die ersten 80 Tage nach dem Eingriff passierte erst mal nichts. Dann versuchte es Bierbaumer mit einem Neuro-Feedback-System, um dem Patienten beizubringen, wie er seine Gehirnströme steuern kann.
Der Patient wird in die Lage versetzt, sein eigenes Gehirn zu hören. Das heißt, er hat einen Ton gehört. Es geht so biiiii Wenn es so geht, dann heißt es mehr Zellenfeuern. Und wenn der Ton tiefer wird, heißt es weniger Zellenfeuern.
Der Computer lernte dem Feuern der Neuronen ein Ja oder Nein zuzuordnen.
Im Moncrieff News Talk war ein Kollege oder ich glaube sein Assistent zu Gast, Uiwal Shotari. Und auch hier wird mal ein bisschen erklärt, wie das funktioniert, wie der Patient kommuniziert.
Wenn er ein A-Kontakt wählen möchte, dann ist A die zweite Wahl.
Dann kommt er ins Programm.
Dann sagt er ein A-Kontakt mit einer Z-Kontakt.
Aber wenn er ein Z-Kontakt wählt, dann muss er zuerst ein A-Kontakt mit einer Z-Kontakt wählen, dann muss er zuerst ein A-Kontakt mit einer Z-Kontakt wählen, dann muss er zuerst ein A-Kontakt mit einer Z-Kontakt wählen, dann muss er zuerst ein A-Kontakt mit einer Z-Kontakt wählen, dann muss er zuerst ein A-Kontakt mit einer Z-Kontakt wählen, dann muss er zuerst ein A-Kontakt mit einer Z-Kontakt wählen, dann muss er zuerst.
Ein A-Kontakt mit einer Z-Kontakt wählen, dann muss er zuerst ein A-Kontakt mit einer Z-Kontakt wählen, dann muss er zuerst ein A-Kontakt mit einer Z-Kontakt wählen, Und dann, wenn du sie alle kennen kannst, dann sag doch nein zu allen, und dann gehst du bis zum Ende zu sie. Noch mal ein Beitrag aus Wissenschaft und Technik. Auf den Videos, die in der Studie zu sehen sind, hört sich das so an.
Ein Durchbruch, sagt Soyo Sukadar von der Berliner Charité. Er ist Einstein-Professor für klinische Neurotechnologie und befasst sich auch mit Hirn-Computerschnittstellen. Was hier besonders war, ist, er konnte praktisch einzelne Buchstaben auswählen. Man nennt das einen Speller. Und konnte damit ganze Sätze formulieren. Einer der ersten Sätze war zum Beispiel, dass er sich bei Herrn Bierbaumer bedanken wollte, dass er die Möglichkeit hat, überhaupt zu kommunizieren. Später hat er dann Sätze formuliert, wie sein größter Wunsch wäre es, in einem neuen Bett zu liegen und...
Bierbaumer hasst übrigens Elon Musk. Er sagt, das sei ein Schwätzer. Und er sollte sein Geld lieber wirklich der Forschung zur Verfügung stellen, die ernsthaft forscht und nicht wieder ein neues Profit-Ding daraus schöpfen will und gucken will, ob man dann mit dem Hirn noch irgendwelche Kaufentscheidungen treffen kann. Sondern hier geht es wirklich darum zu sagen, wir kommunizieren. Hier geht es nicht darum, ich lenke die Welt mit meinem Gehirn und muss nichts mehr sagen. Sondern es geht darum, einen Weg zu finden, wie Menschen wieder kommunizieren können. Deswegen ist Bill Warmer da auch ganz gegen Elon Musk. Wir hören ja einen kleinen Beitrag aus einem Video vom Wyss-Institut, das diese neue Forschung jetzt vorgestellt hat, weil die dann ja auch technisch damit zusammenarbeiten. Das ist ja eine größere Kooperation, dass sowas überhaupt funktionieren kann. Von den Patienten wissen wir nicht viel. Wir wissen, es ist ein junger Mann, der mit Ende 20, Anfang 30 daran erkrankt ist, an dieser besonderen Form von ALS, die dann dazu führt, dass man vollkommen bewegungsunfähig wird und in diesen totalen Locked-In-Zustand verfällt. Es ist nicht der einzige Patient von Bierbaumer. Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, ob es da, ob der Patient über den Bierbaumer jetzt geist spricht, vielleicht auch dieser jetzt ist. Da wird natürlich Anonymität gewahrt, soll uns aber auch jetzt gar nicht so genau interessieren, sondern nur zu wissen ist, dass da so Menschen, die mitten im Leben standen, diese Krankheit bekommen, dann rausgerissen werden, vielleicht sogar vetter Mütter sind. Und ich habe mir dann ein längeres Interview im SWR wieder angehört mit Bierbaumer, das ist ein paar Jahre alt. Und jetzt will ich uns die Angst nehmen vor diesem Thema. Es ist so erstaunlich, was Bierbaumer hier zu berichten weiß von dem Patienten Fabio. Zunächst mal hören wir Bierbaumer, wie er die Bedeutung des Gehirns herausstellt.
Ist das Gehirn also unser zentrales Organ, dass das uns zu Menschen macht?
Was uns zu Menschen macht, in meiner Auffassung nach, ist die Möglichkeit zu kommunizieren in der Art, wie Menschen kommunizieren. Und die Kommunikation geht vom Gehirn aus. Und deswegen waren wir so viel daran gelegen, die Kommunikation bei diesen Menschen wiederherzustellen, bei denen sie verloren gegangen ist. Denn ohne Kommunikation existieren wir eigentlich gar nicht.
Und da komme ich sehr viel dran, ne? Wir müssen uns also jetzt mit einem Patienten auseinandersetzen, der nicht mehr kommunizieren kann außer über sein Gehirn.
Einer Ihrer neuesten Patienten, Herr Bierbaumer, lebt in Italien. Fabio ist komplett gelähmt, also nicht mal seine Augenlider kann er öffnen. Er hat ALS. Wie ist diese Krankheit bei ihm verlaufen?
Bei ihm? Ja, er ist ja noch relativ jung, er ist etwa 30. Dafür läuft sie sehr schnell. Am Anfang werden plötzlich die Beine ein bisschen lahm. Innerhalb von Wochen wird einem das Atem schwer, das Gehen schwer, die Hände werden schwer, man kann dann die Hände nicht mehr bewegen. Dann muss man sich entscheiden, das kann manchmal Jahre dauern, wie bei dem berühmten Stephen Hawking, oder es kann innerhalb von Wochen gehen. Und dann muss man sich irgendwann entscheiden, ob man sich beatmen lässt oder nicht. Denn ohne Muskeln kann man nicht atmen, ohne willendliche Muskulatur. Und wenn man sich dann für die Beatmung entschieden hat und die künstliche Ernährung, dann kann man genauso alt werden wie jeder andere, an der Krankheit kann man dann nicht mehr sterben.
Eine schwerwiegende Entscheidung, die man zu treffen hat.
Das kann man wohl sagen.
Die Familie spielt eine ganz, ganz große Rolle, das betonte mehrmals im Interview hier mal ein Clip dazu.
Wenn wir mit diesen Leuten arbeiten, ist man ja praktisch Teil der Familie. Alle diese Kranken werden innerhalb der Familie gepflegt. Oder umgekehrt gesagt, nur diejenigen wollen weiterleben, die in der Familie gepflegt werden.
Die Vorstellung einsam zu sein und in dieser Weise weiterleben zu müssen, ist für die Leute nicht denkbar. Die entscheiden sich in der Regel dagegen, weiter beatmet zu werden. Die, die in einer Familie richtig aufgehoben sind, die wollen eigentlich weiter beatmet werden.
Würdest du sagen, dass Familie da reicht? Es gibt doch manchmal so Entscheidungen. In meinem Buch spielt ja auch eine gewisse Rolle diese Bundesverfassungsgerichtsentscheidung, die dann im Februar, als Corona schon da war, aber noch nicht zuschlagen. Und da wurde ja ganz klar gesagt, wenn der Wille zum Sterben da ist, dann ist er da und dann muss dem auch stattgegeben werden, selbst wenn keine Krankheit oder irgendwas anderes dazu motiviert. Also eine ganz für deutsche Verhältnisse unglaublich liberales Urteil zum Thema. Es ist dann nicht mal mehr Sterbehilfe, sondern erst mal zum Tod selbst. Jetzt haben wir solche Schicksale, wo du sagst, es gibt noch den Unterschied zwischen, wenn man einsam ist oder Familie hat. Aber ich meine, ich bin ja auch ein Familienmensch. Aber diese Art der Einsamkeit trotz Familie ist doch… Und man weiß ja auch nicht genau…
Die sind Teil der Familie, also das wird dann hier auch beschrieben. Also die fahren ja auch mit den Patienten dann raus.
Aber du erlebst ja auch deine Familie nicht mehr.
Ja, das ist jetzt die große Frage. Also wir haben jetzt eben schon gehört, die können noch mal zusammen Peter Pan gucken. Also der vollkommen gelähmte Vater kommuniziert über sein Gehirn, dass er mit seinem Sohn zusammen Peter Pan gucken will. Es gibt Wünsche wie, ich würde mal gerne wieder in die Kirche. Oder ich will ein anderes Bett. Oder ich will folgendes Essen haben, das ihr mir intravenös bringt. Also auch diese Wünsche werden tatsächlich jetzt mit diesen neun Patienten artikuliert. Das ist alles sehr schwer vorstellbar. Böhmer war, sagt auch selbst, dass irgendwann auch die Worte nicht mehr reichen.
Wie war denn dieser Moment, als ihnen und vor allem der Familie von Fabio klar war, wir können jetzt mit Fabio kommunizieren?
Solche Gefühle in Sprache zu bringen, ist sehr schwer. Das bietet sich meistens auf der nicht verbalen Ebene ab.
Also der Fortschritt, der da errungen wird, macht einen dann widersprachlos. Und jetzt kommen wir natürlich zu diesem Thema der Lebensqualität. Lohnt es sich weiter zu leben? Soll man sich weiter beatmen lassen? Und das ist jetzt ganz erstaunlich.
In Fabio geht es wie den meisten Patienten sehr gut. Auf die Frage, wie er seine Lebensqualität einschätzt. Da gibt es ein paar Standardfragen, die man da abfragt. Sagt er, wie die anderen Patienten auch, dass es sehr gut ist. Nun müssen Sie bedenken, dass die Menschen, für die die Lebensqualität mit dieser Erkrankung nicht gut ist, das wir ja nicht sehen. Das heißt, wir haben hier schon eine doch vorselegierte Gruppe. Also wir haben schon hier Leute, die sich entschieden haben, weiterzuleben. Und die entscheiden sich nur weiterzuleben, wenn sie in der Familie aufgehoben sind. Und deswegen ist es natürlich auch unwahrscheinlich, dass wir Menschen sehen, die keine gute Lebensqualität oder keine Familie haben. Die sind alle tot, nehme ich an.
Die Moderatorin hackt jetzt nochmal nach, weil das so eine unglaubliche Äußerung ist. Die Lebensqualität sei sehr hoch.
Also sie sagen wirklich alle ihre oder fast alle ihre Locked-In-Patienten sagen, mir geht es gut, obwohl sie komplett eingeschlossen sind.
Ja, bei dieser Erkrankung, aber auch anderen Krankheiten, die zu Lehmung führen, soll man sich nicht täuschen lassen. Alle Untersuchungen an Querschnittsgedämpfung sind nicht ganz so hoch, aber ist die Lebensqualität auch zufriedenstellend, wenn die Pflege zufriedenstellend ist. Eine schwere Erkrankung oder auch eine Erkrankung, die zum Tode führt, ist kein Hinweis auf eine schlechte Lebensqualität. Das wird von der populären Meinung, leider Gottes auch von meinen ärztlichen Kollegen, oft so gesehen, dass die Lebensqualität miserabel ist, wenn man gelähmt ist. Das ist einfach nicht so. Die Tatsache ist, wenn man solche Befragungen durchführt, und die wurden ja nicht nur von uns, sondern von vielen anderen Wissenschaftlern auch gemacht, da kommt eben das statistisch heraus, die Lebensqualität ist sehr gut. Und da muss ich mich diesen Fakten beugen, egal wie meine persönliche Einstellung zu der Erkrankung ist. Natürlich, mittlerweile sage ich auch, wenn ich die Krankheit kriegen würde, würde ich auch weiterleben wollen. Aber das hätte ich vor 30 Jahren nicht gesagt.
Ich höre mir die an, mache mir noch mal Gedanken, ob ich das dann noch mal kommentiere entsprechend.
Gut, also jetzt zwei Gründe. Warum ist denn diese Lebensqualität hoch? Warum wird denn das angegeben?
Diese Personen leben in einer Welt. Niemand behandelt sie mehr schlecht. Sie sind vollkommen hilflos. Sie können gar nichts mehr tun. Alle Menschen sind positiv und freundlich zu ihnen, die badigeblieben sind. Wenn sie den ganzen Tag von freundlichen, lebenswerten Menschen umgeben sind, die sie positiv behandeln, dann kommen sie am Abend auch mit guter Laune nach Hause. Die Tatsache, dass unsere Lebensqualität manchmal schlecht ist, liegt ja nicht an uns, sondern an der Umgebung, in der wir leben. Wenn diese Umgebung negative Signale aussendet, dann ist auch die Lebensqualität schlecht. Sowas gibt es aber nicht mehr, wenn sie in der Erkrankung sind. Das ist die Haupterklärung.
Das ist für mich ein sehr, sehr lustiger Gedanke. Natürlich ist es wahnsinnig radikal, wenn man es auf die Situation abzielt. Aber versuchen wir mal, so einen Schritt zurückzugehen. Man weiß doch selbst, wenn man zum Beispiel in einem Stadium der Verliebtheit ist, wo man weiß, es läuft doch alles prima, man wird begehrt und so weiter, und offensehen alles ist dabei, dann sind hier auch andere Dinge, die vielleicht belastend sind. Brief vom Finanzamt bis hin zu Weltkrieg sind dann in einem anderen Dichte. Und wenn wir uns jetzt vorstellen, man ist in einem Zustand, wo man immer was zugeführt bekommt, auch viele Dinge einfach nicht mehr stattfinden, also gerade diese negativen Dinge da nicht am Bett irgendwo sind und mich nicht erreichen, dann ist das ja erstmal was, wo ich sage, ja, da beschneide ich mich ja und nehme ganz viel nicht wahr, ich blende aus bzw. die Leute müssen ausblenden. Aber ja, man schafft sich in gewisser Weise so ein Kokon, den wir uns auch immer wieder selbst schaffen, dass man da so am Wochenende gehe ich aber nicht auf Twitter, ich werde mich nicht über den neuesten Tweet von XY aufregen, sondern ich gehe raus, spazieren, lesen Buch, mach sonst was.
Also ich habe ja so eine kleine neue Vorliebe für 100 Jahre alte Psychologie, die nicht von Sigmund Freud stammt, sondern unter dem Deckmangel der Individualpsychologie erstmal das Individuum in den Mittelpunkt stellt und dieses Prinzip umkehrt. Man kann sich überhaupt nur in Menschen verlieben, die auch ein bisschen in sich selbst verliebt sind, ist so einer dieser Themen. Was ja ein klares Primat auf einen selbst erst mal wirft. Man muss mit sich zufrieden sein, wenn man aber kein Handlungsvermögen umsetzen kann, wenn man in dieser Art keine Wirkmächtigkeit, keine Selbstwirksamkeit hat, finde ich das ein wahnsinnig... Also ich finde es ein schönes Gedanken, dass die sich um ihr Umfeld keine Sorgen mehr machen müssen, weil sie in den Momenten, wo jemand da ist, umsorgt werden und so weiter. Wir kennen alle, ich habe es schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, das ist Ellen Schorr, Anwalt, Boston Legal und so weiter, also eine Figur aus einer Fernsehserie, der kurz beschreibt, obwohl er von vielen Frauen geliebt wird und so weiter. Am schönsten ist es doch, sich einen neuen Anzug zu kaufen, wenn die Schneiderin mit dem Maßband so um die Hüfte rumtänzelt und einen umsorgt wie die eigene Mutter. Man kümmert sich darum, dass er gut aussieht und so. Diese kleinen Berührungen, die da stattfinden, sind viel mehr oxytocin, als wenn man wegen Geld irgendwie Frauen abschleppen kann und so. Und irgendwie in diesem... Also man hat solche Momente vielleicht ein paar Minuten am Tag und so weiter. Aber reichen sie wirklich für ein ganzes Leben? Also kann man das... Der Sprache ist von sozialen Umfeld, aber wie groß ist das denn? Ein, zwei Menschen, die sich um einen kümmern, aber auch nicht 24 Stunden?
Vielleicht ist es eine größere italienische Familie. Es gibt Kinder, es gibt eine Frau, es gibt vielleicht Eltern. Ich weiß nicht, wie groß werden sie sicherlich mehr als einer sein. Wir haben es auf jeden Fall hier nicht mit Patienten zu tun, die mal besucht werden. Also die mal irgendwann besucht werden, zwei, drei Mal die Woche, sondern wir haben Patienten zu tun, die einfach da sind. Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass zum Beispiel abends bei Tisch gegessen wird und der Patient liegt daneben. Wir hören uns noch den zweiten Grund an.
Die zweite Erklärung ist natürlich, da habe ich allerdings auch keine Beweise im Moment noch nicht. Sie sind natürlich dadurch, dass ihre Muskeln vollkommen abgestorben sind. Sind sie natürlich in einer Situation, in der das Gehirn die Meldung kriegt, alles ist entspannt, der ganze Körper ist entspannt. Das heißt, für das Gehirn ist das sozusagen ein Signal, der hier kann nichts mehr passieren.
Paradise Now in einer ganz verschobenen Weise. Also es ist ein ganz irritierendes Interview, beziehungsweise diese Erkenntnisse, die ja nun Forschungserkenntnisse sind, sind so wahnsinnig kontraintuitiv. Aber in gewisser Weise hat mich das auch so hoffnungsfroh gemacht, weil ich dachte, erst soll ich mich damit jetzt beschäftigen. Mich haben schon immer diese Filme wahnsinnig runtergezogen, selbst wenn sie so einen Belendisfaktor hatten. Aber das jetzt hier zu hören, ist ja auch in gewisser Weise heilsam. Vielleicht noch...
Ja, großes Thema in Westworld ist, da sind Hosts, die sind Maschinen. Verhalten sich aber wie Menschen, zumindest für die Menschen, mit denen sie zu tun haben. Und dann kommt einer dieser Kreatoren irgendwann auf die Idee, Arnold, ich möchte gerne mein Maschinenleben einhauchen. Und er weiß aber nicht wie, stirbt dann darüber, in Konkurrenz zu sein und so weiter. Und dann taucht der neue Eigner im Park auf, der sozusagen dieses große Anliegen des Erschaffers der ganzen Welt kennt, selber aber kein Technikfuzzi ist und mit so praktischer Intelligenz an das Thema rangeht. Also ihn interessiert gar nicht die Maschine und die Software, die da läuft, sondern einfach die Kommunikation mit dem Host. Und seine Idee ist, das Leben wird hergestellt über Leiden. Nur wer wirklich leiden kann, lebt. Und das ist ja nun nicht nur eine Idee aus einer Fernsehserie, sondern Leiden durchzieht ja das ganze Mittelalter. Alle Ideologien, inklusive Kirche, aber auch alles, was so rechts und links davon...
Auch die Liebe, die mit Leidenschaft denn verbunden sein soll.
Genau, Leidenschaft, richtig. Und ich merke es ja an mir selber, wie ich natürlich aus Gründen zum Sport gehe, um mein Körper das Signal ausgeben zu lassen, hier ist irgendwas, hier finden gerade Anpassungen statt, du hast ihn gerade überstrapaziert, wie auch immer. Genau darum geht es ja eigentlich. Und gerade nicht diesen dauerseedierten Zustand, dass man es am besten gar nicht merkt. Sondern dann denkt man sich, ich müsste jetzt aber mal wieder. Und es ist für mich... Du hast eine konstruktive Wende angekündigt, ich habe jetzt ihn gehört. Also sowohl der erste als auch der zweite Grund, wo man Lebensqualität rausschöpft. Ich meine, er hat jetzt gesagt, vor 30 Jahren hätte er sich das auch nicht vorstellen können. Jetzt hat er diese Forschung mit diesen Patienten gemacht und würde sich auch dafür entscheiden.
Ich meine, wir müssen die Aussagen ja für wahr erachten. Die Patienten werden nicht lügen, weil eigentlich geht es ihnen schlecht, aber sie wollen es jetzt auch nicht sagen. Sondern sie werden die Wahrheit sagen. Und wenn es da eine empirische Wissenschaft gibt, die mir sagt, es sei so, dann ist das vielleicht etwas, was man auch als seine Seinsweise akzeptieren muss. Also sicherlich würden diese Patienten nicht sagen, ich würde niemanden tauschen wollen, der sich nochmal bewegen kann. Aber man kann auf jeden Fall sagen, dass das auch eine formbefriedigende Existenz sein kann. Ich kann das nur so wahrnehmen, wie das ist. Es ist auch nicht mehr möglich, sich persönlich da rein zu versetzen. Hier kommt man auf die Ebene des abstrakten Verstehens. Dann kann man sagen, es scheint wohl so zu sein, dass das eine Möglichkeit ist, und dass die Menschen dann nicht unglücklich sind. Was erstmal eine wahnsinnig hoffnungsfrohe Botschaft ist. Also stellen wir uns mal vor, da wäre die gegenteilige Antwort gekommen. Es ist die Hölle, und zwar seit fünf Jahren. Aber nein, es geht in diese Richtung. Und das lässt einen natürlich auch noch mal über vieles nachdenken, was einem eigentlich wichtig ist und was entscheidend ist.
Ja, also mir kommt da noch ein... Also eins der ganz großen christlichen Themen ist ja der Stellvertreter im Leiden. Jesus hat für uns gebeten. Und jetzt haben wir hier Patienten, die... Wenn man sich mal überlegt, worunter könnte man leiden? Also es gibt ja auch so Trost spendende Modelle, dass man sich überlegt, wie ist mein Leben gerade aufgebaut? Wir gehen es ja auch durch, familiär, beruflich, finanziell, was muss ich so alles... Welche Wünsche hat man? Und dann imaginiert man sich in eine ganz schlechte Position. Und ich finde, hier finden wir eine, wo man irgendwie sagen kann, es kann dir eigentlich nicht schlimmer gehen. Also diese Trennung von Körper und Seele kann dir... Also mir fiel jetzt kein Szenario ein, bei dem es einem noch schlechter ginge, außer dann wirklich, man hat die Schwelle überschritten zum Tod.
Oder du sagst, naja, das ist jetzt wieder auch eine Frage der Perspektive. Wir gucken jetzt darauf und sagen, wir können uns bewegen. Und deswegen ist die totale Unbeweglichkeit die schlimmste Perspektive. Aber immer natürlich unter der Prämisse, dass beides bei uns funktioniert. Der Kopf wie der Körper. Hier haben wir es mit Menschen zu tun, wo der Körper nicht mehr funktioniert, aber der Kopf funktioniert. Und wir haben ganz, ganz viele Menschen, viel mehr als diese speziellen Patienten, bei denen der Kopf nicht mehr funktioniert, aber das Herz pumpt noch ordentlich. Nämlich jene, die demenzkrank werden. Und auch da würde man ja nicht so einfach sagen, naja, dann hat man Demenz und dann fährt man sofort in die Schweiz. Aber das ist ja auch für viele dann wiederum auch eine Option usw. Aber wir sehen ja auch da, haben wir auch Formen der Freude des Erlebens, die gänzlich anders sind. Ich hatte das mal im Salon kurz erzählt, dass wir den, wie hieß er nochmal, der mit unserer Lady Gaga immer aufgetreten ist. Siehst du hier, das ist auch schon, man redet über Demenz.
Ich erinnere mich, du hast von dem 80, 90.
Tony Bennett, der dement ist, aber wenn er auf der Bühne steht, wenn er Musik spielt, dann sich erinnert und dann aber auch sogar nochmal was Neues aus den Liedern macht, also sie anders phrasiert und so weiter. Das heißt, das sind andere Seinsweisen, aber ich glaube, man muss deshalb auch sehr vorsichtig sein. Und das ist auch wieder ein Punkt, wo ich eigentlich viel mehr die Kirchen auch hören will, wo man sagen kann, ja, aber wir können das nicht alles nur so rationalistisch immer erklären mit dem, was wir als gut definieren, sondern wir müssen auch uns eindenken können in andere Lebensweise. Und wenn die sogar auch noch über empirische Wissenschaften abgesichert sind, also dass ich hier jemanden habe, der sagt, na ja, ich habe mit den Patienten ja gesprochen, die sagen, die Lebensqualität ist hoch, dann ist das ja was, was wir ja auch zur Kenntnis nehmen müssen, was ja dann auch in dem Diskurs darüber, wer sich das Leben nehmen möchte und so wieder eine Rolle spielen muss, weil es ja auch Beratungen oder was weiß ich gibt, wo solche Ergebnisse ja auch mit einfließen müssen, wie man ja auch sonst, wenn man irgendwas gemacht bekommt, wenn man sagt, ich will jetzt einen neuen Zahnersatz, dann wird man auch hingewiesen darauf, das kann bedeuten, bla, bla, bla.
Also wie gesagt, mit diesem Jesus-Punkt wollte ich noch mal auf die Pointe hin, die können ja nun wirklich befragt werden neuerdings dadurch. Und sie haben sich geäußert. Also wir haben sozusagen das empirische Datum darüber, wie es denen geht. Und ja, vielleicht sollten wir es einfach auch bei der Frage, warum die mir diese Videos so als Trost spenden entgegennehmen. Irgendwie, dass es doch eine Option ist.
Ja, ich finde das hochinteressant. Noch vielleicht so zwei praktische Dinge zu den Mitarbeitern. Mit wem arbeitet Bierbauma da eigentlich zusammen?
Meine Mitarbeiter sind buchwegs Ausländer aus Entwicklungsländern, die eben nach Deutschland kommen. Natürlich auch, um was zu lernen, aber eben auch aufgrund ihrer Herkunft bereit sind, da enorme Opfer auf sich zu nehmen. Das sind unsere jungen Psychologinnen oder Medizinerinnen oder Mediziner nicht mehr.
Jetzt denkt man, das ist doch so eine innovative Forschung. Da will doch jeder ganz vorne mit dabei sein.
Und solange die ganze Forschung in den Laboratoriums stattgefunden hat, solange hatte ich nie Probleme, Mitarbeiter zu kriegen. In dem Moment, wo sie aus dem Laboratorium rausgehen und zu den Patienten gehen müssen, indem sie Opfer auf sich nehmen müssen, die über das Arbeiten hinausgehen, also über die Laboratoriumsarbeit hinausgehen, indem sie reisen müssen, Nächte sich um die Ohren schlagen müssen, indem sie Feiertage nicht einhalten und, und dann erst sind die Schwierigkeiten aufgetreten.
Also auch da nochmal ein ganz anderes Thema, das der Zuwanderung nämlich und der Opferbereitschaft und all das. Hochinteressant, also sich damit auseinanderzusetzen, ist sicherlich auch etwas, wenn man Zeitgenosse sein will.
So, Wolfgang, du bist ein Influencer, Experte.
Nein, Experte, ja, okay.
Du bist ein Influencer, Experte. Und wir kommen jetzt hier auch auf so ein bisschen Influencer-Thema. Denn so wie eine Fitnesswelle durchs Internet rollt, gibt es auch eine, wie soll man sagen, Gehirn-Fitness-Welle. Die Leute wollen produktiver arbeiten. Man fragt sich manchmal erstens, warum, und zweitens nur des Selbstzwecks wegen, kann man nicht auch in der Arbeit Lust und Freude finden, muss man sie so schnell wie möglich absolvieren und so weiter und so fort. Aber es ist dieses Phänomen, nachdem ich so ein bisschen schaute, wie kann ich denn, und das ist ja nun so ich-AG-mäßig, wie wir arbeiten, manchmal macht es ja echt Sinn, so ein paar Sachen zu automatisieren oder zumindest zu effektivieren. Und dann bin ich hier auf so ein Tuktus gestoßen in dieser Produktivitätsgang, in diesem Milieu, das da gibt. Das echt so ein bisschen und wir steigern uns mal langsam. Wir fangen mal an hier bei so einem Standard. Wie geht so ein Video los, wenn man über Produktivität spricht? Wow, was für eine Ehre. Die App hat sogar auf den Homescreen seines iPhones geschafft. Der Typ BiteReview heißt der YouTube-Kanal, macht ansonsten irgendwas anderes und ist dann mal so in seine Manufaktur uns reinschauen lassen. Das geht aber auch ein bisschen enthousiastischer, zum Beispiel hier bei Elizabeth Phillips. So, SecondBrain, ganz wichtig, Hashiba ist ein weiterer YouTube-Account, ich glaube sie heißt so. Ihr habt mir ja schon so ein bisschen gehört, sie ist da sehr involviert, das ist ihr Leben und Pipapo und so geht es dann auch weiter.
Es ist Zeit für einen neuen Start, voll von produktiven Vibren und Erkrankungen zu erreichen, vielleicht sogar mit den Resolutions zu stecken. Und ich habe einige Kommentare bekommen, die mich fragen, was dieses Emoji-Film-Minimalist-App ist. Also in diesem Video werde ich mein Liebesverhältnis mit Notion verbreiten und hoffentlich kommt ihr auch noch.
Sie ist schon in Love-Affair mit ihrem Notion, ihrem Second Brain. Sie ist total erleichtert, dass sie jetzt endlich jemanden gefunden hat, der ihrem Leben ein bisschen hilft.
Lass mich da mal gleich eine Frage stellen. Es geht darum, die eigene Produktivität zu steigern. Würdest du sagen, es geht primär darum, mehr Konzentration zu gewinnen? Oder geht es wirklich darum, einfach mehr zu leisten? Also man ist konzentriert auf was, aber man überlegt, wie kann man das jetzt effizienter gestalten? Denn es gibt ja schon lange diesen Diskurs, dass man sagt, ich kann mich nicht konzentrieren, höchstens eine Stunde, oder dann wippeln die Leute auf dem Stuhl, oder sie lenken sich ab mit den entsprechenden anderen Gerätschaften, die es so gibt.
Das ist hier völlig unklar, ob die sich schon gefunden haben im Berufsleben und das einfach besser machen wollen, oder ob sie grundsätzlich auf der Suche sind und dann überlegen, was könnte ich eigentlich mit diesem Tool alles machen, also da so offen sind. Die Frage ist ja auch Produktivität. Die reden ja die ganze Zeit von Notion, also einer Software, die wie so ein Word-Dokument im Grunde funktioniert, also mehr so wie so eine kleine Wikipedia des eigenen Denkens. Nur, das ist halt auch viel Arbeit, weil man muss ja erstmal viel reinbringen, um dann irgendwas suchbar zu machen. Und ich habe bei mir zum Beispiel festgestellt, naja, es macht für mich super viel Sinn, einen Podcast vorzubereiten, über den ich dann drei Stunden rede, um so ein paar Zitate mir einfach festzuhalten. Aber es gibt für mich keine Lebenssituation, wo ich in der Küche stehe und denke, ah, ich wollte das auch nochmal und so. Wo gucke ich dann nach? Ah, ich nutze mal die Suchfunktion von Notion, weil ich das irgendwann mal da reingeschrieben habe.
Also, das heißt, für dich ist es eher wie ein Notizbuch. Ich habe ja mal gesagt, ich habe eine Wörterteil, da schreibe ich mir gewisse Dinge auf. Oder es sind ja auch schon mal Clips oder irgendwelche Panels, die ich mir für den Podcast ansehen will, wo ich aber jetzt gerade keine Zeit für habe und denke, aber nächste Woche, wenn ich den Podcast vorbereite, greife ich darauf zurück.
Genau, ganz aufgabenspezifisch als Werkzeug genutzt. Die hier stellen das aber so als Second Brain vor, bei dem sie so ausleuchten wollen, sich nochmal in Erfahrung über sich selbst zu bringen, von den Sachen, von denen sie nicht wissen, dass sie sie nicht wissen. Dokumentiert man dort die Dinge, die man getan hat, oder geht es vor allem darum, aufzuteilen, was man noch tun muss, dass man sagt, ich muss mich noch beim Arzt melden, ich muss auch noch zur Post und ich muss auch noch...
Also To-Do-Listen sind natürlich produktivitätsmäßig Megathema. Das steckt in Notion soweit alles drin. Also man kann es in jede Richtung total übertreiben. Und am Ende locken die erst mal alles. Welche Filme habe ich gesehen, welche Serien? Dann können sie nachschauen, wann sie es eingetragen haben. Notion hilft dir viel, das zu automatisieren, das Coverbild hinzuzufügen und so weiter. Wenn du so ein Schlagwort mit IMDB, Datenbank und so weiter hast. Also es ist ein bisschen unklar, was machen die hier eigentlich?
Das heißt, das ist schon auch dann ein Tagebuch, wie ja Letterboxd beispielsweise auch so ein Film-Tagebuch ist, was für viele Leute wichtig ist, die das gar nicht nutzen, in der Form, dass sie jetzt Kritiken dort schreiben wollen für eine Community, sondern einfach, dass sie sagen, das ist für mich praktisch, dann kann ich immer gucken, wann ich welchen Film gesehen habe oder welcher für mir von einem Regisseur noch fehlt.
Genau, es gibt also Letterboxd für Filme, es gibt Readvice zum Beispiel für Texte, die man gelesen hat, das nutze ich jetzt auch relativ viel, weil man einfach aus dem Kindle-Markierung das rüberkopiert und während man liest in der Notiz für die Markierung einfach mit Punkten-Hashtags arbeiten kann, also ohne viel Aufwand, kann man so kommentieren, dass man die Textstelle später unter einem gewissen Hashtag wieder findet, den man währenddessen auf dem Kindle-Gerät selbst eintippt. Und das ist schon super, weil ich jetzt dadurch zum Beispiel relativ viele Mark Schiritz-Sachen zum Thema Rentenrepublik im Buch drinne habe. Also wenn ich das auf Papier gelesen hätte, dann müsste ich sagen, welche Seite waren das nochmal und so, aber jetzt hänge ich da einfach...
So arbeite ich ja.
Genau, jetzt hänge ich da einfach einen Hashtag in dem Moment, wo ich es lese, dran, das dauert zwei Sekunden, und dann weiß ich, das ist dann gesichert für später, ne? Also für so ganz spezifische Aufgaben kann ich das alles super nachvollziehen, aber dieser allgemeine, enthusiastische irgendwie, ah cool, da kann ich alles eintragen und hab dann so ein Second Brain, das hören wir hier nochmal von Lana Blakely heißt sie. Sie ist so eine Schwedin und hat einen ganz merkwürdigen YouTube-Account, in dem sie nämlich die ganze Zeit nur so ganz selbst aware über Aufmerksamkeit, Achtsamkeit und das Ganze überhaupt und so. Man fragt sich ja, aber bist du so gefangen in so einem infiniten Loop der Selbstreflektion? Also findet bei dir noch irgendwas anderes außer nur sozusagen das Gespräch vor der Kamera, über dem du dann redest während du vor der Kamera bist?
Das ist ja auch das, was Ole und ich immer bei den Influencern erlebt haben. Nachdem sie dann und wir verfolgten sie da manchmal so wochenlang, weil man dann keine Story verpassen wollte, nachdem sie dann wirklich 100 Snippets gemacht haben, zu dem, wie es ihnen geht, was sie gerne finden, haben sie dann als Abschlusspost für den Tag. Jetzt ist aber mal MeTime angesagt und man denkt, ja du hast doch nur an dich gedacht.
Also sie hat so einen ganz komischen YouTube-Account und findet dann auch, jetzt ist die Zeit aber mal reif, euch mein wahres Ich zu zeigen.
Das sind aber auch so Leute, die einem, wenn man sie mal trifft und mit ihnen sich unterhält, na du, das sind mir aber doch auch so viele negative Gedanken, die du da hast.
Sie ist eine ganz komische Figur. Ich finde es ganz spooky, sie zu sehen. Aber du hast ja diesen gerusamen Enthusiasmus gehört. Heute ist endlich die Zeit. Ich zeige euch mal die Notion-Page. Und jetzt will ich nur kurz umrahmen, mit was wir es hier zu tun haben. Also Notion ist eine Firma, die halt diese Notion-Wigipädeartige für die Selbstseite herstellt, die man super nutzen kann, aber da kann man es halt auch übertreiben. Da funktionieren auch so ein paar Skripte. Man kann Sachen automatisieren, sich Templates vorlegen, was weiß ich, die Reise planen und dann nutze ich das gleich für die nächste Reise und so. Also so ein paar Sachen sind wirklich sehr nützlich. Und dann ist die Strategie von Notion, zu solchen Videos zu animieren, indem sie das einfach bezahlen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, ob es hier bei Lana auch, aber relativ viele Videos werden direkt von Notion bezahlt. Und auch so Vortragsreisende, die dann einfach die Missionen sozusagen in die Welt tragen. Und relativ viele springen dann auf den Zug auf und finden dann Publikum darüber, dass sie ja schon super produktiv arbeiten und relativ viele Studenten und Schüler das ja auch wollen. Also gucken die das dann. Und die Idee, die dann, also die Vermarktungsidee ist, dass diejenigen, die sich so Produktivitäts-Influencer herausgestellt haben, dass die das dann über Skillshare vermarkten. Kennst du Skillshare?
Nein.
Also Skillshare ist sowas wie YouTube, nur mit Bezahlschranken. Also man muss einen Monatsbeitrag bezahlen. Und dann betteln sich die Nutzer auf Skillshare darüber, wer am meisten Aufmerksamkeit bekommt, denn so wird das Geld dann verteilt. So und auf Skillshare, wie man es halt vermutet, Skill und Share, lädt man halt kleine Videos hoch, in denen man erklärt, wie etwas geht. Also da finden ganz viele Stricken, Zeichnen, Filme machen, was auch immer.
Also Tutorials, eigentlich das, was man bei YouTube-Tutorials bekommt, kann man da nochmal buchen.
Aber eben nicht in so einem Durcheinander, wo man nicht genau weiß, wenn ich jetzt diese Video anklicke, werde ich dann wirklich aufgeklärt, wie eine Donauwelle zu backen ist. Bei Skillshare ist das halt super strukturiert. Da ist ein Reputationssystem, da sind Sterne dahinter, da sieht man, ah, der Typ hat schon 37.000 Reviews, also klicke ich das mal an und die verdienen darüber Geld. Und es ist halt wirklich wahnsinnig viel. Also die 105-6-Stelle gibt Träge, teilweise pro Jahr raus. Und dann rutscht er aber rein. Also wenn du einmal damit dein Geld verdienst, musst du halt auf YouTube so einen Anwerbe, das einfach zum Anwerben nutzen, um dann immer wieder darauf hinzuweisen, dass es bei Skillshare halt dann den harten Stoff gibt, sozusagen.
Das ist wie bei Instagram die OnlyFans-Creators sind, die dann immer so sagen, schreibt mir mal eine DM, wenn ihr mehr wissen wollt.
Genau, jetzt zeige ich euch ja schon mal die Knie, und bei OnlyFans gibt es dann mehr. Naja, wie sie es nutzen, ist dann ganz interessant. Also in dieser Dunstglocke hier kommt auch mal zu meinem Skillshare rüber und haut mir die Taschen voll. Elizabeth Phillips. Nein, denn dieses Versprechen oder naja, wir können natürlich drüber diskutieren. Ihr Versprechen ist ja, wenn ich das nutze, werden mir Möglichkeiten geschaffen, die ich nicht hätte, wenn ich mich nur auf mein First Brain verlassen würde. Also brauche ich ein Second Brain und dann bin ich sozusagen in Interaktion mit mir selber und überrasche mich auch selber, weil ich stöbere dann so durch und finde irgendwas.
Und ist das vielleicht, frage ich mich jetzt schon mal, dass eigentlich im Metaverse das dann da aufgebaut wird und Mark Zuckerberg spielt da noch mit seinen komischen lustigen Figuren rum, aber da ist eigentlich das Metaverse in dem Sinne, wie es auch richtig praktisch für viele Leute erscheint.
Das kann sein, dass im Metaverse noch so viele andere Menschen rumhampeln und nicht nur Second, Third und Fourth Brains von einem selber oder so. Also diese Leute sind hier in der Soziologie die doppelte Kontingenz, wenn sich zwei Leute begegnen und füreinander unklar ist, was passiert eigentlich als nächstes und dann ist es dieses ganze Aushandeln und sich überraschen lassen und Spontanität erlauben und so. Und ja, ihr Anspruch ist oder das verspricht sie uns hier, wenn wir da mit ihr ins Rapid-Hole gehen, dann erklärt sie uns, wie wir das mit uns selber herstellen. Naja, diese Hashiba, die wir eben schon gehört haben, verwendet es ganz ähnlich. Der lebt glaube ich in London. Der verdient mittlerweile, da macht er auch YouTube-Videos drüber, so 5 Millionen Dollar damit pro Jahr, einfach nur die Produktivitätswelle zu reiten. Über Skillshare, über und ich habe auch noch ein Notizbuch entwickelt, das ihr euch mal kaufen könnt und so weiter.
Das heißt, der Leidensdruck scheint ganz hoch zu sein. Mir ist bei den Influencern aufgefallen, dass sie das Laufen thematisiert haben, auch Notions, soweit ich weiß, aber auch To-Do-Listen immer wieder thematisiert haben, dass sie die jetzt erstellt haben. Man hat auch dann sich oft gefragt, was machen die denn? Sie müssen ihre Posts machen, die haben ihre Werbepartner und die haben noch einen Assistenten und das muss auch ein bisschen gemanagt werden. Aber das wurde alles immer wieder niedergeschrieben und diese Art der Produktivitätssteigerungen, die man aber zunächst einmal dadurch herstellt, dass man darüber spricht, dass man die herstellen will, die hat mich schon immer sehr stark irritiert. Denn man kann mal ganz kurz doch in meinen Augen überlegen, wie will man sich jetzt organisieren? Und da muss man vielleicht manchmal, wenn sich Lebenssituationen ändern, noch mal ein bisschen was verschieben. Aber dann ist das doch schnell wieder... Also ich denke ja jetzt nicht darüber nach, wie ich meine Tage organisiere.
Die schon. Und du siehst es hier gleich. Oder relativ viele zeigen dann so, diese Videos habe ich geplant und dann so eine lange Liste. Und dann per Drag & Drop wird das dann eine Liste weitergeschoben, eine Spalte ist in Produktion, muss noch Post-Production und so weiter. Man lässt das alles immer mitbegleiten. Es gibt für alles immer so ein digitales Duplikat, sodass man so eine Übersicht und so weiter hat. Und dieser Ali Abdael klickt ja mal so durch seinen Notion. Wir sehen es, ihr hört es nur, aber es ist schon ziemlich übertrieben, das muss man sagen. Ich benutze es, um meine E-Mail-Newsletters zu machen. Ich benutze es, um meine Videos zu machen.
Ich habe dieses Life-Wiki, wo ich meine Gedanken schenke. Ich bereite meine Gedanken um Kreativität, Organisation, Produktivität, all das, was ich für mich interessiert.
Ich benutze es, um Ideen für das Geld zu machen, die ich habe. Es gibt viele, viele Use-Cases, die ich in weiteren Videos diskutieren werde.
Man muss sich das vorstellen, tatsächlich wie eine Wikipedia-Seite mit ganz vielen Reitern, die man aufmachen kann. Und dann öffnen sich wieder Ordner, wo wir jetzt erklärt bekommen, was er da alles einfügt und macht. Und ich frage mich, wie viel Zeit verwendet er darauf und könnte produktiv sein, indem er diese Notions da ausfüllt. Denn wir sind ja da bestimmt bei zwei Stunden am Tag, die er dafür verwenden muss, um das alles so korrekt zu machen.
Es ist irre.
Ich meine, ich bewundere in gewisser Weise, dass man so diszipliniert sein kann. Man denkt das immer so, wenn man zum Beispiel die Steuererklärung hat. Dann denkt man, ach ja, man wollte doch eigentlich immer mal diese Quittungen alle so und so schon sortiert haben. Das macht man dann nie. Aber hier haben wir ja so diese Idee, dass man jetzt das Leben komplett organisiert. Aber man organisiert es so stark, also man baut sich ein bürokratisches Monster auf, das einen lebensunfähig macht. Das ist ja eigentlich die große Lehre aus der modernen Bürokratie, dass man es irgendwann so weit getrieben hat. Wir brauchen es ja nur die Verwaltung an den Universitäten anzusehen, dass man auf jeden Lehrenden irgendwann einen im bürokratischen Apparat haben muss, der verwaltet. Und hier scheint mir das so, acht Stunden lebe ich und acht Stunden verwalte ich mein Leben, das ich gerade gelebt habe oder morgen leben werde.
Ja, sehe ich ganz genau so. Hier ist wenig Raum für keine Ahnung. Das wird dann abgebucht unter Selbstverwirklichung und Orientierungsfindung oder so, keine Ahnung.
Geht es auch um Rechtfertigung? Also geht es um Rechtfertigung vor einem selbst, dass man, so psychoanalytisch gesprochen, einen großen anderen hat, dem man das sagt? Also sonst hat man vielleicht die Kirche, wir haben die protestantische Ethik besprochen, als wir über Sandwich waren, die einem sagt, sei fleißig, denn wenn du fleißig bist, dann ist das so und so mit dem lieben Gott. Und hier haben wir natürlich das nicht mehr, sondern man sagt das einem selbst oder man muss es so generell mitteilen und wenn es nur für so ein Programm ist.
Ja, also ich habe auch so ganz kleine Prozesse, die aber aus 17 einzelnen Tasks bestehen, die ich viele lange Zeit einfach so, was muss ich jetzt und so weiter, jetzt hake ich das einfach ab, jetzt habe ich das auf Wiedervorlage, jeder Woche sagt mir mein Telefon einfach hier, das ist die Liste, und dann kann ich es einfach abhaken und dadurch bin ich doppelt so schnell. Aber das geht nicht allgemein. Also ich würde nie auf den Gedanken kommen, wenn ich jetzt unten bin und es gibt ein Geburtstagskuchen zu backen oder so, dass ich dann, ich gehe dann ins Internet und suche mir Rezepte raus, aber ich fange nicht an in meinem eigenen Second Brain irgendwie nachgrübeln zu wollen, was ich mal für die Idee hatte zu einem Kuchen. Also das ist auch so eine gewisse Abkopplung von und auch so ein bisschen Login, während man gleichzeitig aber so produktiv, produktiv sein will. Also es ist wirklich sehr merkwürdig. Aber dieses Prinzip Second Brain, was die da so durchbraten, das ist ich, weiß auch nicht. Wir hören ja nochmal diesen Abteil.
Aber ich denke, wenn eine App in einem bestimmten Art und Weise ausgestattet ist, empfängt es dich, Dinge in einem bestimmten Art und Weise zu denken.
Und da steckt ja auch fast so eine Primatumkehr drin. Er möchte sich gern die Abläufe extern strukturieren lassen, hat aber, er hat auch Personal, aber in dem Moment eben hier kein Personal, also lässt er sich einfach, aber wie gesagt, für ganz spezifische Prozesse, die immer wieder kommen und wo man weiß, was die Stolpersteine sind, ja, da macht externe Strukturierung Sinn, aber nicht in diesem Open-World-Ding, das man ja eigentlich Leben nennt. Na ja, wir hören ihm noch ein bisschen zu. Ja, es ist ein kognitiver Hausbau, der da stattfindet und dann richtet man sich ein. Jetzt hören wir einen weiteren Protagonisten, Thiago Forte, das ist auch einer da aus dem Zentrum der Bubble. Leben zu leben. Die Notions-Function ist super, nur deswegen macht man es ja zweitens. Shareability, also kann man da auch andere Leute drüber informieren, was man da eigentlich und so weiter. Und ich habe ja auch so eine Seite veröffentlicht, oder diese Hörer-Treffen-Seite ist auch eine Notions-Seite, also dafür geht es ganz gut, finden die auch. Und jetzt Transferability. Erleitet man hier ein Login in der Software eines anderen?
Sie haben Export-Tools. Aber in Bezug auf meinen gesamten Kustom-Build-Werkflug, ich habe das nicht in ein anderes System verwendet.
Und das ist jetzt ein Kunde quasi, den er da bereit, wie er seine Produktivität erhöhen kann.
Genau, der Vorte spricht ja mit jemandem, der selber auch relativ viel von diesen Videos macht, also nicht wirklich so ein Kunde, aber der Vorte ist halt nochmal so auf Mission, und er ist mehr so ein Nutzer. Also die begegnen sich hier so, dass er ihn schon fragt, wie ist das so. Also suchen geht super, Shareability geht auch super. Das ist natürlich immer die Frage, wenn man jetzt jemandem was erzählen könnte über Ideen, sollte man dann echt eine Notion-Page verschicken, wo man es nachlesen kann, oder sollte man es nicht über den Dialog lernen?
Und wer ist das, dem man das dann da schickt?
Auch so eine Frage. Bereitet man es für den da nochmal auf oder gibt man dem einfach den Wirrwarr so hin? Ja, aber die Transferability ist halt nicht gegeben. Also die erleben hier schon diesen Log-in-Effekt, der eben auch die sozialen Netzwerke so wertvoll gemacht hat, dass man nämlich klar, wenn man Twitter nicht mehr nutzen will, geht man zu Mostadon und twittert dort für drei Leute.
Ja, kannst du mal ganz kurz, auch wenn es jetzt ein bisschen zu spät kommt, da hätten wir eben schon bei Twitter drüber sprechen können, uns drei Worte zu dieser Alternative, die offenbar keine ist, sagen.
Mostadon? Ja, Mostadon hostet man einfach selbst. Das ist ja die Idee, die Elon Musk auch so hat, dass man einfach den Code veröffentlicht, in dem Falle dann das Tweetschreiben selbst. Und da gibt es verschiedene Instanzen, so nennt man dann die einzelnen Serverinstallationen, die aber miteinander kommunizieren können. Also ich habe zum Beispiel einen Account bei Chaos Social, das ist irgendwie Dunstkreis Chaos Computer Club. Und die sind aber immer so ein bisschen begrenzt. Und das bedeutet dann aber, es gibt keinen zentralen Server. Also wenn irgendwer dann keine Lust mehr hat, seinen eigenen Server zu betreiben, sind die anderen trotzdem noch da. Und witzigerweise behandeln dann auch diejenigen, die bei Mastodon Twitter-Nutzer anschreiben, Twitter nur als weitere Instanz von Mastodon. Also als wäre das nur ein weiterer Server, obwohl der 20.000 Mal größer ist.
Aber da muss man sich jetzt nicht noch anmelden.
Da muss man sich nicht anmelden. Die Frage ist dann erst mal, wo, welchem Anbieter vertraut man eigentlich in dem Moment, dass der Account dann auch in drei Jahren noch da ist und betrieben wird. Solche Entscheidungen muss man treffen, dann relativ wenig Publikum. Man findet halt so seine Freunde irgendwie, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man da so ein 20.000, 30.000 Follower-Ding aufbauen könnte.
Ich habe mich ja bei LinkedIn angemeldet, das muss reichen.
Das wird auch reichen, ja. Aber daran sieht man eben, der Wert von Twitter ist dieses Social-Login. Und hier ist es so dieses kognitive Login. Also du bist halt dann an diese Platte. Wenn du einmal die Tabellen da angefangen hast, die kriegst du dann nicht wieder raus. Kannst du den PDF ausdrucken, aber so richtig funktional ist das dann auch nicht.
Nur an wen richtet sich das denn jetzt? Denn die meisten Menschen gehen ja einer Tätigkeit nach, bei der sie angestellt sind. Und da sind sie erstmal gebunden. Und da sagt der Arbeitgeber, wie es auszusehen hat, wer wann wo im Büro sein muss. Und dann gibt es das Privatleben, das organisiert werden muss, Hobbys und Familie und so weiter. Und dann gibt es ja Selbstständige. Ich habe den Eindruck hier, und so funktionieren ja auch diese ganzen Business-Wolches, ist ja immer für ein selbstständiges Leben, für das Ich-AG-Leben gedacht. Dass also da eine besondere Organisation stattfinden muss, um die Produktivität und damit den Profit zu steigern.
Für die meisten Sachen, für die man mit Kollegen was organisiert, reicht ein Kalender. Also das geht weit darüber hinaus. Und deswegen kann man da auch immer nur selbst was mit anfangen. Dieses Shareability-Ding ist schon... Wann macht man das dann mal? Also man ist hier sozusagen locked in mit sich selbst und diesem Unternehmen. Und die Frage, für wen? Ja, man sieht halt relativ viele. Sara Dietschy zum Beispiel, die macht so YouTube-Videos, Kram-Pivö, also Zeug halt. Die hat jetzt gar nicht so viel mit Produktivität zu tun. Kam dann aber auch mal auf ihre Seite zu sprechen. Ja, also dieses Gehirn freier Räumen.
Das Nebulöse, das wird dahin gelagert.
Genau, es ist so ein bisschen wie bei Harry Potter, wenn man dieses Memo Dingsda Bums, wo man sich einfach mit dem Zauberstab so ein Faden aus dem Kopf, und dann hat man so ein kleines Flüssigkeitsbecken und dann können auch andere da reintauchen und die eigenen Erinnerungen nacherleben und wie auch immer. Naja, ein interessantes Video.
Ich überlege gerade, ob wir auch Second Brain machen, wenn wir podcasten, denn meine Professorin hat mal zu mir gesagt, man schreibt, um zu vergessen. Denn man hat es dann aufgeschrieben, aber man muss sich jetzt selbst nicht mehr an das Mark Schiritz Zitat erinnern. Du hast es dann aufgeschrieben, es ist dann als Fußnote da, und es ist dann auch noch gedruckt und dann ist gut. Und wir haben einen Podcast, wir sprechen darüber, zum Beispiel jetzt über dieses Thema, und in gewisser Weise ist es auch Second Brain, dass ich jetzt das da als Podcast hingegeben habe. Also wir kippen jetzt unsere Gehirne da aus, in diesen Podcast, in die Mikrofone, und dann ist das dort. Das bedeutet aber auch, es hat eine gewisse entlastende Funktion, dass man zwar jetzt immer weiß, was Notions ist, man kann immer was dazu sagen, aber wenn du jetzt diese eine YouTuberin da, wie hieß die nochmal, dann könnte ich es jetzt dann nachgucken in der Podcast-Folge und sagen, ah ja, da haben wir darüber gesprochen.
Genau. Und das ist ja wieder eine sehr spezifische Aufgabe, sich zu erinnern, was man dem Podcast gesagt hat. Ich habe ja zum Beispiel für jeden Podcast entweder in Notion oder in Word, was ich ehrlich gesagt auch ein bisschen präferiere, Skripte, also Notizen einfach. Ich habe jetzt auch beim Schreiben, ich habe vor drei Jahren das Talk-Radio gemacht, als Monolog-Podcast. Dem lagen ja auch immer Skripte zugrunde. Ich höre also nicht die Folgen nochmal nach, sondern gucke mir, was wollte ich in diesem Podcast sagen, und habe es dann wahrscheinlich auch gesagt, aber es steht halt in meinem Skript drin. Unter der Maskabe, ja, da, auch wenn man es dann nicht vergessen hat oder sich nur dunkel erinnert, guckt man nochmal nach, was man vergessen hat, dadurch, dass man es dann einmal ausgesprochen hat. Aber das ist ja halt super interessant, denn wir sind ja jetzt an dem Punkt, man will das ja alles nutzen. So, Notion wie ich es nutze, da fällt halt ein Podcast bei raus. Oder ein Buch, oder was auch immer. Jetzt, wenn ich so an Zitavi denke, ist ja ein sehr spezifisches, so kann man es strukturieren. Und jetzt ist hier einer, Mike Gaston, der spricht über Lumans Zettelkasten. Auf Englisch. Er nennt ihn deswegen immer Lure, er blendet das dann noch ein, dass er sich da falsch, also dass die Aussprache falsch ist. Aber Luman hat ja das alles mit Zetteln gemacht. Also ohne Links, ohne Shareability, ohne Searchability. Das waren ja wirklich nur die Sortierungen. Und dann hat er ja auch mal gesagt, also so seinen Zettelkasten rausgezogen unter seinem Schreibtisch, also wenn ich hier jetzt einen Zettel falsch reinlege, ist der weg. Der taucht dann nie wieder auf. Der überrascht mich dann irgendwann mal, wenn ich ihn nicht gebrauchen kann, weil der ist dann weg. Der muss richtig nummeriert und richtig gedingst sein. Und jetzt hören wir mal, wie Produktivität eigentlich funktioniert, wenn man gar kein Internet hat. Also er nennt hier auch nochmal die Zahlen des Publikationswesens aus einer Biografie, nämlich der Niklas Lumans.
Es zeigt das System, das Nicholas Lurhman geholfen hat.
Es hat Lurhman eine tolle, komplexe, hohe Respekt für die Erinnerung und das Content.
So, 70 Bücher, 400 Texte. Das ist natürlich.
Das ist Produktivität.
Das ist mal Produktivität in 30 Jahren.
Wer jetzt verzweifelt, Slavoj Zizek hat auch etwa so viele Bücher geschrieben. Ich hörte, ich weiß nicht, ob es stimmt, dass Zizek einfach mit einer Wörterteil arbeitet und alles da reinschreibt, fertig. Dann wird immer was rauskopiert und das ist dann das Buch, das Nächste, 400 Seiten wieder.
Genau, die schreiben ja anders als wir beide. Wir geben ja unserem Lektor quasi fertige Texte ab. Das ist ja da ganz anders. Die sind ja so eingebunden in so ein Verlagsdingster-Wumms.
Ich weiß es gar nicht. Also man sagte, es gab doch so ein Interview mal von dem Lektor von Habermas zum Beispiel. Zurkamp hatte das veröffentlicht bei YouTube. Da hieß es, dass Habermas halt fertige Texte macht. Da muss vielleicht mal irgendwo mal ein Komma hin oder weg. Genauso, glaube ich, wurde das auch über Stotadek mal gesagt. Und ich weiß das gar nicht. Ob Zizek jetzt so einen Wust abliefert, glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, dass er dann einfach so ein Packen da rausnimmt und das dann da rein nimmt, was aber auch dazu führt, dass er dann immer wieder Redundanzen produziert.
Ja, Redundanzen sind natürlich das eine. Ich dachte jetzt so an so populärwissenschaftliche Autoren. Schirmer hat zum Beispiel so geschrieben. Das war dann immer so ein... Da mussten die Lektoren schon noch mal gucken, welche Textteile da noch ausgeblendet waren.
Ich glaube, Luhmann ist schon jemand, der das als Text durchgeschrieben hat.
Genau, der die fertigen Dinger so abgeliefert hat. Das waren ja auch diese einzelnen Projekte. Aber es gibt ja auch, Nils Buckelberg beschreibt das immer mal wieder, wie Stephen King schreibt. Der sich einfach morgens um neun an den Schreibtisch setzt und dann holt er sich so eine Idee, die er hatte, und dann der schreibt er dann. Egal zu welchem der laufenden Bücher, die passt. So, und dann wird das irgendwie alles passend gemacht.
Ja, es gibt ganz, ganz interessante Faktoren. Edgar Wallace hat ja diktiert seine Kriminalromanen. Die Sekretärin musste aufpassen, dass keine Figur unter den Tisch fällt. Das ist nämlich häufiger bei ihm vorgekommen. Und Josh Simenon hat, also der die Migré-Romane geschrieben hat, der hat sich so ein sehr gutes Skript eigentlich gemacht, so Notizen gemacht vom ganzen Aufbau. Und dann wurden die Romane aber glaube ich in 14 Tagen geschrieben.
Das ist auch, wenn man das kann, sehr gut. Es ist jedenfalls das Schreiben. Es ist, und das finde ich super interessant, wie er noch mal auf den eigentlichen Produktivitäts-Guru Lumans sprechen kommt und eben diese ganze Trennung, die wir eben gehört haben, Second Brain, First Brain, hier Notizen machen, da dann das Projekt verwirklichen und so weiter, wie das alles aufgehoben wird. Und darauf muss man sich ja mal einlassen. Man kann so viel planen, wie man will, aber am Ende macht man am besten die Planung selbst zum Projekt, das aufs Finale hinausführt.
Das macht Slavoj Zizek, ja, er sagt, es sei für ihn eigentlich undenkbar, sich hinzusetzen und ein Buch zu schreiben. Deswegen tut er so, als würde er jetzt gerade das mal planen und skizzieren und dann merkt er, ach so, das ist jetzt das Buch, jetzt ist er fertig.
Genau, man ist dann schon mittendrin. Ist natürlich schwierig, wenn man ungefähr weiß, was man unterbringen will in dem Buch. Aber dann hat man ja auch diesen Prozess, also ich merke das bei Zitavi immer wieder, dass ich dann eine Notiz, irgendeine Quelle, irgendeinen Zitat und so weiter, und dann schreibe ich aber schon so ein bisschen Text dazu. Und im Grunde könnte man aus diesen Zitavi-Inhalten dann schon mit so ein paar Verbindungsstücken irgendwie so kapitelweise das zusammenbauen. Also das ist eben diese Entkopplung von, ah, jetzt planen wir erstmal unseren Urlaub. Nee, pack doch gleich die Tasche, oder leg doch gleich alles hin. Denk doch nicht erst über die Schwimmbrille nach, sondern hol sie einfach aus dem Schrank so ungefähr. Ist natürlich bei Urlaubsplanungen irgendwie bequemer, auf dem Sofa zu sitzen und ihn erstmal virtuell zu planen und dann wirklich die Liste durchzugehen. Aber bei dieser kognitiven Arbeit, die die hier alle machen, ist es eben anders. Lesen gilt im Grunde das selbe wie beim Schreiben. Das war ja bei Luhmann auch. Man hat ja immer gefragt, ja klar, 70 Bücher, 400 Texte, aber man hatte den gelesen und das Lesen war natürlich das Schreiben. Und der kleine Zettel war so der Brückenschlag. Also man hat die Notiz des Lesens festgehalten und dann eine Stunde später saß man schon wieder am Zettel und hat den schon wieder verarbeitet in den eigenen Text. Also Lesen ist Schreiben, Schreiben ist Denken. Das muss alles mal so ein bisschen verstanden sein.
Und auch für jene, die nicht schreiben und nur lesen, es hilft doch sehr, wenn man ein Buch unter einer gewissen Fragestellung sieht. Und nicht immer nur die Fragestellung, die der Titel einem vorgibt, sondern das kann auch genau die entgegengesetzte Fragestellung sein.
Ja, mein Vater fragt mich zum Beispiel immer, was weiß ich, er hört so den Salon und fragt mich dann, hast du das gelesen? Ich so, na, ich hab drüber gesprochen. Klar, hab ich's gelesen, wie soll ich sonst darüber sprechen? Dieselbe Frage beim Buch, das im Text bei mir auftaucht als Referenz, hast du es gelesen? Ist natürlich, weiß ich nicht mehr, müsste ich nachgucken. Wahrscheinlich hab ich die drei Seiten gelesen, die mich interessieren oder so. Aber nein, Bücher, die da hinten aufgeführt sind, hab ich natürlich nicht alle vollständig gelesen, sondern ich hab sie gelesen, als ich schon geschrieben habe. Also das ist alles total integriert. Und wie man sich einen produktiven Prozess vorstellt, wird hier ganz wunderbar von ihm beschrieben. Es sind nämlich die generativen Prozesse. Aus Seite 300 vielleicht auch, dass man das Produktivität in diesem kognitiven Arbeiten einfach anzufangen, den Mut zu nehmen. Alles, was die Noten eigentlich nicht nimmst, weil du dann immer denkst, du hast es wegsortiert. Das ist erstmal gut aufgehoben da hinten in der Ecke, in der Garage.
Ich würde auch sagen, man sperrt das eigentlich weg. Das ist so was, wo man sagt, ach, das ist diese Datei da hinten, die öffne ich jetzt aber nicht nochmal.
Genau, man macht so einen Haken dran und denkt dann, puh, abgearbeitet. Dabei ist es nicht abgearbeitet. Es muss ins Produkt schon mal dann irgendwie dann doch reinfließen. Zurück zu Notion und diesen Paradigmen. Wir hören ein bisschen Thiago Forte zu, erhält einen Vortrag. Ich finde, es ist auch lustig zuzuhören, wie sie übertreiben.
Eine Ausstattung ihres Intellekts, eine Ausstattung ihres Intuitions, eine Ausstattung ihres Selbstes.
Bei diesem Typen frage ich mich ja, gibt es überhaupt irgendwelche wahren Inhalte, die der Innotions notieren kann? Oder ist der Inhalt eigentlich nur, man muss die Produktivität steigern und ich rede darüber, wie man sie steigern kann, aber ich weiß noch gar nicht, was Produktivität bei mir eigentlich mein. Denn was der Mann ja macht, ist er wird wahrscheinlich hochbezahlt dafür, solche Panels zu veranstalten und dann ein paar, naja, Gemeinplätze von sich zu geben. Das ist genauso wie bei diesen ganzen Erfolgscoaches, die am Ende doch nur sagen, investieren Bitcoin. Wo ich denke, ja, ist das jetzt so die wahnsinnige unternehmerische Leistung? Eher nicht.
Also für mich passt das irgendwie in die Zeit, in der alle so ganz alarmistisch was machen wollen, so getrieben sind. Ich muss jetzt was machen, aber sich nicht festlegen wollen auf ein Resultat. Also legen sie sich so in das Schicksal der Software. Das wird mir schon eine Struktur geben irgendwann. Aber wer, ich muss selber irgendwann mal den Text schreiben, das Video so produzieren, weil dann ist man doch wieder auf sich geworfen. Und dann, ja gut, man hat irgendeine Idee, man macht es in der und der Reihenfolge, aber dann erlebt man, nee, man muss dann doch irgendwann mal entscheiden.
Ja, oder ein Geschäftsleiter, ein Handwerker sein oder sonst was. Also da kann man vielleicht sich auch mal an einem Sonntagnahmittag Gedanken machen, wie man die nächste Woche organisiert. Aber sonst muss auch einfach gearbeitet werden.
Genau. Und auf der anderen Seite finde ich super interessant, welches Paradegum man hier drin hat. Nämlich, also Second Brain und so, albern.
Aber das dynamische Working-Document.
Ja, das ist natürlich, da warten wir alle so ein bisschen drauf, aber das bedeutet eben auch, es muss für alle ein, also praktikabel sein. Es kann nicht einfach einer mit seiner Art von Working-Document kommen und dann müssen sich alle daran, so wie SAP Software macht. Ja, man guckt sich den Weltmarktführer an und dann schreibt man für den eine Software und dann sollen das alle anderen Marktteilnehmer genau so machen. Dann hat man so eine große Metamorphose und alle machen es irgendwie gleich, aber es ist trotzdem keiner glücklich. Kann das alles auch schiefgehen? Auf ihn im Vortrag folgt eine Mitarbeiterin von ihm. Lauren Valdez, die mal hier zwei Punkte aufgreift, von denen wir sagen, ja stimmt, darüber sollte man mal nachdenken.
Und das ist etwas, was ich finde, als wir diesen Notions-Tour jetzt machen, ist das unser dritter Stopp.
Ja, man quatscht den Leuten Notion auf, dann fangen die damit an und haben erst mal Breakdown.
Das ist wie Leute, die Freizeitstress haben. Ja, das ist alles ein bisschen eigenartig.
Oder eben weil Leute echt mal was geregelt haben wollen, aber sie sich plötzlich so in einer Notion-Struktur unterwerfen müssen und dann merken irgendwie, ich komm ja gar nicht vorwärts.
Mir ist das gar... Ich verstehe auch nicht. Also man hat doch im Gehirn genügend Platz auch für ganz viele. Also klar, wir haben ja ganz viele Second Brains, wenn man so möchte. Ich lerne keine Telefonnummern auswendig, weil die auf dem Handy gespeichert sind. Also das ist ja etwas, was wir immer haben. Ich frage mich nur diese Lebensorganisationen, die da angeboten werden, welche Leben führen diese Leute? Also ich weiß es ja nicht, wie kompliziert deren Leben so sind, aber ich würde sagen, man kriegt das doch hin.
Ja, es ist alles sehr merkwürdig und sie greift hier noch einen zweiten Punkt auf.
Das ganze System ist um die Anwendung von Information für die Aktie zu organisieren.
Weil es schrecklich ist, voieren wir es, und wir machen Planen.
Ja, es ist eine Vermeidungsstrategie. Man hackt das dann ab als ich habe ja was getan, aber...
Wir haben ja im Salon das Buch von Kevin Roos gelesen und ich erinnere mich, dass wir darüber diskutierten und ich ganz entsetzt war, dass Kevin Roos jetzt immer mal wieder 15 Minuten, glaube ich, sich ganz vom Internet löst, um sich auf ein Buch zu konzentrieren. Und dass das so ganz allmähliche Schritte sind, dass er wieder vertiefende Lektüre und so etwas leisten kann. Und ich war ja total entsetzt darüber, dass das sein kann, dass man also 15 Minuten überhaupt herauslöst. Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, gut, wenn man vier Stunden vielleicht dann rausgeht und sonst viel damit zu tun hat, aber 15 Minuten ist ja nichts. Aber deshalb meine Frage, ist dieses Phänomen, das du uns jetzt hier vorgestellt hast, vielleicht in erster Linie ein Symptom für ein TikTok-Zeitalter? Wenn wir jetzt daran denken, YouTube hat weniger Aufrufe, also weniger Menschen konsumieren, YouTube bzw. YouTube wird nicht mehr so lang konsumiert, haben jetzt die neuen Earnings von Google ergeben. Das heißt, man kann sich jetzt überlegen, wo sind die hingegangen? Nicht zu Netflix, denn auch Netflix hat keine große Steigerung mehr zu verzeichnen bei Abonnenten, ganz im Gegenteil, die schrumpfen. Wo sind sie? Sie sind vermutlich zum größten Teil bei TikTok. Das heißt, TikTok frisst wahnsinnig viel Aufmerksamkeit. Und da frage ich mich schon, ob dies nicht einen Effekt haben kann, dass man dann da Stunden verbracht hat, plötzlich merkt, ich kriege mein Leben gar nicht mehr organisiert. Eigentlich wollte ich doch diese zwei, drei Dinge, war ja gar nicht viel, machen, aber jetzt habe ich vier Stunden lang 15 Sekunden Videos geguckt.
Ja, also ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass dieses Produktivitätsding unglücklich macht, weil man keine Resultate sieht, außer so ein Durcheinander von Tabellen und überhaupt, so wie man auch nach 15 Minuten oder 20 Minuten TikTok einfach, also ich weiß aber nicht, das kann niemanden glücklich machen, TikTok-Videos zu gucken.
Ja, ich vermute, dass aber der Effekt wirklich ist, also TikTok produziert Kunden für Notion, weil die Leute bei TikTok sind, davon nicht so richtig loskommen, eigentlich müssten sie ihre TikTok-Sucht bekämpfen, dann bietet Notion aber an, den Tag zu strukturieren. Aber da macht man eigentlich auch wieder nur etwas, was einen nicht befriedigt, und dann geht man wieder zurück zu TikTok.
Ja, man muss sich von dem allen befreien, einfach, das kann man hier einfach nur sagen. Und dieses Produktivität, das Rapid Toll, ich würde sagen, wer glaubt, Notion zu brauchen, in dem Maße, wie man es hier, sollte echt noch mal drüber nachdenken, ob nicht die Tasks, die man wirklich hat, schon organisiert sind über Kalender. Kleine To-Do-Listen, die wirklich nicht mehr machen als eine To-Do-Liste. Und dann eben auch, was weiß ich, die Kommunikationsplattform, die man halt so hat, ja, einen Gedanken festhalten, weil man ihn sharen will über Notion und so. Alles gruselig.
Dann lieber effizient sein in dem, wie man es tut. Du schreibst ja ganz effiziente Nachrichten und E-Mails. Du bist jetzt niemand, der erst mal absatzblumige Worte macht, um dann mitzuteilen, wir treffen uns dann morgen. Sondern du sagst einfach, morgen, neun Uhr, okay. Dann soll ich aber eigentlich nur noch den Daumen hoch dir senden. Und das reicht.
Du schickst auch immer Satzzeichen in Twitter-DM's. Und du weißt, dass Satzzeichen in Twitter-DM's als sehr unhöflich angesehen werden.
Satzzeichen werden als unhöflich angesehen? Wo sind wir denn jetzt gelandet? Das ist ja genau umgekehrt. Wer keine Satzzeichen macht, der ist unhöflich, weil ich muss ja dann den Satz entschlüsseln.
Es gibt so Studien in Amerika, die befassen sich damit, wie Eltern und Kinder miteinander kompensieren. Und wir wissen alle, was ein Ausrufezeichen ist und so weiter. Das ist ein Befehl. Aber es stellte sich raus, auch für die Eltern sehr überraschend, wenn die Eltern ihre Kurznachrichten mit im letzten Satz einen Punkt abschließen, finden das die Kinder als unhöflich. Sondern das soll einfach der letzte Buchstabe und das war's. Dieser kleine Punkt, da liegen Welten zwischen den Rezeptionsgeschichten. Das ist ganz verrückt. Du schreibst ja immer ein Wort Punkt zum Beispiel. Also du machst ja immer einen Punkt, was ja auch grammatikalisch genau richtig ist.
Genau.
Da muss ich immer wieder an die amerikanischen Teenies denken.
Der Einsatz muss beendet werden und zwar mit einem Punkt. Und auch sonst darf mal ein Komma gesetzt werden oder ein Semikolon vielleicht sogar.
Genau, also der Lesbarkeit halber soll natürlich Satzzeichen reichen, aber es geht so um diesen abschließenden Punkt am Ende.
Ach so, und das wird dann schon als emotionaler Druck wahrscheinlich abgefasst. Das ist aber wirklich dann Snowflake Generation.
Kann man so sagen, würde ich auch. Es ist im April ein Thema aufgetaucht, über das man ewig reden könnte und zwar aus allen Richtungen. Ich hab zum Beispiel bei meinem Buch so eine Gegenüberstellung drin, wie wir auf der einen Seite in Deutschland immer noch vom Ministerium für Frauen, Familien und Gedöns hören, was Gerhard Schröder damals sagte. Gleichzeitig hören wir den amerikanischen Präsidenten, der mit 80 Jahren oder so, 79, also Joe Biden, jetzt noch mal davon spricht, wie die Familie das Bollwerk gegen den chinesischen Struktur-Kolonialismus ist. Also dass man sich im Systemstreit mit China nur erwähren kann, wenn man auch die Familien unterstützt. Jetzt haben wir in Deutschland das Problem, Familien haben auf der einen Seite mit hohen Wohnkosten zu rechnen, müssen aber gleichzeitig die Kinder aufs Erwerbspersonenpotenzial vorbereiten. Diejenigen, die das tun, die also Kinder haben und darauf vorbereiten, haben dann wieder so wenig Geld, dass sie keine Altersvorsorge machen können. Das machen dann wieder die privat, die keine Kinder haben. Also es sind so ganz viele Paradoxien, die da irgendwie ineinander greifen und niemand weiß so richtig, wie geht es denn jetzt eigentlich. Und dafür haben wir ja, wir haben für viele Themen kein Ministerium, zum Beispiel für Singles oder für Einsamkeit. Und es klingt immer lustig, weil in England haben die das. Also da gibt es einfach ein Mysterium für Einsamkeit. Und jetzt haben wir in Deutschland ja auch, die Hälfte sind Single-Haushalte. Und wir haben mal ein Familienministerium. Und da geht es immer wieder drunter und drüber. Seit das Rita Süßmuth irgendwann vor 30 Jahren übernommen hat, haben wir so eine verrückte Geschichte nach der anderen, wie zum Beispiel Katharina Bali oder so. Das habe ich jetzt präsent, aber ich habe den Clip nicht noch mal rausgesucht, weil er auch nicht richtig wert ist zu spielen. Wie sie alles gesagt, Podcast von der Zeit damals. Also wir haben ja immer dieses unendlich lange Gespräch, bis der Gast irgendwann das Codewort nennt. Und dann hört es auf. Und da kommen also Politiker auch mal richtig ins Plaudern. Und sie war damals gerade nicht mehr Familienministerin, sondern Justizministerin 2018 und sprach dann aber darüber, es ist schon so ein bisschen aus der Mode gekommen, es auch mal selbst besser zu machen. Wir in der Politik würden ja gerne jedem Rentner 2000 Euro zahlen und jedem eine bezahlbare Wohnung geben, aber das können wir eben nicht. Und dann dauert sie das so, dass es echt aus der Mode gekommen ist, dass dann auch jeder selber mal so ein bisschen. Und schließt dann sogar noch an. Oh, das war jetzt echt gemein, sorry. Da fragt man sich so ein bisschen, Familienministerin 2018, die dann Justizministerin wird, dann sich weggloben lässt in Europa-Parlament, in Brüssel aber plötzlich private Suche twittert, weil irgendeine Freundin von ihr für die Tochter in Köln eine Wohnung sucht. Wo man sich denkt, wenn nicht mal Katharina Barley eine Wohnung findet, und dann habe ich, das ist aber so eine etwas schwierige Recherche, weil es ja auch um ihr Privatleben geht, aber offenbar ist es so, dass Katharina Barley selber eine Scheidung hinter sich hat, als die Kinder zwei und neun Jahre alt waren, was sich heute keine Eltern mehr erlauben können, weil sie zum Beispiel gar nicht ausziehen können, weil die neue Wohnung kostet halt so unendlich viel Geld. Also man schafft ja zu zweit, das ist ja auch verrückt, die Emanzipationsgeschichte heißt, früher reichte es, dass die Frau nicht arbeitet, der Mann hat das Geld nach Hause gebracht, es hat für die Wohnung gereicht, und jetzt muss die Frau mitarbeiten, und man sagt immer, sie darf mitarbeiten, aber nein, sie muss mitarbeiten, weil sonst reicht es nicht für die Wohnung.
Was bedeutet, dass wenn die sich trennen, es für beide nicht mehr reicht?
Ja, dann ist einfach wirklich finanziell Sense für sehr viele, gerade in den urbanen Zentren, wo ja sehr viele junge Leute leben. Und von Katharina Barley weiß man, dass sie damals sich getrennt hat, als die Kinder zwei und neun Jahre alt waren, und von Anfang an die Kinder in jeweils beiden Haushalten, Mutter und Vater, ein Kinderzimmer hatten. Also ein Modell, das heute nicht mehr funktioniert.
Es sei denn, man verdient so viel wie Katharina Barley.
Genau, es sei denn, man wird direkt als Richterin geboren und sagt dann aber, ich gehe jetzt mal in die private Wirtschaft. Und verdient dann halt von Anfang an immer mega gut und hat dann auch alle Gelegenheiten, bis hin zu Justizministerin und so weiter, das zu werden. So, dann haben wir Christina Schröder, an die erinnert man sich ja auch. Die erste Mutter im Kabinett, also die, während sie Ministerin war, schwanger wurde. Ja, so gleichzeitig mit diesem, also als Familienministerin, aber jetzt verabschiedet mich auch aus der Politik. Ist mir zu viel. So, dann haben wir jetzt Anne Spiegel. Und ich will nicht diesen Ausschnitt spielen, wie sie nicht wusste, dass das gerade live übertragen wird. Und sie sich für den Urlaub entschuldigt.
Und sie fragt, wie man es abbinden soll.
Und wie man es abbinden soll, genau. Also, dass man nochmal abbinden oder aufpimpen. Man ist ja ein bisschen unklar, wie die Anweisung war. Abbinden wäre noch die zahmere.
Ach so, ich habe Abbinden verstanden, weil das so ein typischer Slogan.
Genau, Abbinden ist eins.
Aber aufpimpen eben auch. Das muss den Beitrag noch abbinden.
Aber aufpimpen eben auch, im Sinne von, das muss nochmal aufgepimpft werden für die Presse dann.
Ich glaube eher abbinden.
Naja, aber wir wissen ja, was sie sagte. Nämlich, als die Flut kam, ging es meiner Familie schlecht. Die Kinder haben Corona nicht gut mitgemacht. Mein Mann hatte einen Schlaganfall zwei Jahre vorher. Wir standen unter Druck. Und sind wir dann in einen vierwöchigen Urlaub gefahren. Und sie hat sich zweimal für diesen Urlaub entschuldigt. Und jetzt entsponnt sich da natürlich eine Diskussion darüber. Hm, Work-Live-Balance, wie geht denn das? Wir haben diesen neuen Podcast von Sascha Lobo und seiner Frau, die sich ja auch immer so um ein Thema Gedanken machen, wie man das so emotional verarbeiten kann.
Und jetzt willst du uns wirklich quälen, oder was?
Na, wir hören da mal rein. Ich fand es nicht ganz uninteressant. Aber ich finde, man muss auch immer noch ein bisschen was dazu sagen. Also zum einen...
Das ist doch das schlimmste Medienepaar der Welt, oder?
Findest du?
Das ist doch irgendwie so... Also dann lieber sollen die Kardashians wieder zusammenkommen.
Also ich hab's jetzt nur für diesen Fall gehört, da mir das zu dichte Monologe sind. Dialoge. Oder also eigentlich anschließende Monologe. Also manchmal sind ja Gespräche einfach zu... Es darf ruhig ein bisschen lockerer sein. Und das fehlt mir in den Podcasts. Deswegen hab ich jetzt nur diese eine Folge.
Nein, ich finde... Also ich weiß nicht, ich bekomm's immer nur von Freunden zugespielt, was die so in den sozialen Medien treiben. Und dann denk ich immer, du lieber Gott. Da kann man ja doch immer froh sein, über das, was irgendwie Bachelorette-Kandidatin mit Bachelor-Gewinner zusammen bei RTL veranstaltet.
Kennen Sie gar nicht. Kennen nur Sascha Lobo so. Also klar, dann jahrelange Verfolgung, irgendwie das ganze gelesene Zeug. Sie äußert Verständnis für Anne Spiegel.
Ich muss aber sagen, dass ich schon auch ein Verständnis für die Lage von Anne Spiegel habe und auch für die Entscheidungen, sogar für die Lügen und für die Fehler habe. Weil ich finde, dass das tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen der Druck in der Arbeitswelt ist. Und vor allem, ich würde auch schon sagen, dass da noch dazu kommt, dass sie eine Frau ist. Aber ich würde erstmal grundsätzlich sagen, dass es der Druck in der Arbeitswelt ist, dass man denkt, ich muss das jetzt hier machen. Wenn mir das angeboten wird, dann muss ich das jetzt hier wahrnehmen. Dann muss ich das Abend auch noch machen. Und ich kann total verstehen, wie sie da hinkommt, obwohl man ja sagen muss, sie hat ja die wichtigen Ämter oder zwei weitere Posten nach dem Schlaganfall ihres Mannes angenommen. Also von der Chronologie her ist es ja schon so, dass man jetzt nicht sagen kann, sie hat jetzt unwissend über das, was da passieren wird, ganz viele Ämter angenommen, die eigentlich schon zu viel waren. Und dann kam dieser Schicksalsschlag, Schlaganfall des Mannes dazu. Das würde ich schon auch sehen.
Ja, ich kann das alles überhaupt gar nicht nachvollziehen. Also entweder ist man überlastet, aber dann kann man ja nicht noch weitere Sachen sich drauf schaffen. Also wenn ich jetzt sage, oh, ich habe unglaublich viel Stress, dann würde ich ja nicht sagen, vielleicht mache ich mal noch ein wöchentliches Podcast-Promat. Zumal in der Politik wird einem nichts angeboten. Das heißt, man muss sich so sehr schon nach vorne gestellt haben, dass man überhaupt dafür, also klingelt nicht irgendwann das Telefon und denkt mal, ach, dass sie aber an mich gedacht haben, dann werde ich jetzt Ministerin. Sondern da muss man wirklich die ganze Zeit schon alle Türklinken geputzt haben, alles gemacht haben, um da hinzukommen. Deswegen halte ich das für eine absolut falsche Aussage. Und ich würde jetzt gleich noch hinzufügen, sie war Familienministerin in Rheinland-Pfalz. Sie weiß also aus eigener Erfahrung, wie es Familie mit Corona gegangen ist. Ich bin ja aus dem Sendegebiet, SWR. Ich bin ja Rheinland-Pfalzer, obwohl man Rheinland-Pfalzer nicht sein kann, man ist Rheinländer zum Beispiel. Und ich kann sagen, dass die Landesregierung unter Spiegel und auch nach Spiegel einen Hardliner-Kurs in Sachen Corona gemacht hat und nicht irgendwelche Zugeständnisse für Familien, junge Menschen oder sonst was gemacht haben, dass sie ja selbst offenbar darunter litt und dann nicht das in eine andere Politik verwandelt hat, sondern einfach eine Exit-Strategie wählt und sagt, macht ihr euren Lockdown, das sind die Fälle, über die wir ja schon gesprochen haben, macht ihr euren Lockdown, ich fahre in den Urlaub. Das ist so wie, ja, alle sollen kein Auto mehr fahren, wo ist eigentlich mein Chauffeur geblieben? Das geht nicht.
Genau. Wir haben Thomas de Maizière Abschiedsworte im Bundestag gehört, er hat die Balance nochmal konkretisiert, Krise macht Spaß. Da kommt der Politiker so richtig zur Geltung, da kann man endlich die gewonnene Macht dann mal einsetzen und auch so ein bisschen rumspielen. Und wir hatten mit dieser Flut natürlich eine Krise. Und sie ist aber in diesem Moment in den Urlaub gefahren. Und so wie die Jule Lobo das hier beschreibt, ist das ja so ein, naja, wir haben halt hier die Familie und da ist die Arbeit und dann belastet sich das alles so gegenseitig. Nur sie hat sich ja für den Urlaub entschuldigt öffentlich, der Urlaub war falsch. Und vielleicht meint sie das wirklich ernst, denn ich würde diesen Politikern, dem nun wirklich nichts geschenkt wird, die haben sich alle Macht, die sie haben, da irgendwie rangeholt, ich würde ihr einfach unterstellen, sie war halt wirklich mit Leidenschaft Politikerin und wollte gar nicht in den Urlaub fahren. Sondern es lag halt irgendwie nahe ihr Mann und keine Ahnung, und dann musste sie halt. Also ich will jetzt gar nichts über Anne Spiegel konkret sagen, weil wir es nicht wissen und sie jetzt auch erstmal da nicht ansprechbar ist bei dem Thema. Aber ich mache mir für die Rentenaboblick als Buch natürlich schon Gedanken gerade jetzt, wo ich das Familienkapitel noch schreibe, ob wir hier beim Thema Work-Live-Balance nicht sowohl Work als auch Live nochmal hinterfragen müssten, ob nicht für einige Familie Arbeit ist und die Arbeit eigentlich die Leidenschaft und was das eigentlich bedeutet. Ob man das nicht denjenigen auch erlauben darf oder sollte, zu sagen, naja, wenn du vier Kinder hast und dann eröffnet sich aber für dich so eine politische Karriere, warum sollte man sie dran hindern? Ihr Mann hatte einen Schlaganfall. Das ist ein medizinisches Problem. Warum soll Anne Spiegel das jetzt lösen? Sie ist doch für alle Menschen in der Politik da. Warum sollte sie jetzt, nur weil sie mal ihn geheiratet hat? Also ich will jetzt nichts Anne Spiegel unter der Familie unterstellen, sondern nur das Prinzip. Darum geht es.
Aber wir haben doch diesen Satz von Spinoza, jede Entscheidung ist Verneinung. Und das bedeutet doch schon, wenn man sich für das eine entscheidet, dass das gewisse andere Dinge ausschließt. Also jetzt mal was ganz Banales. Wenn ich mir jetzt einen Hund anschaffen würde, dann müsste ich jetzt gleich nach dem Podcast sagen, Schnitzel essen geht nicht mehr, ich muss nach Hause. Ich muss nämlich noch mit dem Hund raus, der macht sonst in die Bude. Da kann ich nicht sagen, naja gut, da habe ich mich vor zwei Jahren leider doof entschieden. Ist halt so.
Meinst du nicht? Ich würde dafür plädieren, dass man...
Ja, dann muss ich ihnen einen Time geben.
Genau, dass man so lebens...
Aber man kann jetzt nicht jeder die Kinder einen Time geben.
Na ja, aber man kann ja...
Sie finden die ganz schön voll.
Klar, bei den Kindern, aber auch um Kinder können sich ja Menschen kümmern.
Ja, aber das ist ja dann wieder mit Geld in Verbindung zu bringen. Aber das muss man ja schon ausreichend haben.
Ja, aber da würde ich sagen, der Landesministerin mangelt es erst mal nicht an den Möglichkeiten.
Sie könnte jetzt auch sagen, der Mann und eine Nanny fahren in den Urlaub. Die Kinder müssen raus, die drehen sonst am Rad. Und ich mache jetzt hier Krise.
Genau, und in der Hinsicht, mir fehlt... Es ist wirklich schwer, aber die... Also gerade hier in Frankfurt, wenn man hier so essen geht, dann sieht man so die Hochhäuser, wie Menschen arbeiten. Und man würde nicht sagen, dass die unter ihrer Arbeit leiden oder so. Es gibt auch diese verschiedenen... Man soll das Unternehmen nicht mit der Familie verwechseln und so weiter. Das Licht soll ein bisschen länger anbleiben, damit die Konkurrenz auf der anderen Seite der Stadt sieht. Da wird aber hart gearbeitet und alle quälen sich so ein bisschen durch. Es gibt auch sehr viele Menschen, die wirklich leidenschaftlich gerne arbeiten und dann voll drin aufgehen und die Unternehmen das auch wirklich unterstützen, dass es da zu Leidenschaft beikommt.
Aber man könnte ja auch fragen, wenn das so ist, warum haben die denn so große Familien? Also ich meine, man kann das ja auch für Dinge entscheiden. Also ich glaube, das Problem bei Anne Spiegel ist Folgendes. Ich habe das dann einfach noch mal in Interviews nachvollzogen. Sie hat zum Beispiel im Dezember ein Interview gegeben in der Bahnstatement. Karriere und Familie, sagte sie, dürfen niemals Gegensätze sein. Und dann würde ich sagen, doch, das sind Gegensätze. Die Frage ist nur, in welchem Spannungsverhältnis die zueinander stehen. Wenn ich sage, der Beruf ist für mich eigentlich immer das Wichtigste, so war das zum Beispiel bei einem Udo Jürgens. Da hat dann Jenny Jürgens einmal in einem Interview gesagt, natürlich die Familie, ja, er war Familienmensch, aber am Ende war die Karriere das Entscheidende und alles musste dahinter anstehen. Und wenn man das so sieht, kann man sich, wie Joachim Kaiser, der berühmte Musikkritiker aus der Süddeutschen Estate, fragen im Alter, war das eigentlich gut, eine Familie überhaupt zu haben? Sollten so Menschen wie ich Familie haben? Dann sagte Kaiser, und das war eine Doku, die seine Tochter gedreht hat, eher nein. Und jetzt will ich nicht aber sagen, Karriere geht nur, wenn man ganz auf die Familie verzichtet. Nur, wer der Minne entsagt, kann jetzt der Macht dienen, wie Albrecht im Ring. Aber dass es diesen Gegensatz gibt und dass man nicht so tun kann, als gäbe es den nicht, und das hat an den Spiegel, das haben viele immer suggeriert, ich glaube, das produziert diesen hohen Stress. Und wenn man tatsächlich sagen würde, ich habe eine Familie, aber das bedeutet auch, dass ich natürlich eine gewisse Anzahl von Stunden mit der Familie verbringe, eine gewisse Anzahl von Stunden mit der Politik, dann kann ich nie so viel Politik machen wie jemand wie Peter Altmaier, der sagt, ach, ich habe immer samstags abends am liebsten Journalisten zu Gast, da hat nämlich sonst keiner Zeit für Politik. Das ist klar. Das heißt aber auch noch nichts an der Qualität der Politik, weil wir uns einig sind, Altmaier mag zwar 100 Stunden Politik gemacht haben die Woche, aber hat keine gute Politik gemacht. Aber ich glaube, diesen Gegensatz, den muss man erkennen. Und dann ist die Frage, wie man den aushandelt, wie man auch erkennen muss. Man kann einen Freundeskreis aus sieben Leuten haben, aber wenn man die alle wirklich regelmäßig treffen will, dann entstehen da auch gewisse Spannungen zeitlich, wo man sehen muss, wie man sich da organisiert. Vielleicht braucht sie Notion.
Vielleicht braucht sie Notion, genau. Mit Shareability, damit auch alle gleich sehen, ohne dass sie sie direkt anspricht, was sie vorhat in ihrem Kalender. Wir hatten eine Corona-Politik im Bund, die von vier Ministern ohne Kinder, ohne Familie getragen wurde. Also Spahn als Gesundheitsminister, Finanzminister Scholz, Merkel und Altmaier Wirtschaftsminister. Und es muss ja einen Weg geben, dass Familien da involviert sind. So wie eben auf Landesebene, auch wenn wir jetzt das Resultat der Familienpolitik entsprechend sehen.
Sie hatte zwar Familie, aber das heißt nicht unbedingt, also das ist ja ein identitätspolitisches Argument, das du jetzt machst. Und ich würde auch zunächst einmal sagen, ja klar, Menschen, die Familie haben, kennen es ja aus der direkten Umgebung und bringen dann vielleicht ein, hört mal, wir können aber mit den Schulen nicht so und so umgehen, ich habe es ja bei mir zu Hause gesehen. Das fand aber in dem Sinne nicht statt. Es hat mich auch gewundert und sie war ja keineswegs die einzige mit Kindern in der Politik, die so eigentlich unempathisch gegenüber Familien war.
Also wir hören mal diesen nächsten Clip von Jule Lobo. Sie verwendet hier das Wort auch, finde ich, auf so eine Upgrade-bedürftige Art und Weise.
Wenn wir über Work-Live-Balance sprechen, dann ist ja die Frage eigentlich nicht, also ich glaube, wir wissen alle, was Work heißt. Aber wissen wir dann wirklich, was das Live bedeutet? Und ich würde sagen, und das ist auch auf jeden Fall ein wichtiger Punkt, von dem wir so ein bisschen erzählen können, weil wir da Erfahrungen haben, ist, dass Live Familienleben ein Stück weit bedeutet. Also dass es darum geht, Familie mit Arbeit irgendwie zu kombinieren. Und bevor wir jetzt gleich darauf kommen, dass Live ja auch einfach Privatleben bedeutet, weil ich finde schon, dass es wichtig ist, also ich finde, Work-Live-Balance ist auch wichtig, wenn man jetzt keine Kinder hat, weil man einfach einen Anspruch darauf hat, sich frei zu entfalten.
Ja, also hier geht alles drunter und drüber. Und man muss sich, finde ich, wirklich politisch Gedanken machen. Sie hat jetzt Privatleben genannt, damit meinen sie ja weder Work noch Familie. So, das ist natürlich auch wichtig.
Ich sage immer, wichtig ist, dass man das Privatleben aus der Familie raushält.
Irgendwie so, genau. Es ist ja durchaus ein moderner Ansatz, so zu sagen. Oder eben Work, Familie und Privatleben. Und dann ist aber völlig unklar, wie die Leidenschaften so verteilt sind. Und es muss aber so strukturierbar sein, dass wir Kinderwünsche, die da sind, nie unterdrücken, weil. Sondern da fehlt sozusagen, ich werde in Rettenrepublik auch das Argument machen, oder die Altenrepublik, wie es heißt, alte Menschen, wir reden immer über die Rente. Und da geht es ums Geld. Nur die alten Leute suchen nicht wirklich Geld. Denen ist mit Geld wenig geholfen. Die suchen Geselligkeit. Und die kann man ja durchaus organisieren. Man kann für alle Menschen in Deutschland einen Urlaub auf bis zum Abruf organisieren. Also, dass sie sich wirklich wie im Urlaub fühlen. Dass sie morgens erstmal zum gemeinsamen Frühstück gehen, sich dann nachmittags zum Sport treffen und so weiter. Das ist alles möglich. Und es kostet nicht besonders viel Geld, nur niemand organisiert. Und dieses Prinzip, klar, es beginnt immer bei den Älteren, so wie wir auch das bedingungslose Grundeinkommen zuerst bei den Älteren sehen werden, und dann sickert das so langsam in die Gesellschaft ein. Dieses Prinzip fehlt total bei Familien. Wie schaffen wir es, Familien so zu organisieren, dass, wenn Anne Spiegel plötzlich in Berlin arbeitet, das einfach trotzdem funktioniert, obwohl die Kinder noch klein sind? Kann man für eine Familienministerin eine Viertagewoche in Berlin einführen, zum Beispiel. Dass sie dann trotzdem irgendwie durchpendeln usw. Diese große Streitfrage, war sie jetzt bei den Arbeitsrunden in ihrem Ministerium anwesend oder nur zugeschaltet oder gar nicht? Was für eine Verquere, war sie jetzt am Telefon montags 10-12 Uhr oder nicht? Das ist ja so, man denkt, das kann doch nicht die Entscheidung sein, ob man dann feststellt, jetzt haben sie aber gelogen, jetzt müssen sie ihre ganze Biografie bitte mal neu schreiben, weil sie nicht Mittwoch von 10-12 Uhr mit ihren Mitarbeitern telefoniert haben.
Nur würde das dann nicht bedeuten, dass man von diesem Girl-Boss-Ding runterkommen muss, dass man halt, es ist alles kein Gegensatz, sie schafft das wunderbar und ich mach noch drei weitere Ministerien, wenn's sein muss. Und wir haben ja dann eine ganz klare Trennung, also die Trennung war ja da, wie auch bei anderen Politikerpaaren. Die Männer bleiben zu Hause, also das ist ja das umgedrehte Verhältnis von dem, wie früher Politik stattfand, Helmut Kohl macht Politik, Hannelore ist zu Hause. Jetzt hat man das umgedreht und dass man aber das dann trotzdem auch noch thematisiert, indem man sagt, ja, aber das ist alles trotzdem nicht so, als hätte man keine Kinder. Und das ist ja auch etwas, was aber dann in einer anderen Weise vorgetragen werden muss, wie, ja, das ist alles gar kein Gegensatz. Also ich kann ja auch nicht sagen, ich bin eigentlich, wenn ich jetzt mich entscheide, Marathon zu laufen, das ist kein Gegensatz zu dem, was ich tue. Doch, das ist ein Gegensatz zu dem, was ich tue. Und dann kostet das einfach mehr Zeit. Und dann werde ich irgendetwas, zum Beispiel so viel lesen oder so viel ins Kino gehen, nicht mehr machen können. Das kann ich dann thematisieren. Aber ich kann nicht behaupten, das ist kein Gegensatz. Dann ist mir irgendwo Zeit geschenkt worden. Das wüsste ich nicht.
Genau, es gibt einiges über Arbeit und über Familie, immer im Gleichschritt zu sagen.
Und das gilt im gleichen Maße ja, weil wir sprechen jetzt über eine Ministerin, aber das würde im gleichen Maße ja für die Männer gelten, die ja auch jetzt vermutlich zum allergrößten Teil der Politik, wenn sie Kinder haben, noch so Politik machen, dass man irgendwie mal samstags die Kinder mal kurz auf den Arm nimmt. Aber eigentlich ist man natürlich Politiker und unterwegs.
Ich strapaziere uns jetzt noch mal ein bisschen, in dem ich nicht nur jetzt Jule Lobo gehört, sondern jetzt kommt Richard-David Precht und Markus Lanz aus ihrem Podcast. Die haben jetzt in der aktuellen Folge nochmal, finde ich auch interessant, über Arbeit gesprochen. Precht hat ja gerade dieses Arbeitsbuch, das er jetzt im März publiziert. Ich finde es ziemlich gut, wie die beiden hier reden.
Ich meine, du bist jemand, der sich wie wenige andere mit zum Beispiel Arbeit beschäftigt. Wir definieren uns ja, ich habe im Vorfeld auf dieses Gespräch ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht, wir definieren uns ja wahnsinnig über Arbeit. Arbeit ist eigentlich die sinnstiftende Sache überhaupt in unserem Leben. Neben Familie, Privat und so weiter, aber die Arbeit... In den privilegierteren Berufen. Nicht in allen. Bin ich bei dir? Es geht um ein Gefühl, es geht um das Gefühl, gebraucht zu werden. Wir haben uns so viele Gedanken gemacht über Ausbeutung bei Arbeit. Was ist ungerecht? Was ist verhältnismäßig? Was ist ein gerechter Lohn? Und all diese Dinge. Aber wir haben doch jetzt, und ich glaube oder frage mich, ist das das Gefühl, dass viele Leute haben, Stichwort Digitalisierung, Stichwort Roboter, Stichwort die Frage, eine deiner Thesen. Und darüber sollten wir wirklich mal ausführlich sprechen. Geht uns die Arbeit sozusagen irgendwann aus? Werden Menschen nicht mehr gebraucht? Du hast es doch jetzt mit etwas Neuem zu tun. Nämlich mit der Angst, überflüssig zu werden. Und das ist doch etwas, von dem ich glaube, Menschen spüren sowas instinktiv. Dass wir genau in eine solche Phase eintreten. Und ich frage mich, ob möglicherweise genau da, auch an dem Punkt, einer der Gründe für diesen Frust und für diese Ängstlichkeit liegt. Und diese Art und Weise, dann aggressiv in die Welt reinzuschauen, weil man merkt, das funktioniert alles nicht mehr, so wie wir das mal hatten.
So, in diesem neueren Podcast, kommen Sie noch mal drauf zu sprechen, weil Brecht sagt, er privilegiert den Berufen, stimmt das, die sind so sim-stiftend usw. Aber das geht halt nur für 15%. Alle anderen sind so nah am Deplorables.
Schicksal.
Obwohl ich da auch immer wieder fragen würde, ist das nicht auch seine Perspektive darauf, weil ich mich ja schwer reinversetzen kann in sehr andere Berufe. Also das ist ja eine Abstraktionsleistung, die ganz schwer zu vollbringen ist. Also wir sind immer sehr schnell dabei und gehen dann auf so ein paar Berufe, die scheiß Jobs sind, in dem Sinne, dass sie zwar wichtig sind, aber richtig schlecht bezahlt werden. Und dann gibt es noch dieses Phänomen der Bullshit-Jobs. Das haben wir auch schon im Salon besprochen. Und dann frage ich mich aber bei Jobs, die für mich nicht nachvollziehbar sind. Ich will jetzt mal nämlich zwei Jobs nennen, die gut Geld einbringen, weil man redet dann immer über Jobs, die ganz wenig einbringen und so was. Aber ich rede mal über Jobs, die sehr viel Geld einbringen, die für mich überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbar sind. Steuerberater. Niemals würde ich das machen. Niemals. Oder Facharzt, die in der MRTs auswerten und dann sagen, ja, da muss eine Spritze ins Knie. Das ist auch für mich eine Sache. Und ich rede jetzt ein bisschen dispektierlich darüber, aber das sind beide, braucht man, ganz wichtig. Und dennoch ist das für mich persönlich nicht nachvollziehbar, wie man eine Leidenschaft da reinbringt. Ich befürchte nur, oder was heißt ich hoffe, wahrscheinlich werden die das ähnlich über das sagen, was ich tue. Und die haben sich ja auch dafür entschieden, dass wenn ja leider blieb nichts anderes übrig, ich bin Steuerberater geworden. Die jetzt auch wahnsinnig viel Geld haben. Ich habe schon den Eindruck, dass die Leute das gerne machen. Ich habe also nicht den Eindruck, wenn ich mit meiner Steuerberaterin rede, dass ich es mit einem unglücklichen Menschen zu tun habe. Insofern würde ich das erstmal in Frage stellen. Und das zweite, was angesprochen wird, diese Idee der Überflüssigkeit, das ist eigentlich ein nuller Jahre Diskurs, wo das mit der hohen Arbeitslosigkeit und diesem Niedriglohnsektor, der geschaffen wurde, so aussah. Aber die Sache ist doch jetzt die, dass wir es mit einer Investen, mit einer Arbeiterlosigkeit zu tun haben, auf Dauer haben werden, egal wie die Digitalisierung da fortschreitet, all diese wichtigen Jobs, die kommen werden, für die Familien, dafür dann auch, dass jemand wie Anne Spiegel nicht in Urlaub fahren müsste, weil jemand mitkommt und so. Fehlen Leute ohne Ende. Also ich glaube, dass diese ganze These der Automatisierung, die die Arbeitsplätze verschwinden lässt, nicht stimmt. Wir haben auch schon mal über dieses Buch von Ben Annaf gesprochen und konnten ihm zustimmen. Aber ich glaube, wenn man es jetzt auch nochmal zuspitzt auf die globale Krisen, der wir uns befinden, dann ist Arbeitslosigkeit hier nicht unser Thema. Es gibt diese Massenarbeitslosigkeit im Süden, aber die hat nichts mit technischem Fortschritt zu tun, sondern da gibt es eine strukturell falsche Politik, die mit EU und so weiter zusammenhängt.
Genau, das stimmt. Dieses ist ja von Harari, dieses Deplorables-Ding, wo es so richtig übertreibt, finde ich auch. Da ist dann recht auch nicht einverstanden. Ich ausnahmsweise mal auch nicht mit so einer Idee, denn wir sehen an der demografischen Wende auch in Amerika, es fehlen ja weiterhin 12 Millionen Mitarbeiter, die nicht wieder aus der Corona-Pandemie zurückkamen, weil sie sich fragen, wozu eigentlich. Ich habe mich jetzt irgendwie zu Hause eingelebt und das bisschen Geld, was ich dann mehr verdiene. Also haben jetzt Truckerfahrer und so weiter sehr viel mehr Macht, die sie gar nicht organisieren müssen, sondern dann alleine, weil sie gefragt werden, können sie einfach sagen, ja, ich will aber doppelt so viel verdienen. Und dann wird dem auch stattgegeben, weil sie dann doch mal durchkalkuliert haben, wie viel sie eigentlich wert sind. Also da ist vieles in Bewegung, das dem Trend so ein bisschen entgegengeht. Aber auch wenn man gute Arbeit, also Arbeit hat, die gut bezahlt wird, heißt das ja trotzdem. Das Prekariats-Ding, die Perspektivlosigkeit im Sinne von Sinnstiffen der Tätigkeit, das ist acht Stunden am Tag, die bleibt ja trotzdem.
Und das geht nur mit einer Arbeitszeitverkürzung. Und das sind auch Leute, deswegen hat mich das auch so in gewisser Weise wütend gemacht, weil es gab ja einige Politiker, wo jetzt rausgekommen ist, dann sind sie da in Urlaub und so weiter. Die, die richtig straucheln mussten und die auch noch die ganze Zeit den Kopf hingehalten haben, die nämlich gearbeitet haben da draußen, die nicht im Homeoffice sitzen konnten und die dann noch angemotzt worden sind von irgendwelchen Twitter-User, die haben ja die Maske nicht richtig auf, die bekommen natürlich jetzt nochmal so eine Ohrfeige, sie sagen, na klar, Boris Johnson hat gefeiert, die waren im Urlaub und, und, und, über die Fernsehstudios haben wir ja schon gesprochen und das ist, also finde ich, nochmal richtig hart.
Um den Diskurs nochmal aufzugreifen, hören wir mal bei Sumuncu, Serdar Sumuncu und Florian Schröder rein, weil die beiden, ich finde auch, das ist so ein bisschen neben der Spur alles.
Es gibt viele andere Familien, die in ähnlichen Krisensituationen sind und da nimmt man nicht mal eben zwei Ministerämte parallel an und sagt, okay, gib mir das Amt, der Rest ist mir egal, ob ich es schaffe oder nicht, das kann ich ja dann später gucken. Also großes politisches Versagen und eine längst überfällige Konsequenz und leider sich selbst den Hunden zum Phras vorgeworfen, denn die Opposition profitiert jetzt davon, weil sie ihr Bild einer korrupten Politikerin bestätigt sieht.
Ich habe im Hinterkopf so eine Idee von jemanden, wie Anne Spiegel, tritt in 20 Jahren vor die Kamera und sagt, es tut mir leid, dass ich in den Urlaub gefahren bin, so wie sie das jetzt auch sagt. Es war ein Fehler, dass wir in den Urlaub gefahren sind und wann wir in den Urlaub gefahren sind. Genau das hat sie ja gesagt. Und dann aber sagt, um meiner politischen Verantwortung gerecht zu werden, habe ich mich von meiner Familie getrennt. Es ist aber alles geregelt, das Ministergehalt ist ja da und so. Die Kinder müssten zum Beispiel nicht, das war ja für sie auch das Spiegel-Spitzen-Gespräch im Februar, da können wir gleich nochmal reingucken. Da hat sie Markus Feldenkirchen erzählt, wie kompliziert es war, in Berlin eine Wohnung zu finden für vier Kinder. Aber es hat dann geklappt, der zweite Versuch war dann schon ein Treffer, weil du natürlich mit so einem Ministergehalt das einfach machen kannst. Da frage ich mich, wie viel hätte man noch machen können mit einem modernen Ministerium, das auch mal so ein bisschen Arbeit auf Abstand erlaubt, gleichzeitig sie komplett in die Verantwortung nimmt, die politische, aber ihr eben auch die Aufgabe gibt, organisiert das Haus so, dass die Politik umgesetzt werden kann und dann trotzdem Familien leben.
Aber sie wird doch sicherlich da unterstützt werden. Also wenn ein Professor heute einen Ruf zu einer anderen Uni bekommt, dann wird er ja ein bisschen gelockt mit Geld und sonst was. Und da kommt dann, die machen die komplett den Umzug und fotografieren noch das Bücherregal so ab und bauen das eins zu eins wieder in der neuen Wohnung auf. Also ich kann mir jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass es da irgendwelche Schwierigkeiten gibt.
Genau, aber die Frage ist ja, würden wir es akzeptieren, dass eine Ministerin für Familie da steht und sagt, ich werde meiner politischen Verantwortung künftig gerecht werden. Der Urlaub war ein Fehler, weil ich die Familie entsprechend einsortiert habe in meinem Leben. Würden wir natürlich nicht. Bei uns ist ja, dass die Familie wie auch immer funktioniert primär und dann muss man es halt hinbekommen. Und das ist eben auch hier Schröder. Florian Schröder, der sagt es so.
Ja, es gibt ja mehrere Aspekte dieses Themas. Mein erster Punkt wäre, ich möchte von einer Politikerin mit derart privaten Details schlicht nicht behelligt werden. Ich möchte es nicht wissen. Ich möchte nicht wissen, ob ihr Mann einen Schlaganfall hatte, tragisch wenn es so war. Ich möchte nicht wissen, ob sie mit vier Kindern im Lockdown kaum klarkamen, ob es anstrengend war. Das betrifft andere Familien auch, die nicht Ministerin sind. Ich will auch nicht wissen, wie viele Ämter sie gleichzeitig angenommen hat, weil sie offenbar glaubte, alles zu können. Phasenweise sogar Familien- und Umweltministerium in Rheinland-Pfalz. Plus Spitzenkandidatur. Da sage ich jetzt mal ganz kalt, eine Politikerin oder ein Politiker, der das alles auf sich nimmt, der hat es zu wuppen. Punkt. Ohne wenn das nicht hinkriegt, kriegt das nicht hin.
Also darf das private politisch werden? Das war ja die Forderung der 68er. Ich bin ja auch immer sehr dagegen, dass man mit privatistischen Angelegenheiten behelligt wird in der Form, dass ich nicht alles wissen muss. Und ich bin heute froh, wenn auch schon mal jemand eine CD veröffentlicht, ohne einen seelensstripti in den Podcast hinzulegen. Aber ich würde jetzt gerade hier, wo das politische und das private so eng miteinander gekoppelt sind, sagen, ja, dann muss das in einer anderen Art nicht nur kommuniziert werden, sondern auch das muss auch überführt werden in eine andere Politik. Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht nur, wie kann man Ministern das Leben besser machen. Ich würde sagen, denen geht es schon wahnsinnig gut. Also da haben ja andere ganz viel zu strauchen. Das sind ja alles Gehälter, die verdient ja kein Mensch. Also das ist ja einfach, dass man sagen muss, dann mietet euch ins beste Hotel ein und haltet den Mund. Ich mache jetzt da Krise. Also das ist ja alles für mich ein Nachvollziehbar. Aber ich glaube schon, dass man es kommunizieren könnte in einer Weise, dass man sagt, also ich will offen sein. Folgendermaßen ist das, ich würde sogar so weit gehen. Dieser Rücktritt hätte jetzt gar nicht sein gemusst. Ich glaube, sie hätte das sogar so kommunizieren können, dass sie sagt, und sie muss auch nicht ihre Familie verlassen, aber sie sagt, ich habe auch den Fehler gemacht, dass ich geglaubt habe, es gibt keine Gegensätze. Es gibt diese Gegensätze. Und ich bin jetzt mit meinem Mann übereingekommen, dass ich einfach einige Tage gar nicht erreichbar bin als Mutter und Ehefrau, sondern das da ganz mache. Und das ist ja bei anderen Berufen und gerade bei so High-Performer-Berufen, man kann mal Profimusiker oder so fragen, ist das ja ganz ähnlich. Und deswegen glaube ich, müsste das anders kommuniziert werden. Es war natürlich auch ein kommunikatives Desaster. Aber ich glaube schon, dass das politisch, dass das Private nicht so rausgetränkt werden kann. Weil wenn Florian Schröder sagt, dass das einfach funktionieren muss, dann muss man fragen, ja, aber wer macht das denn, dass es funktioniert? Und irgendjemand ist ja dann der Leidtragende des Ganzen. Und das war ja gerade auch die Lehre aus diesen ganzen tragischen Fällen, wie Hannelore Kohl und so. Da wurde nämlich eigentlich immer gesagt, ja, und der Rest musste funktionieren. Das hieß aber immer, die Frauen mussten funktionieren, der Männerweltgemäß.
Genau. Und das ist ein echtes Problem. Emanzipation wäre abgeschlossen, wenn, so wie du es eben vorgestellt hast, Anne Spiegel sagen könnte, hört mal zu, ich mache hier diese Politik wirklich aus Leidenschaft. Glaub mir das. Meine Leidenschaft ist so groß, ich habe mit meinem Mann geregelt, dass ich eine Woche des Monats wirklich nicht zur Verfügung stehe, um 24 Stunden am Tag Politik zu machen. Die Frage ist dann, unter welchen Bedingungen würden wir das so medial akzeptieren, dass sie auch dann, wenn wir das wissen, Politikerin in diesem Maße sein kann. Die Kommentare kann man sich ungefähr vorstellen. Nur ist es eben so, Florian Schröder kann sich hier wünschen, was er will. Die Corona-Pandemie war da. Für Familien mit vier Kindern war die halt nicht rauszudrängen, egal wie viel Geld und wie viel man da irgendwie investiert. Das ist halt einfach ein faktisches Problem. Wir können ja nicht alle, die öffentlich exponiert solche Jobs ausfüllen. Deswegen das Corona-Leiden besonders sichtbar nach außen bringen, aus ihrem Job raustreiben, um denen zu sagen, bleib mal für deine Familie da. Sondern da muss man irgendwie so einen Weg finden und sagen, keine Familie kriegt das so hin, wie sie sich's wünscht. Und wir können aber nicht allen, die leidenschaftlich in der Öffentlichkeit arbeiten, dann sagen, stopp hier. Weißt du, wie das für die Männer selbstverständlich ist, dass sie da einfach so... Ich meine, Annalena Baerbock macht es ja auch krass. Da ist es ja auch eine totale Selbstverständlichkeit, dass ihr Mann sich da einfach freinimmt für die Familie.
Ich denke, wir haben es ja auch mit absoluten Spitzenpositionen zu tun, wo das nochmal ganz anders ist. Das sind auch so große Lebensentscheidungen, die dann mal getroffen sind. Das ist aber vergleichbar mit einem Spitzensportler, der wird nicht sagen, ich gehe jetzt heute Abend mit dem Kumpel zum Bier trinken. Es geht halt einfach nicht. Es ist nicht möglich.
Genau, es gibt viel zu bedenken. Und wir hören nochmal in vier Clips rein. Anne Spiegel im Februar. Sie sitzt bei Feldenkirchen in diesem Spitzengespräch. Spiegel online Fernsehstudio. Und wird mal über ihre eigene Biografie gefragt. Und da finde ich, es ist wirklich schade, was an Gelegenheit jetzt einfach so nicht mehr verwirklicht wird. Klar, es steht alles im Koalitionsvertrag, was jetzt gemacht werden soll und so weiter. Aber ich hätte es doch gerne von Anne Spiegel gesehen.
Ich habe auch gelesen, Sie selber sind in einer Art WG groß geworden. Haben Sie meinen Kolleginnen und Kollegen vom Spiegel neulich gesagt. Wie sah es da aus? Was hat es zu einer WG gemacht?
Na ja, das heißt einfach, dass ich als Kind, da war ich noch relativ klein, also im Kita-Alter für ein paar Jahre, mit meiner Mutter in einer Art WG gewohnt habe, also mit einer Mitbewohnerin. Und das war für mich, aber klar, als Kind, man denkt nicht weiter drüber nach. Für mich war das selbstverständlich. Eine Mitbewohnerin. Mit der habe ich auch heute noch Kontakt. Für mich gehört sie einfach dazu zur Familie. Wir sind sehr eng miteinander. Ich glaube, das wird nicht überbewerten, dass mich das total geprägt hat. Aber natürlich ist es eine Erfahrung, die bereichert einen. Da habe ich vor allen Dingen in der Kita gemerkt, wie man dann zu Hause wohnt. Das gibt es jetzt nicht überall bei den anderen Kita-Kindern. Vor allen Dingen war das für mich normal, dass ich mit Heike auch Zeit verbringe, dass wir was unternehmen zusammen, dass sie mich auch mal aus der Kita abholt und Ähnliches.
Was für sie so normal ist, dass sie heute sogar sagt, das würde ich jetzt nicht überinterpretieren, würde ich sagen, doch, genau das muss jetzt mal so richtig in der Politik stattfinden. Das ist jetzt das Konzept der Wahlverwandtschaft. Wahlverwandtschaft, Verantwortungsgemeinschaft, wird es dann politisch nennen, es steht ja schon im Koalitionsvertrag.
Man sollte es auch nicht Wahlverwandtschaft nennen, denn bei Goethe scheitert das sehr.
Eben, da ist auch viel Drama immer angelegt, aber sie kann aus so einer positiven, biografischen Erfahrung hier daraus schöpfen und in deren Sicht, und es gibt eben wirklich noch schwierige Aufgaben zu bewältigen.
Ich möchte keiner Familie, niemandem vorschreiben, wie er oder sie ihr Familienleben zu gestalten haben.
Das ist das grüne Trauma, dass man in Verdacht geraten könnte, anderen was vorschreiben zu wollen.
Ich habe lediglich festgestellt, dass die Statistiken an der Stelle relativ eindeutig sind, sprich etwa die Hälfte der Frauen mit Familie wünschen sich mehr zu arbeiten, also im Beruf zu arbeiten. Und etwa die Hälfte der Männer wünscht sich mehr auch Arbeit im Bereich Sorgearbeit und Hausarbeit zu übernehmen. Und das passt irgendwie nicht so zusammen.
Die Hälfte der Frauen wünscht sich mehr berufliche Arbeit für sich.
Und die Hälfte der Männer sagt mehr durchaus mit den Kindern im Haushalt. Ich würde das auch so aus meinem eigenen Bekanntenkreis bestätigen wollen, dass das sehr stark in die Richtung geht.
Wir haben jetzt aber wieder einen Spiegel erlebt, wie jemand aus dieser beruflichen Arbeit einfach rausgekickelt wurde. Das ist ein echtes Drama, weil sie weiß, das betrifft die Hälfte der Frauen in ganz Deutschland, die einfach sagen, ja klar, Familie und so weiter, aber ich möchte auch arbeiten. Und sie wollte auch, und das wissen wir, wie krass sie arbeiten wollte, wie groß dieser Wunsch war. Naja, Feldenkirchen spricht sie da mal auf diese Modelle an, die jetzt im Koalitionsvertrag eben drinstehen, aber nicht mehr von ihr verwirklicht werden.
Sie haben ein Familienbild, was sich offenkundig von dem Familienbild herkömmlicher Ministerinnen und Minister unterscheidet. Sie reden von Verantwortungsgemeinschaften, von Bonuseltern. Können Sie verstehen, wenn, sagen wir mal, traditionelle Familien da das Gefühl bekommen, Ihr Lebensgefühl, Ihr Lebensentwurf, der zähle plötzlich nicht mehr ganz so viel?
Also ich glaube, ganz entscheidend ist, und da möchte ich auch nicht missverstanden werden, dass die traditionellen Familien, die traditionellen Ehen und auch mit 0, 1 oder 2 Kindern, also ich sag mal, in einer verheirateten Familie, da sollen ja keine Rechte weggenommen werden. Da soll ja nichts beschnitten werden. Darum soll es ja überhaupt nicht gehen, sondern es soll darum gehen, dass wir auch wirklich die gesellschaftliche Realität, die wir haben, stärker auch politisch und rechtlich abbilden.
Dafür bräuchten wir auch endlich mal ein Seniorenministerium zum Beispiel, denn diese Verantwortungsgemeinschaft braucht man natürlich vor allem für diese 75% allein lebenden Seniorinnen ab 75 Jahre, die sich auch einfach mal zusammentun könnten. Warum machen die keine WGs auf?
Rhetorisch ist sie ja sehr schwach auf der Brust, denn sie hätte ja das sofort kontern können. Ich lebe ja in so einer traditionellen Familie und fahre gut damit. Und ich würde ja nicht meine Familie abschaffen wollen.
Ja, also da hören wir mal diesen letzten Clip. Feldenkirchen gibt ihr so ein Freundschaftsbuch und sagt ihr dann, welche Rubriken sie da ausfüllen sollen.
Bei diesem Menschen möchte ich mich entschuldigen.
Entschuldigen? Eigentlich bei meinem Mann, weil er doch ganz schön viel auffangen muss. Die letzten Wochen waren auch hart.
Und was er noch nicht weiß, die nächsten werden nicht besser?
Ja, genau.
Was war denn so hart daran?
Na ja, wir waren ja getrennt als Familie. Ich war hier in Berlin, und die Kinder und mein Mann waren in Rhein und Pfalz. Das ist natürlich schon eine ganze Ecke weg. Und da kann man nicht mal zwischendurch zur Unterstützung vorbeikommen. Und ja, ich glaube, das ist jetzt gut, dass wir alle zusammen sind als Familie.
Ja, jetzt leben sie in Berlin. Ohne Grund haben sie die Heimat verlassen.
Ja, da ist es in Rhein und Pfalz schöner.
Ja, es ist einfach, ich finde es ein ganz brutales Schicksal, gerade für eine Familienministerin.
Ja, ja. Also ich will jetzt auch nicht da den Stab über ihr brechen. Da haben wir ganz andere schon in der Politik erlebt. Nur glaube ich, ist es so interessant, dass es auch nicht auf eine andere Ebene in der Kommunikation bei ihr gekommen ist, aber auch nicht von jenen, die es kommentieren. Und das wird sich jetzt wiederholen. Also solche Schicksale werden wir jetzt noch einige Male. Vielleicht Ende der 20er wird das dann schon von Anfang an anders kommuniziert werden. Möglicherweise, ja, man wird sehen. Aber ich glaube, dass man ganz klar nicht mehr dieses, es gibt keine Gegensätze, sondern man muss diese Gegensätze betonen und dann aber auch sagen, wo Prioritäten liegen. Und das kann man auch, glaube ich, sehr gut abstecken, wo man das macht. Und was ist denn eigentlich dann für einen wirklich das Leben? Was ist das Privatleben oder was sind auch da lästige Pflichten, die nicht unbedingt so zu verhandeln sind, dass man sagt, ach ja, jetzt habe ich Freizeit? Also für mich gibt es auch so ein paar Verwandtschaftstermine, irgendwelche Feiern, wo ich mich schon dabei ertappt habe, dass ich mir da extra einen Vortrag auf diesen Tag lege und dann sage, ach, ich wäre ja so gerne gekommen. Aber ich muss leider diesen Vortrag halten. Die Wahrheit ist natürlich, ich genieße es, den Vortrag zu halten. Und für mich wäre das jetzt schlimme Arbeit, wenn ich vier Stunden auf dieser Feier sitzen möchte.
Ja, also in dieser Verantwortungsgemeinschaft stecken so Synergieeffekte drin, die für alle so neue Räume ermöglichen. Bonus Eltern ist jetzt schon sehr konkret. Aber weil es dann so um Erwachsene, die für Kinder da sind, die aber nicht der eigene Kinder sind, das braucht man, also man braucht auch, was weiß ich, Bonus Freunde oder so, wo man so zusammenlebt. Aber das wirklich als Zweck, wie ich gehe. Wir sind nicht immer so badiburgtisch, wir haben es auch immer gut verstanden, also machen wir jetzt auch WG und so, sondern wo es einfach mal so ein paar Synergieeffekte gibt. Und Familien brauchen halt auch wieder so ein, das ganze Dorf muss irgendwie da sein, um ein Kind zu erziehen. Das kann man natürlich viel über Sportvereine, die Schule hilft und so. Aber ich bin jetzt mal sehr gespannt, was diese Koalition da gerade auf die Reihe kriegt. Das ist sehr anspruchsvoll. Und man hat jetzt an ihr gesehen, wie wenig bereit die Gesellschaft ist, die Realität, die ja da ist, dann auch einfach mal in Worte zu fassen. Und eben in so einem Podcast nicht irgendwas von Work-Live-Balance oder sonst irgendwas, sondern mal ganz konkret sich den Einzelfall anzuschauen und zu sehen, ey, an den Spiegel rauszunehmen. Mit so viel Engagement. Ich meine, wir brauchen ja auch Politiker, die bereit sind, 20 Stunden am Tag zu arbeiten, wenn es drauf ankommt und so. Und zuerst hat sie die Familie rausgenommen und jetzt hat sie die Gesellschaft aussortiert. Und das ist schon wirklich schade.
Ich frage mich bei diesen Sachen ja häufig, denn wir haben ja so viele CDU-Politiker, die es einfach ausgesessen haben, ob nicht immer so übertrieben wird in der Schnelligkeit. Also es gibt dann gerade diesen unglaublichen medialen Shitstorm gegen eine Ahnenspiegel. Und seien wir mal ehrlich, jetzt haben wir uns schon fast nur noch dunkel dran erinnert. Es ist schon wieder zweieinhalb Wochen her. Ach ja, das war das und das. Wir wissen schon gar nicht mehr diese einzelnen Vorwürfe, von wem die jetzt kamen. Und da frage ich mich, ob nicht auch, da manche Leute zwar dieses Bekenntnis ablegen müssen, auch das, sagen wir einmal, etwas angespannte Verhältnis zur Wahrheit, das da ja tatsächlich zu beobachten war. Und dass man aber trotzdem sagt, aber ich will das jetzt hier weitermachen, gib mir noch eine Chance, ich trete jetzt mal nicht zurück. Wie wir das im Übrigen ja auch sonst ganz viel machen. Also auch beim Job wird man nicht sofort gekündigt, sondern man kriegt eine Abmahnung und dann braucht man ein paar dafür. Im privaten Kreise ist es auch so, dass man nicht mit einem Mal, es sei denn, es ist wirklich was ganz, ganz Schlimmes passiert, dass man dann mit einem Mal mit jemandem bricht. Also da frage ich mich auch, ob das nicht anders ginge. Also da hat sich ja, ist es vollkommen logisch, dass es jetzt nicht so sein soll, naja, die CDU hat das so gemacht, jetzt müsst ihr mal lernen, wie die CDU zu werden. Nee, man könnte es ja viel offener kommunizieren. Also es ist ja nicht so, also Andi Scheuer hat ja nie einen Fehler zugegeben, sondern der hat einfach immer gesagt, ich mach doch alles richtig, die Kanzlerin hat es auch nochmal gesagt. Aber hier könnte man ja sagen, ja, das war definitiv falsch, aber ich mache ja jetzt auch nichts mehr richtig, indem ich zurücktrete. Also das ist für mich immer so, wenn damit jetzt was geschützt wird für Künftiges oder Gegenwertiges, kann ich das verstehen. Aber jetzt zu sagen, ja wisst ihr da, ich war da übrigens Ministerin in Rheinland-Pfalz, das wisst ihr im meisten in Deutschland eh nicht, ich war ja nicht in Rheinland-Pfalz gelebt. Und da war Folgendes mit der Flut, das ist für mich tatsächlich viel Virtues Signaling, was aber eigentlich nicht besonders effektiv ist. Und wahrscheinlich hätte sie jetzt gerade mit diesem Bekenntnis und mit dieser Erfahrung eigentlich die Glaubwürdigkeit erhöhen können. Also das ist für mich eine ganz heikte Sache. Man hatte immer diese Idee, wenn jemand weg ist, dann ist wieder irgendwie eine Reinheit im System geschaffen. Aber nein, das System an sich ist nicht ganz sauber. Und der Glaube, man könnte das immer wieder so wie ein Schreibtisch aufräumen, und dann ist alles sauber. Das ist nicht der Fall. Sondern wir bekommen neue Akteure und die werden auch wieder irgendwas. Von daher ist eigentlich diese Art des Bekenntnisses, und auch ganz klar nicht nur von Fehlern, sondern auch davon zu sprechen, dass man da nicht ehrlich war, eigentlich wieder eine Möglichkeit, wie ein Zusammenleben, auch ein politisches Zusammenleben, möglich sein könnte. Ja, sehr schade. Es ist ein sehr eigenartiger Fall. Ich würde aber die Prognose wagen, in den Neuen Zwanzigern werden wir Anne Spiegel nochmal wieder sehen in irgendeiner Form. Es sei denn, sie ist jetzt so sehr davon getroffen, dass sie sich in privatwirtschaftliche Gefilde begibt. Wir werden sehen. Wir kommen nicht mehr zu dem Thema Hunger, das wir auch noch angedacht haben, weil es doch schon sehr fortgeschritten ist in der Zeit. Wir müssen noch ganz kurz sprechen Salon. Wir haben es schon gesagt. Also das Ende des Endes der Geschichte werden wir besprechen. Außerdem das Buch Die Zukunft des Luxus. Und ich werde noch einen Liebesroman mitbringen, der furios ist von Madame Nielsen. So nennt sich die Schriftstellerin, die ein ganz ungewöhnliches Leben geführt hat. Die hat nämlich ihre Familie verlassen, als sie noch ein Mann war, hat dann in Obdachlosigkeit gelebt und sich dann vollkommen neu erfunden und ist als Madame Nielsen dann auf der Bildfläche erschienen. Und wir wollen über diesen Text sprechen, aus den Blättern, den will ich mitbringen, was da so ein Chefideologe von Putin sich über die Ukraine so herbeifantasiert. Sehr erschreckend. Und wir müssen nochmal dieses Thema Pazifismus in wie weit sollte man einschreiten und so aufgreifen. Denn Habermas, ich habe es noch nicht gelesen, aber ich würde ihn mitbringen, hat heute in der Süddeutschen Zeitung einen großen Essay dazu veröffentlicht. Ist jetzt der Pazifismus passé? Muss der passé sein? Was kann man tun? Und das andere halte ich mir immer noch offen.
Genau, ich gehe meine Liste nur kurz durch. A long walk in a fading corner of Japan. Also Japan ist ja wirklich, ich habe es noch nicht gelesen, aber da verschwinden ja jetzt wirklich Städte einfach. Da wird nochmal so ein Löwe aus Papa auf die Straße gestellt, um die Bären zu verjagen, damit die letzten Einwohner dort nicht von der Natur sofort überrumpelt werden. Also es ist wirklich schlimm. Dann Vanity Fair hat sich nochmal die neue Rechte jetzt gerade angeguckt, wo Peter Thiel, kommt auch gleich in der Überschrift vor, Peter Thiel nochmal seine größte Wette eingeht. Also mal gucken, meine Reading-App sagt hier, wenn ich das lese, dauert das 43 Minuten, also es scheint da einiges drin zu stecken. Und ja, mal gucken, kleines Snippet hier. Sehr viel weniger Menschen überweisen Geld an die Bundesregierung auf ein speziell eingerichtetes Konto zum Schuldentilgen.
Weniger.
Es gibt ein Konto für die Bundes...
Ja, das weiß ich. Und es gibt zum Beispiel den Literaturwissenschaftler Jochen Hörisch, der hat da mal 10.000 Euro überwiesen, weil er offenbar das mit den Schulden nicht so ganz verstanden hat und glaubte, was Gutes zu tun. Und jetzt sind es weniger.
Im vergangenen Jahr haben 236 Leute 63.088 Euro überwiesen.
Ja, vielleicht haben die dann doch mal was von der MMT mitbekommen.
Die höchste Einzelspende 25.000 Euro.
Wenn man wirklich... Also, da weiß ich gar nicht, was man machen soll.
Es ist grotesk.
Das ist wie die... Ich hab's in so einer Comedy-Show gesehen, wie die Amerikaner, die Trump-Anhänger, die glauben, dass Biden gespielt wird von Schauspielern. Unter anderem war dann eine Dame da, die sagte, ja... Ich glaube zum Beispiel, es sind mehrere Schauspieler, die tragen eine Biden-Maske und spielen den. Und ein Schauspieler sei Jim Carrey. Das hätte man daran gemerkt, weil Biden doch dann mal so das Flugzeug hochgestolpert ist. Und das sei bestimmt Jim Carrey. Aber ich würde sagen, dieser Nonsens ist nicht weit davon entfernt, von dem zu sagen, ich überweise ein paar Tausend Euro der Bundesregierung zur Tilgung der Schulden. Also das, bitte, macht niemand. Ich bringe jetzt mal noch einen schönen melancholischen Clip zum Abschied. Wir haben ja schon Georg Stefan Troller gehört. Und er wird am Ende dieses Interviews dann noch mal so ganz persönlich gefragt, weil er das auch immer gemacht hat. Wie es denn mit der Liebe sei. Und das hören wir uns noch an. Denn hier spricht jetzt ein 100-Jähriger. Der kann natürlich nichts mehr rückgängig machen. Aber wir, die etwas jünger sind, können natürlich auch ganz anders gestalten. Und wir wissen noch nicht das, was Troller weiß. Aber vielleicht können wir irgendwie dieses Wissen antizipieren. Wir hören also diesen Clip zum Schluss.
Sie haben ja mal eine große Reportage gemacht. Sie haben gesagt, es ist eine Liebe in Hollywood. Sie haben gezeigt, wie oberflächlich so etwas sein kann. Haben Sie das andere erlebt, nämlich das wirklich Essenzielle an Liebe?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich so eine Frage beantworten kann. Ich bin dem ziemlich nahe gekommen. Hätte ich damals gewusst, was ich heute weiß, wäre ich der Sache noch näher gekommen. Ich hätte das alles besser machen können.
Machts gut, machts besser, einen schönen Monat und wir sehen uns im Salon.